ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND AND TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
MUSIC HAS A WAY OF TRANSCENDING
LANGUAGE AND CULTURE.
IT IS UNIVERSAL.
AND IT CAN BE TIRELESSLY
MAGICAL.
MUSIC IS ALSO A MIRROR.
REFLECTING THE TIMES IN WHICH WE
ARE LIVING.
LAST THURSDAY AUGUST SIXTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THE
WORLD LOST A VISIONARY VOICE.
THAT HELPED REFLECT THE
TUMULTUOUS YET DEEPLY HOPEFUL
TIMES OF MY HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE YEARS IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
THROUGH THE YEARS ARETHA
FRANKLIN REMINDED US TO VALUE
LIFE.
THERE WE ARE NOT ALONE IN
EXPERIENCING THE FULFILMENT AND
THE HEARTBREAK OF LOVE.
AND ALSO THAT IN LIVING LIFE WE
MUST ALL KNOW DEEP.
THE PAIN OF LOSS.
OF ARETHA FRANKLIN I FEEL BARACK
AND MICHELLE OBAMA SPOKE FOR ALL
OF US IN SAYING. FOR MORE THAN
SIX DECADES EVERYTIME SHE SANG.
WE WERE ALL GRACED WITH A
GLIMPSE OF THE DIVINE. TO HER
COMPOSITIONS AND UNMATCHED
MUSICIANSHIP.
ARETHA HELP DEFINE THE AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE.
IN HER VOICE WE COULD FEEL OUR
HISTORY.
ALL OF IT AND IN EVERY SHADE.
OUR POWER AND OUR PAIN.
OUR DARKNESS AND OUR LIFE.
OUR QUEST FOR REDEMPTION AND OUR
HARD WON RESPECT.
SHE HELPED US FEEL MORE
CONNECTED TO EACH OTHER.
MORE WHOLE.
MORE HUMAN.
TIMES HE HELPED US JUST FORGET
ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE AND DANCE
[inaudible]
SO CHIU.
WHEN A BABY IS BORN?
ONLY THE BABY CRY.
WHEN ONE HAS LIVED THEIR LIFE
TRULY WELL?
WHEN THEIR LIFE ENDS MANY WILL
CRY?
BUT OUR TEARS OF SADNESS ARE
ALSO.
ACCUSED OF LOVE AND
APPRECIATION.
LET US TRY TO LIVE OUR LIVES
WELL.
AND EARNED SUCH TEARS OF
LOBBYING GRATITUDE.
NOW MORE MEET UP.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTSAND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GABRIEL.
PLEASE PLACE YOUR RIGHT HAND
OVER YOUR HEART READY BEGAN I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JULY 262018%
OF PROVISIONS OF TITLE FIFTY
NINE THE FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY
JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN REGULAR SESSION WAS
PRINTED WHILE THE ASSEMBLY WITH
IN SUMMER RECESS.
THE BOWLING COMMUNICATIONS
REPRESENTED BY THE SPEAKER IN
ORDER MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND
MS BAKER SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SITTING.
KILEY AND O'DONNELL TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS EGGMAN BONTA IT
WATER EDUARDO GARCIA PATTERSON
WEBER BAKER IN LIMON TO SPEAK ON
INJURED.
AND WE TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM THREE EIGHTY SEVEN SB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR SKINNER BY
RUBIO.
ITEM THREE EIGHTY SIX S. B.
ELEVEN ON NINE BY BATES
[inaudible]
ITEM. THREE NINETY SIX SP
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HERNANDEZ.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
PLEASE RETURN ITEM TO THIRTEEN
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
THURMOND TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO WAY
TO FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE TO HEAR A BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTY FIVE THURMOND.
ON WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY
SECOND ONE THIRTY PM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
ENACT A FILE.
ITEM NUMBER TO THIRTY SIX ACR OF
TWO FIFTY THREE KILEY AN ITEM
TWO NINETY S. B. FIFTEEN TEN
GOVERNMENT A FINE GOVERNOR STATE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE OTHERS I'M
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE.
ITEM A THIRTY AB TWENTY THREE A
THREE THURMAN ITEM A FORTY TWO
S. B. FIVE THIRTY TWO DODD ITEM
A FORTY FOUR S. B. TEN FIFTY
FOUR HERTZBERG.
AN ITEM A FORTY THREE SB TEN
FIFTY ONE DOT.
THE CLERK WILL ALSO KNOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER S. B. A FORTY FOUR
SB FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR MINING.
FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY A SIXTY
TWO EIGHT THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO ADD THE FOLLOWING
TRIBAL CONTACTS TO THEIR
HEARING.
NOTICE FOR WITH THIS WEDNESDAY
AUGUST TWENTY SECOND.
THE BIG VALLEY BAND OF POMO
INDIANS OF THE BIG VALLEY
RANCHERIA.
THE HOW THE MOTTO LOW POMO OF
UPPER LAKE AND THE TOWARDS
MARTINEZ BAND OF CAHUILLA
INDIANS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
MEMBERS OF I COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY WE ALSO HAVE A
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TANG FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR A VERY
SPECIAL PRESENTATION MEMBERS WE
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE MR
TANG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
VERY HONORED TO RISE TODAY IN
THE HOUSE.
OF THE ASSEMBLY TO RECOGNIZE ONE
OF SACRAMENTO IN OUR CAPITALS --
BEST PUBLIC SERVANTS AND THAT'S
MAC TAYLOR WHO AS OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HAS SERVED
--
THIS LEGISLATURE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE LAST TEN OF
WHICH HE WAS OUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S --
HE HAS BEEN HE'S HAD A
REMARKABLE TENURE OF THE LAST
TEN YEARS OF REALLY --
WORKING VERY HARD STAFF MAKING
SURE THAT THE ANALYTICS OF THE
DATA HAVE BEEN AS RESPONSIVE TO
US AS COULD BE POSSIBLE.
AND SOMEONE WHO HAS JUST LED AN
EXEMPLARY CAREER --
IN SACRAMENTO HE IS A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN BORN SINGER
CALIFORNIA WHICH I DIDN'T KNOW
TAUGHT WAS READ THE FILE.
SO THE CENTRAL CENTRAL VALLEY
GUY.
AND DOWN YOU KNOW REALLY IS
CREDITED WITH CENTURY WITH THIS
TECHNOLOGY ITS REPORTS --
WE OBVIOUSLY ARE VERY VERY SAD
TO SEE HIM GO BIRD AFTER --
YOU KNOW THIRTY YEARS OF SERVICE
WE CAN HARDLY BLAME HIM THEY ARE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATIVE FOR ALL
THE TIME THAT HE SACRIFICED FOR
THIS GREAT STATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ALSO
APPRECIATIVE VERY MUCH FOR HIS
FAMILY FOR ALLOWING HIM TO DO
THAT SACRIFICE SO WITH THAT I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
I'D LIKE TO JOIN IN THINKING OF
MAC TAYLOR FOR AN INCREDIBLY
DISTINGUISHED CAREER OF
EXCELLENCE IN SERVICE TO THIS
INSTITUTION.
I IN YOUR SHOES SERVER ARE GOING
TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO FILL.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU READ.
THE RESOLUTION BUT MAC HAS SERVE
THE LAST TEN YEARS OR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S BUT HE
SERVED IN THE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOR THIRTY YEARS BEFORE THAT
SIXTEEN YEARS AS DEPUTY ANALYST.
SO I CAN'T THINK OF VERY MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE AS
IMPRESSIVE A CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
INSTITUTION AND TO THE
LEGISLATION WE PASSED AS YOU AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YOUR MANY YEARS OF SERVICE
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
RETIREMENT
TRY IT AGAIN HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE MISTER
O'DONNELL FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR THE CHAMBER MISS YOUR
O'DONNELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THERE SHE IS.
OKAY I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
HONOR ONE OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
MOST BELOVED EMPLOYEES
[inaudible]
FRANCIE RUPERT'S.
WHO IS RETIRING THIS YEAR AFTER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF QUALITY
AND CABLE SERVICE TO THIS
ASSEMBLY?
FRANCIA SERVED AS THE SECRETARY
OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR OVER TWENTY THREE
YEARS.
PROVIDING OUTSTANDING SERVICE TO
NINE DIFFERENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMITTEE CHAIR TRAFFIC MAJOR
FROM THE ALL VERY DIFFERENT --
ALL ALL WHO WORK WITH FRANCIE
ARE STRUCK BY HER WARMTH AND
POSITIVE ATTITUDE.
TOWARDS COLLEAGUES AND VISITORS
ALIKE AND I CAN ATTEST THAT YOU
ALWAYS SEE FRANCE YOU WITH A
SMILE ALWAYS A WARM GREETING SHE
IS A BEAUTIFUL PERSON NO DOUBT.
FRANCIE PERVERTED PERSONIFIES
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND ADVOCATES
CANNOT IMAGINE THE COMMITTEE
WITHOUT HER I CAN'T IMAGINE THE
COMMITTEE WITHOUT HER.
WE WISH FRANCIE WELL AS SHE
EMBARKS ON HER RETIREMENT.
SHE'S PLANS TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH HER FAMILY WHO I BELIEVE
ARE HERE TODAY THERE THEY ARE.
OHIO AND UP PURSUE HER MANY
INTERESTS INCLUDING RUNNING
HIKING AND CRAFT PROJECTS AND I
ALSO THINK SMILING AND MAKING I
FEEL LOVED.
HER MANY FRIENDS IN AND AROUND
THE CAPITAL GREATLY MISS HER I
WILL MISS HER THIS BODY WILL
MISS HER I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING MISS
FRANCIE RUPERT FOR HER EXEMPLARY
SERVICE TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
WISHING HER WELL ON HER MUCH.
DESERVED RETIREMENT.
GIVER HAVE
TO GET MEMBERS IF WE
COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION AND
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRAZIER AND
KILEY.
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER WILL BEGIN WITH MISTER
KILEY MISTER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
CONGRATULATE ERIC LAYING ON HIS
RETIREMENT TODAY AND THANK HIM
FOR HIS MANY YEARS OF SERVICE TO
THIS BODY.
ERIC IS A NATIVE OF ALAMEDA AND
A CURRENT RESIDENT OF EL DORADO
HILLS IN THE SIX ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
HE RECEIVED HIS ECONOMICS DEGREE
FROM UC BERKELEY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE AND HIS LAW DEGREE
FROM UC DAVIS IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ERICA SERVED
IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS THOUGH HE JUST TOLD
ME IT FEELS LIKE YOU JUST WALKED
IN THE DOOR --
YESTERDAY GETTING AS A
CONSULTANT IN THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE OVER THE
YEARS IS DEVELOPED EXTENSIVE
EXPERTISE IN TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AND AS LONG MANY GO TO
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT ON
HIGHWAYS VEHICLES RAILROADS IN
MASS TRANSIT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE ERIC
BEGIN WORKING FOR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL IN THE BUSINESS
INSURANCE AND HEALTH INSURANCE.
AREAS AND LATER IN
TRANSPORTATION AND AIR RESOURCES
MOST RECENTLY HE ACCEPTED A
TEMPORARY ASSIGNMENT AS THE
PRINCIPAL DEPUTY SUPERVISING THE
TRANSPORTATION THEIR RESOURCES
AND HIGHER EDUCATION AREAS.
IN ADDITION TO HIS PROFESSIONAL
INTEREST IN TRANSPORTATION
ERIKA'S HIMSELF TRAVELLED TO
MORE THAN FIFTY COUNTRIES
INCLUDING TWENTY SIX TRIPS TO
EUROPE.
HE'S DRIVEN A CAR IN ALL FIFTY
STATES HE'S TRAVELED ON
VIRTUALLY THE ENTIRE AMTRAK
NATIONAL SYSTEM HAS GONE CAMPING
IN THIRTY STATES ON FIVE
CONTINENTS HAS VISITED THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTEEN UNITS.
OF THE NATIONAL PARK SYSTEM HAS
BEEN TO TWENTY FIVE STATE
CAPITALS END TO THE HIGHEST
POINTS IN NINETEEN STATES
INCLUDING TWICE ABOUT WHITNEY
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST PEAK.
I HEAR THAT HE IS VERY EXCITED
TO CONTINUOUS TRAVELS AND
ADVENTURES WITH HIS WIFE JUDY.
ERIC CONGRADULATIONS ON YOUR
RETIREMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR MANY YEARS OF DEDICATED
SERVICE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MISTER BRAZIER YOU ARE
NEVER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
MY ROOMMATE RISE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE IN HONORING ERIC PLAY.
AS CHAIRMAN OF THE PRINT
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
IT WILL BE HARD TO IMAGINE
STARTING THE UPCOMING
LEGISLATIVE SPACE SESSION
WITHOUT MISTER LANG.
HAS LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
HIS CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION POLICY FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
HIS FINGERPRINTS ARE ARE ON ALL
OF THE MAJOR TRANSPORTATION
LEGISLATION IN THIS HOUSE HAS.
AND HAS CONSIDERED EVEN.
S. B. ONE WHICH IS MAGNIFICENT.
HIS THIS THE TALKS WILL
KNOWLEDGE OF TRANSPORTATION
POLICY AND UNDERSTANDING OF
TRANSPORTATION FINANCE WAS
INTERCOLONIAL BEEN CRAFT AT
LANDMARK BILL.
IS WHITE SO GOOD TODAY.
MR LANGE'S ALWAYS READY TO
DISCUSSING NEW OR OLD IDEA.
ADDING A BIT OF HISTORY IN HIS
VAST EXPERIENCE. TO EVERY
CONVERSATION.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS AND
STAFF BOTH CURRENT AND FORMER OF
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. FOR YOUR HELP YOUR
GUIDANCE.
AND WISH YOU THE VERY BEST ON
YOUR JOURNEY AND PLEASE.
DO NOT BE A STRANGER
.
MEMBERS VERY MOVED TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS SECOND READING
[inaudible]
KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY TO TEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS SIXTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S ONE SIXTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SEVENTY FIVE AT
THE MOMENT. THREE TWENTY WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE FORTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS THREE FIFTY
FOURTH AMENDMENT'S FOR THIRTY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS FOR FIFTY
TWO WITH AMENDMENTS FOR FIFTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS. FIVE A ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE THIRTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS SIX NINETY
FIVE WITH THE MOMENT SEVEN
HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS SEVEN
TWENTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS SEVEN
FORTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS. SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT
TWENTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS. EIGHT THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT THIRTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS NINE OH FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS. NINE TWENTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS I FIFTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS NINE FIFTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS NINE SIXTY
WITH AMENDMENTS. NINE SIXTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS NINE SIXTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS NINE SEVENTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS ONE
THOUSAND WITH AMENDMENTS TENDO
FOURTH AMENDMENT'S TEN THIRTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TEN SEVENTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS. TEN TWENTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS TEN FORTY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS TEN FORTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS. TEN FIFTY WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN SEVENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN SEVENTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS. TEN EIGHTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS TEN NINETY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS ELLEN
FIFTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS. ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
ELEMENT THERE ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS ELEVEN FIFTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTEEN HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTEEN TEN WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
FORTINOS HE WITH AMENDMENTS.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WITH THE
MEMONS FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS.
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN EIGHTY WITH
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION LED THE
TEAM WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
461-832-12270. FOUR THREE NINETY
EIGHT THREE NINETY NINE FIVE
BOATS YOU 518-635-6567.
007-823-83480 1-896-933-9379
619-649-78980 NINES HAD NO FIVE
TEN OF 810-141-01910 TWENTY ONE
AND 231-025-1080 611-001-10411
006-111-91120. 411-251-12611
441-156-1170 TWO ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ALTHOUGH
512-231-22512 261-260-1260
312-791-29212. 941-301-1309
THIRTEEN TWELVE THIRTEEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINE THIRTEEN SIXTY THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN
NINETY SEVEN FOURTEEN OH THREE
FOURTEEN OF SEX.
FORTINO 914-131-42214
461-440-81440 NINE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR FOURTEEN TO ME
SEVEN FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU
KATIE.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
DEEMED ADOPTED
.
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO MOVE ITEM FOURTEEN S.
B. FIVE THIRTY NAME FIVE THIRTY
NINE DALY ON TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT.
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I RE REFER IN THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWO SIXTY THREE SB.
EIGHT TWENTY ONE JACKSON TO THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO THE CONCURRENCE
[inaudible]
FILE.
CSUS CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY TWO WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE A. B.. TWO
EIGHTY TWO BY MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
INCORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACTUALLY TO
SUICIDE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
A TWO IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
OUR RESPECTIVE ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
THEY MISS JONES SAWYER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLOCK CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WIZARD OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS EIGHTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FOURS AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SIX
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBERS SANTIAGO
ACTIVITY HEALING ARTS MISTER
SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
ON AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SIX ARE
WERE MINOR FOR CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES RESPECTFULLY ASK AND
I'VE OF SENIOR DISCUSSION TO
MAKE CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY FIVE IS AB BY.
SEVEN FORTY FIVE BY MISS CARILLO
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FIVE BY SOME A
MEMBER CARILLO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO STATE PARKS.
MISS CARILLO YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FIVE WHICH IS BACK
FROM CURRENT.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKING AND THE
SENATE ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS ZERO
NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WAS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT I SIXTY NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN GOING TO PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SEVEN IS AB.
ONE EIGHTY THREE COOPERATE.
AS A LEGAL ONE EIGHTY THREE BY
SONY MEMBER LACKEY AND ACTUALLY
PUBLIC PLEASE [inaudible]
MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ONE EIGHTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT WILL REQUIRE ALL
DEPARTMENTS WITH MORE THAN ONE
SHIFT. TO DEVELOP POLICIES FOR
SUPERVISORS OF THE PERTAINS TO
SHIP ASSIGNMENTS VACATIONS IN
OVERTIME GIVING EMPLOYEES THERE
AND THEIR FAMILY MORE STABILITY
--
TO DIRECT THEIR LIVES AND I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A SAD VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AT AYE SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
OUR CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT IS AB. FIFTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY MISTER BERMAN
[inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN [inaudible]
CORKERY.
IT'S ONLY ABOUT FIFTEEN THIRTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE COURT FEES WHICH
BERMAN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE A BILL TO
ENSURE CONSISTENCY AND
UNIFORMITY AND HOW COURT REFUND
HOW ABOUT.
THEN HOW COURTS REFUND THE
DUPLICATE PAYMENT OF COURT
FILING FEES AND JUST NOT PAYMENT
OF FILING FEES SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDED THE PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
ATTORNEYS.
THAT ELECTRONICALLY FILED
DOCUMENTS WITH THE COURT PAY THE
REQUISITE FILING FEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
THEIR SKETCHER DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TIE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY NINE IS AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE BY MISS COMEY
AEROCAR CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER CABALLERO
AND ACTUALLY THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT WAS
CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL MAKES THREE COMMON SENSE
REFORMS TO THE SANTA CLARA.
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ACT THE
SENATE TOOK AMENDMENTS WHICH
TIGHTENED UP THE COMPENSABLE
MEETING DAY'S REQUIREMENT FOR
THE BOARD AND ADDED A FIVE YEAR
SON SUNSET.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISS COMEY OC NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROADS HOW ABOUT I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENT
CIRCUIT CURTAIN FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY IS AB NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
MISTER RICHARD GOOD MORNING --
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B.
NINETY THREE THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE --
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE FOR THE
ABORIGINE TO STRAY FOR THREE
CYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS ME CHANCY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE IS AB.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY ADMINISTRATOR
REVIEW ACTUALLY STATE REAL
PROPERTY MAKE IN PREPARATION
THEREFORE [inaudible]
DR EGGMAN [inaudible]
YOU ARE.
RECOGNIZE I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS A
CONCURRENCE AND HAD TO PUT IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THE SENATE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLTIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO IS AB
TWO THOUSAND SIX QUIRK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER EGGMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO BE HIT
KILLER AIR POLLUTION.
DR ED WHEN YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
THINK YOU'RE SPEAKER AB TWO ZERO
ZERO SIX IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT
HAVING TO DEAL WITH VAN PULLS IN
GETTING PEOPLE TO WORK SAFELY
AND REDUCING.
THE YEAH THAT.
STRAIN ON OUR ENVIRONMENT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR SEEN NO
DISCUSSION BAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
UNDECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS HAD VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN
IS AB TWENTY NINETY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY SIX
BY SOME A MEMBER FRAZIER AND
ATLANTA TAXATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
MISTER FRAZIER GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY NINETY SIX IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER SOME
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE.
THIS BILL CREATED VOLUNTARY
CHECKOFF FUND FOR OF DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA THE NONPROFIT THAT
MANAGERS ARE STATES ORGAN EYE
AND TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY.
THANK YOU FOR AND A RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS FRAZIER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TYPE OF I
SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR IS AB.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY AND
OTHERS IN ATLANTA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES MISTER KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE IT
UPDATES EXISTING K. TWELVE
EMPLOYEE DISMISSAL POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BETTER PROTECT
STUDENTS FROM SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND OTHER INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR.
IT DOES THIS BY ALLOWING
EVIDENCE ORDER THEM IT'S
PRESENTED DISMISSAL PROCEEDINGS
INVOLVING SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
MISCONDUCT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
CLARIFYING THE BILL WAS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KILEY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN. FIVE AND ONE
SIXTY FIVE IS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES
AND ACTUALLY THE PARKS
RECREATION.
MR MAYES YOUR MAILBOX.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY SEVEN WAS AMENDED IN
THE SENATE TO APPLY TO ALL
REGIONAL PARK IN OPEN SPACE
DISTRICTS.
PROVIDING GREATER EFFICIENCY AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RESOURCES
STATEWIDE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
VOTE THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS RESPECT WE ASK YOU RIGHT
NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER MAY SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON BUT THIS OUT OF
OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PILOT ON ONE SIXTY SIX IS AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY SOME THE
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACTUALLY
DIVEST UL'S.
ZAKIR CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THE DEFINITION OF A VESSEL TO
INCLUDE BOTH THE VESSEL AND ANY
TRAILER USED BY THE OPERATOR TO
TRANSPORT THE VESSEL.
AB TWENTY ONE SO FIVE HAS NO
OPPOSITION PASSED UNANIMOUSLY ON
THE SENATE FLOOR IRIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTED THIS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE I SEE SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTH
.
SEVEN WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT WORD FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE MISTER KANSEN
CHU CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MR SHIPP I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SAM MEMBER.
A AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT THE SENATE
AMENDMENT TOOK OUT PARTS OF THE
BILL WHICH DEAL WITH A CHILD
SOCIAL MEDIA INFLUENCER.
THIS BILL A TO LIMIT THE BILL.
MAHER MODERN LYSINE DAY EXISTING
LAWS REGARDING CHILD PERFORMERS
AND AMATEUR.
A PRODUCTIONS BY ADDING THE TERM
DIGITAL EXHIBITIONS. TO DO IT
REFLECT A MODERN STREAMING AND
BROADCAST PRACTICE THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND IS SUPPORTED
BY MP A AND THIS PARTNERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY MISSED YOU SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE
NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY IS AB
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED BY SOME A MEMBER COLOR
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TAXATION
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED EXTENDS A
SUNSET DATE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
VOLUNTARY TAX CHECK OFF FOR
ALZHEIMER'S RESEARCH AND OTHER
DEMENTIA RELATED DISEASES.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENTOF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
BE REIMBURSED FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AND SPECIFIES THAT GRANT
MONEY SHALL NOT BE USED FOR ANY
PURPOSE OUTSIDE THE STATE.
SELECT WE ASPIRIN AYE BOATING
CONCURRENCE OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS KALRA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
UNDECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY ONE IS AB TWENTY FORTY
FIVE FOR COREY.
AS A LEGAL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE BY SONY MEMBER CHAO
ACTUALLY COULD ENFORCEMENT.
MISTER CHAU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL AND ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE WITH A LEGITIMATE REASON
TO PARTICIPATE IN A CODE
ENFORCEMENT INSPECTION.
MAY IN INDEED ATTEND THE
INSPECTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS CHAO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
THE SENATE OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY TWO WAS AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN THE
CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACT LIKE
CORPORATIONS.
THE STRANGITE THANK THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN CORRECTS
TECHNICAL CROSS REFERENCES.
THROUGHOUT SECTIONS THE
CORPORATION'S CODE --
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT OF THOSE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROWLAND HIGH THAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY THREES AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER
OBERNOLTE ACTUALLY TOWARDS.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FIVE WOULD PROVIDE THAT A
JUVENILE COURT RETAINS
JURISDICTION OVER THE
SUPERVISION OF A WARRANT WHEN
THEY ARE RELEASED FROM CUSTODY.
OF THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE MERELY A
TECHNICAL THEY MADE A CHANGE OF
TERMINOLOGY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THIS OUT OF VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR TV
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY IN
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCACY.
THIS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN INTEGRATES THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE WITHIN THE
STATE'S EXISTING.
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY ACTIVITIES THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO NAME THE
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE AND THE TITLE OF ITS
DIRECTOR.
THIS BILL IS JOINTLY AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN OF
WHOSE DISTRICT AND OTHER
DISTRICTS SUFFERED GREATLY THIS
YEAR'S AND THIS YEAR'S FIRES THE
BILL RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THEN IS QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
AND FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SIX CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX MY FAMILY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE
TAXATION.
MISTER GARCIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
TWENTY SEVEN FOR SIX BECAUSE
BACK FROM CURRENT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FOUR SIX
ADDRESSES UNCERTAINTY THAT
ARISES IN CASES WHERE THE
PROPERTY OWNER FILED BANKRUPTCY
IN THE WINDOW PERIOD AFTER THE
TAX SELL COMMENCES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR PAYMENTS GARCIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROAD TYPE BUT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SIX DB TWENTY EIGHT OH
ONE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY A A ONE BY
SOME A NUMBER SALAS AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY MEMORIALS.
MISTER SALAS HE MEHLMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SIMPLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT OH ONE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FAMOUS SALAS SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL A TIE VOTE EYES
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
FIVE MISTER STONE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER MARK STONE
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION.
THIS YEAR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS THE BILL ABOUT
THIS YEAR NEVADA CONSERVANCY
STRENGTHENING SOME OF ITS
PROVISIONS ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
RESPECT TO ITS WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL I'VE JOINTLY AUTHORED
WITH OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER
IN ORDER TO AT ASSIST THAT
CONSERVANCY SENATE AMENDMENTS WE
REALLY.
MAKE SOME CHANGES WITH RESPECT
TO WHAT GETS REPORTED IN THEIR
ANNUAL REPORT AND ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
NAMES DOWN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
RUN TO SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ASIDE OF THE
CLERK WELL CLOSE RUNS HIGH BUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY EIGHT AND
ONE SEVENTY NINE THAT BRINGS US.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
ONE IS AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN
CORPORATE A SOME LEGAL TWENTY
NINE TWENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOES AREA AND ACTUALLY TO
INSURANCE MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE.
MISTRESS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN
CLARIFIES CURRENT STATUTE THAT
ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY TO PLACE A SURCHARGE
ON THEIR POLICYHOLDERS PREMIUM
IN THE EVENT OF AN EXTREMELY
LARGE UNPRECEDENTED EARTHQUAKE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
CLARIFYING THE BILL HAS HAD NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AND HAS
HAD NO NO VOTES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR OF SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE HOME MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK. TO
FILE ITEM [inaudible] ONE EIGHTY
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE EIGHT AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE
COVERAGE.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY THREE BY SOME A MEMBER
WALDRON AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS THIS BILL WILL
ACQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT REVIEW PROGRAM TO
CONSIDER A LONGER OUTLOOK. FOR
DATA EVALUATION LOOKING AT THE
COST OF SAVINGS OF THE COVERAGE
OR REPEAL OF COVERAGE OF THE
BENEFIT OR SERVICE FOR UP TO TWO
YEARS.
AMENDMENTS MADE IN THE SENATE.
WILL MAKE THE IMPLEMENTATION FOR
THIS BILL EASIER FOR OF TO BURP
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE
VOTE.
THEY MISS WALDRON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
UNDECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT
I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE. TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT THIS
IS FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO BY MISS RUBIO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AND
OTHERS AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BELL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO WHICH
WILL SET SAFE TEMPERATURE
STANDARDS FOR THE MOBILE
TRANSPORTATION OF DOGS AND CATS.
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND TO INCLUDE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTIONS.
IT RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN BOTH HOUSES AND NOW BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO WILL
PROTECT DOGS AND CATS FROM
TEMPERATURE RELATED INJURIES OR
DEATHS.
I RESPECT FOR RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
NAME IS RUBIO SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE TO ROLLING TIE THAT AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
BACK CAN FILE ORDER.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM LADY.
TO AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE THIRTY
BY SOME A MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE TENDENCY.
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THE SENATE WERE CLARIFYING
BY NATURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS IT IS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE WRONG TIED
ABOUT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS OCCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
EIGHT OR BY SOME THE MEMBER
JONES SAWYER ACTUALLY TAXATION
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOURTH BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE MEMBERS
TAKEN IS SENATOR TECHNICAL IN
NATURE DISABILITIES RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THROUGHOUT
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DECIDE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
AYE [inaudible]
SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FOUR AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
NINE BY MISTER GLORIOUS.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY NINE FORTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACT THE PEOPLE RESIDENTS SEE.
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
NINE WHICH IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CREEK PARITY WITH
OTHER HIGHLY MOBILE STUDENT
GROUPS BY ALLOWING STUDENTS OF
MILITARY FAMILIES TO CONTINUE.
INTO THEIR FEEDER SCHOOLS WITHIN
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT OF ORIGIN
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES GLORIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WELL OVER THERE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE IS AB
THIRTY TWELVE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWELVE BY
SOME REMEMBER GALLAGHER AND
ACTUALLY THE COASTAL RESOURCES.
SURE GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY OR THIRTY TWELVE WHICH IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT SYMBOL HELP
ENCOURAGE MULTI BENEFIT
SETTLEMENT REMOVAL PROJECTS --
I'D ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK
YOU.
THINGS GALLAGHER SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE VOTE.
IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED THAT
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTIES
SIX A. B. THIRTY ONE OUT
[inaudible]
TO KERKORIAN.
I SOME THIRTY ONE OH NINE BY
SOME A MEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CONTRACTS.
MISTER STONE YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THIS IS AB.
THIRTY ONE OH NINE BACK TO US
FROM THE SENATE IT HAD TWO
PROVISIONS THAT WHEN YOU ALL
VOTED ON THIS.
A NUMBER OF MONTHS AGO WHEN ONE
WAY MAKE UNENFORCEABLE ANY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT THAT
PROHIBITS SOMEONE FROM SPEAKING
TO A LEGISLATIVE BODY OR
JUDICIAL BODY OR ADMINISTRATIVE
BODY.
PART THAT I TOOK OUT IN THE
SENATE HAS TO DO WITH
PROHIBITIONS ON NO HIGHER
AGREEMENTS AND THAT WAS REMOVED
BECAUSE OF PENDING LITIGATION.
SO OTHER THAN THAT IT'S PRETTY
MUCH WHAT WE SAW A NUMBER OF
MONTHS AGO AND ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TYPE OF EYES SIXTEEN
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
AB.
THREE TO FOUR CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER KILEY AND
ACTUALLY THE DISORDERLY CONDUCT.
MEASURE KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IS AB THREE TWENTY
FOUR WHICH STRENGTHENS
PROTECTIONS AGAINST VOYEURISM
AND INVASIONS OF PRIVACY.
SENATE AMENDMENTS DEFINED THE
TERM IDENTIFIABLE SO THE PURPOSE
OF PERPETRATOR COMPUTERIZED
SECLUDED IF THE VICTIM IS SELF
IDENTIFIED OR IF THE VICTIM IS
CAPABLE OF BEING IDENTIFIED.
THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVED THE
OPPOSITION OF THE CELL YOU IN
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I ASK YOUR I'VE OUT.
THEY CAN WHICH KILEY.
SEE KNOW DISCUSSION MAY CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO'S OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT IS AB FOUR
SEVEN NINE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY NINE
BY SOME THE MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO WORKERS COMPENSATION.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU AB FOR SEVENTY NINE
BIAS.
STATION AND DEALING WITH BREAST
CANCER THE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR
TECHNICAL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
XENA DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE AYE.
SIXTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE IS A.
B..
NINE TWO NINE THE CORPORAL RATE.
AS A LEGAL NINE TWENTY NINE BY
SOME THE MEMBER RUBIO AND
ACTUALLY JUST I'LL SUPPORT.
IS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
ARE PRESENTING AB NINE TWENTY
NINE WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
AS A REMINDER THIS BILL AMENDS
FAMILY CODE TO INDICATE THAT A
PRESUMPTION AGAINST AWAITING
SPOUSAL SUPPORT TO AN ABUSER
SHOULD ARISE IN NUMEROUS
SITUATIONS OUTSIDE OF JUST THE
CONVICTION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AFTER MAKING SOME AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY A FEW FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION I AM PROUD TO SAY
THAT AB NINE TWENTY NINE IS NOW.
AN EVEN BETTER BILL THAN IT WAS
WHEN IT ORIGINALLY PASSED
THROUGH THIS HOUSE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
DOES I STRONGLY URGE AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LEANN HOME MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY FOUR I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
AND MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY MISTER KALRA.
QUACKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY SOME A MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY THE DEBT COLLECTION
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX TO YOU TODAY.
MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX IS A
SIMPLE YET IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
HELP CLARIFY HOW AND WHEN THE
DEBT MAY BE PURSUED FOR
REPAYMENT THE STATUE LIMITATIONS
HAS EXPIRED.
pTO CLARIFY HOW THE INITIAL
AFTER
BY CREDITORS TO COLLECT ON TIME
BARRED DEBT IS MADE.
ALL THIS BILL PASSED UP THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SEVENTY FIVE ZERO
ON THE SENATE FLOOR THIRTY SEVEN
ZERO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE BOAT FOR CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CORPORAL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIS OUT OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS HAD ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT AYE SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND MEMBERS WERE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINORTH
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
MISTER STEINORTH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX OF BACKING
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE RECENT
AMENDMENTS ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE TO ASSIST IN
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS BILL HAS UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I DOUBT.
NAME STEINORTH SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
A CLUB LARA.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VETERANS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ARE ALL TIED
THE KNOT AND SIXTY FOUR KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM. ONE
NINETY TWO IT'S A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE CORKERY SOME LEGAL
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE BY SOME A
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY
THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
[inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THE BILL CORPORATE INFORMATION
ON HOW MOBILE PHONE APPLICATIONS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA ARE USED FOR
HOME HUMAN TRAFFICKING INTO
REQUIRED CURRICULUM.
TECHNO MOMENTS IN THE SENATE
ADDRESS CHATTERING ISSUES
ESPECIALLY AFTER I WROTE.
THINGS RODRIGUEZ SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM OF ONE NINETY THREE IS
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTIES INCORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE REQUIRES
THAT EMPLOYERS WITH FIFTY OR
MORE EMPLOYEES RETAIN EMPLOYEE
COMPLAINTS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE
RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS FROM
A PERIOD OF TEN YEARS TO PERIOD
OF AT LEAST FIVE YEARS AFTER THE
TERMINATION OF EMPLOYMENT.
THE COMPLAINANT OR THE ALLEGED
HARASSER NAMED IN THE COMPLAINT
WHICHEVER IS LATER.
RECENT AMENDMENTS ALSO REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM GROUPS LIKE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS THE RETEK
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND OTHERS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY USE RACE THE SAME NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
PARK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE IN TIME
BUT I SIXTY KNOWS.
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND WERE FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY FOUR AB NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA
GROUNDWATER.
MISTER GARCIA AB NINETEEN FORTY
FOURS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN.
ON MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW IT ABOUT I.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVES AB TWENTY FORTY ONE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY ONE
BY SOME THE MEMBER CABALLERO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IS COMING ERA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER --
AB TWENTY FORTY ONE IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION.
PLEASE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES CABALLERO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VETERANS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLLING TIED
ABOUT EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS.
NINETEEN SOME MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SIX IS AB.
TWENTY AB [inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND ARMY AB. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTEEN CARGO RATE.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN
BY SOME A MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
[inaudible]
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN MAKES
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE LICENSING
PROCESSES FOR LICENSED MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPISTS LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS.
IT SEEKS TO INCREASE CONSISTENCY
IN THE LICENSING REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS THESE THREE PROFESSIONS.
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
ADDRESS CHAPTER RING OUT ISSUES
WITH TWO OTHER BILLS THIS BILL
HAS HAD.
NO OPPOSITION AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SHE NOTICED CATCHER MADE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LIBERAL.
RESERVED ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS THERE TO VOTE.
THE DESERT ABOUT [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN IS AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO CORKERY
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALY AND ACTUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL ENSURES THE
JUDGES CAN ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TO PRESERVE THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
AFTER THEY RETIRE FROM THE
BENCH.
SENATE FLOOR AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING.
SPILL HAS RECEIVED NARY A NO
VOTE.
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
I RESPECTFULLY I WANT TO GET
YOUR ATTENTION.
IT'S HARD TO SAY HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES.
SO NERI A NO VOTE GOT YOUR
ATTENTION I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD MISTER DALY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CORPORAL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS WHO ARE THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE WRONG TIE THAT
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT IS AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER MATHIS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
DEPARTMENTS EQUALITY
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS A VITAL BILL FOR
FIXING UP HOUSING --
DEALING WITH THE HOMELESSNESS
AND FIXING INFILL AND OUR
DISTRICTS IT'S BACCARAT
CONCURRENCE AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FAMOUS MATHIS SEE NO DISCUSS AND
DEBATE CORPORAL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHEN
I SPEAK TO NINE KNOWS.
THREE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY NINE IT'S
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TRAFFIC
SAFETY [inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB TWENTY
THREE SIX THREE ZERO TRAFFIC
FATALITIES TASK FORCE IN THE
SENATE DID THE FOLLOWING.
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH STATEWIDE MOTORIST
ORGANIZATIONS AND TRANSPORTATION
ADVOCACY GROUPS THE COMPOSITION
OF THE TASK FORCE.
CHANGED THE NAME OF THAT HOUSE
FORCED TO THE ZERO TRAFFIC
FATALITIES TASK FORCE.
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS THE
STATE CONTINUE TO WEIGH IN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IT PASSED THE SENATE FLOOR WITH
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
PLEASE DON'T BE A ZERO VOTE AYE
ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU.
THINK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEM NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS A
JOINT AUTHOR OF AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY CITIES HAVE
TAKEN THE PLEDGE TO REDUCE
TRAFFIC FATALITIES TWO ZERO IN
THIS IS A MOVEMENT THAT MUST
RESONATE IN EVERY CALIFORNIA
CITY.
AS THE FATHER OF A CHILD WHO
LOST THEIR LIFE IN A SENSELESS
TRAFFIC FATALITY.
I SPEAK WITH FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
CURTAILING DISTRACTED DRIVING
EXCESSIVE SPEED AND DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES IN THIS BILL KEEP US
KEEPS US MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I URGE DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWO HUNDRED AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT BY DOCTOR WEBER THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOMETHING ALL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
DOCTOR WEBER YES MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
FOR CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS TAKE IT IN THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE TAX
COLLECTOR IS NOT REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE PARCEL TAX EXEMPTION
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEBSITE OF
THE COUNTY TAX BILL IF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BILLS TO PROVIDE A TAX COLLECTOR
WITH THE SPECIFIED INFORMATION.
LASTLY ALSO MOST MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS RESOLVE THE CHAPLAIN
OUT CONFLICT WITH ANOTHER BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THIS BILL ALSO HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES NOT HARD TO SAY --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO'S OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY
THAT I SIXTY SEVEN ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM TO A ONE IS AB
[inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FIVE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY AND CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE.
MISTER MAYES.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FIVE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
--
YOU ALL VOTED FOR IT BEFORE IT'S
A BETTER BE OWN I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE VOTE.
IT'S MAYES ZENO DESCRIPTOR
DEBATE COURT WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE SAN VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROWLAND HIGH ABOUT ICE
FIFTY TWO KNOWS.
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TO GO TO IS A BE
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR CORKERY.
AT SOME LEGAL TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
PARTICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
ASSURE RODRIGUEZ.
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY FOURS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES.
THIS BILL INCREASED PENALTIES
FOR COMMERCIAL TRUCKS THAT USE
COLLIDERS WHICH ARE TRUCKS THAT
RUN ON OUTDATED ENGINE.
BUT ARE HIDDEN FROM BEHIND YOU
BODY TRUCK PARTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL THEY'RE ALL ON MEMBERS.
DESERT THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DECIDE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TYPE ON I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWO OR THREE IS AB.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ATLANTA INSURANCE DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FOUR IN THE SENATE
DID THE FOLLOWING MAY TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE CHANGES
MADE BY THIS BILL APPLY TO FORMS
OR POLICIES ISSUED A RENEWED.
ON OR AFTER JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ADOPTS AN
URGENCY PROVISION THAT REQUIRES
INSURERS TO IMMEDIATELY EXTEND
THE FACT OF LIMITATIONS TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. FOR ALL
LOSSES THAT RESULT FROM A STATE
OF EMERGENCY AFTER THE DATE OF
ENACTMENT.
THIS BILL PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR THIRTY SEVEN TO ZERO WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY IS FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SEEN
NOTICE KASHER DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VETERANS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
IS THAT A VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
I SIXTIES SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
EVERYWHERE FILE ITEM.
TWO OH FOR AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWO BY MISTER DALLI.
CORKERY.
AS A LEGAL TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO
BY FAMILY MEMBER DALLY AND
ACTUALLY THE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
MISTER DALLI.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS BACK IN THE SENATE.
THE MEMBERS WERE JUST CHATTERING
ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
THEY WHICH DELI SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CORP WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT AYE
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH FIVE BY MISTER
HOLETHEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY SEVEN OH FIVE
BY SOME THE MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACT AND PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS [inaudible]
MR HOLDING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NO FIVE BRINGS
PARITY TO OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION LAWS FOR
CONTRACTORS.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
THINGS HOLDEN SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE SAT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER SARAH VOTE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU WHAT
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM TWO OF SIX IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND
ACT AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
MISTER MAYES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS --
AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS BACK
MISS QUESTION I'VE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TO A
SEVEN HAS AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN CORKERY.
AT SOME LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER STE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN IS BACK
ON CONCURRENT AFTER TAKING
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
THE SENATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE.
THINK HIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI ABOUT ICE
FIFTY NOSE FIVE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TO AWAIT IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT COVERAGE.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
AND ACTUALLY THEIR MERCHANT
SERVICES.
SURE GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
MEMBER'S AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS CHATTERING OUT ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
HE WAS GLORIA SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
A CLUB THE ROLL-ON DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND SALAS ABOUT I.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM TOUR.
NINE IS AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE
FOR COREY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE TWELVE BY SOME REMEMBER
IRWIN AND ACTUALLY IN THE COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
[inaudible]
MS OWEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY NINE TWELVE AS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE THAT MAKES
THREE SIMPLE CHANGES TO REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF FINANCIAL
ABUSE AND HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO LEAD THE
PROHIBITION ON ALLOWING THE
MANAGING AGENT OF AN ASSOCIATION
TO ALSO TRANSFER FUNDS THANK
YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL THEM.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM.
TO TEN IS AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE BY SOME
THE MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE TRAFFIC.
IS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY FIVE IN THE SENATE
DID THE FOLLOWING OUT AT THE
CELLMARK COMMUNITY PLAN AREA AND
THE SOMEONE TO HUNGER.
LAKE VIEW TERRACE SHADOW HILLS
IS TELL A SO I EAST LA TUNA
CANYON.
COMMUNITY PLAN AREA IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES TO THE AREA THAT
MAY CONSIDER EQUESTRIAN SAFETY
CONDUCTING AN ENGINEERING AND
TRAFFIC SURVEY ADDED SENATOR
PORTANTINO IS A PRINCIPAL CHO
AUTHOR.
PASS THIS BILL PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR THIRTY SEVEN ZERO WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU.
NAME IS FRIEDMAN.
SAME NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THERE ALL ON MEMBERS
FOUND THIS OUT OF VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WAS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL ABOUT AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN IS AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE CORKERY SOME
LEGAL TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE
BY SOME A MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALTH FACILITIES.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY THREE
PROHIBITS GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS OR AN ACUTE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL.
FROM REQUIRING A PERSON WHO
VOLUNTARILY SEEKS CARE TO BE
PLACED ON A FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLD
AS A CONDITION OF ACCEPTING THE
TRANSFER OF THAT PERSON.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT A HOSPITAL CANNOT REQUIRE A
PERSON TO BE ON A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY HOLD AS A CONDITION OF
ACCEPTING TRANSFER.
AFTER THE WRITTEN CONSENT FOR
TREATMENT AND TRANSFERS
DOCUMENTED OR IN THE ABSENCE OF
ANY EVIDENCE FOR DETENTION ON A
FIFTY ONE FIFTY FOUR AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARP LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED
THIS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT AND FILE AND TO
TWELVE IS AB THIRTY TWENTY TWO
CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWENTY TWO
BY SOME A MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENATE
MET.
THANK YOU MISS CONSULTANCY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS RUN TO
SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT I
SIXTY KNOWS ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM HURRY PASS AND
RETAIN.
WHEN TO PASS A RETAIN ON
[inaudible]
FILE ITEMS.
TWO THIRTEEN TO
FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTEEN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTEEN AB [inaudible]
THIRTY TO FIFTY TWO OPERATE.
AS UNABLE THIRTY TO FIFTY TWO BY
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND
ACTUALLY TO ANIMAL HEALTH BEGIN
PREPARATION THERE.
FOR MS CABALLERO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE IS
OMNIBUS ANIMAL HEALTH BILL.
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVE
OUTDATED LANGUAGE EXPANSE WHO
CAN BE FINE FOR KNOWINGLY MOVE
MOVING A DISEASED ANIMAL OUT OF
A QUARANTINE ZONE WITHOUT PROPER
PERMISSION.
AND UPDATED LANGUAGE RELATED TO
EXPLAIN DRUGS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MS CAO THERE SEEMED NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WAS OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO SARAH VOTE.%
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO THE SENTIMENT SORT
CONCURRENT.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN
AB NINETEEN OH NINE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH NINE
BY SOME THE MEMBER NAZARIAN AND
ACTUALLY TO IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
MISTER IS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN OH NINE REQUIRES.
DSS THE TRANSLATE ALL WRITTEN
MATERIALS --
INTENDED FOR PROVIDERS OF IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICALLY
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SENIORS GOT HER DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WAS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO.
BUT WELL CLOSER ROLLED HOW ABOUT
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
AND TO EIGHTEEN IS AB TWENTY TWO
OH ONE CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY TWO OH ONE
BY FAMILY MEMBER MAYES ACTUALLY
THE COURTS.
MISTER MAYES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
AT SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR CONFIDENTIAL NAME
CHANGES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE.
THINGS MAY SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TYPE AND I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM. TO
NINETEEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO TWENTY AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SIX BY DUCKS CHEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER CHEN AND I
GOING TO VEHICLES.
DOCTOR CHEN.
BUT HE WAS SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SIXTY SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THE BILL TOOK TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AND SENATE
AND HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU DUCKED SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
WE SAT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLL AND TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
AND PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY ONE THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY TWO AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE BY MISTER COOPER
COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTUALLY TO MINORS.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE SEND AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. TO
MATCH THE DEFINITION USED BY THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE.
THIS WE FILAMENTS MAKE CLEAR
THAT A HEALTH PRACTITIONER WHOSE
TRING THE VICTIM IS A MANDATED
REPORTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY WAS COOPER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
A VOTE EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS
TWENTY SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS.
TO TWENTY FIVE THREE TWO THIRTY
TO THIRTY ONE TO THIRTY TWO WILL
BE CONTINUED.
THOSE HERE RECONSIDERATION ITEMS
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
WHEN WE DO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING?
WHERE PASS RETAIN A FILE ON?
TO THIRTY THREE WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
TO THIRTY FOUR HR.
ONE FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE FOURTEEN BY
SOME A MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY BELT
OF THE PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY DAY.
MS AGUILAR CURRY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
HONOREDTO PRESENT HR.
ONE FOURTEEN A CLOSE OCTOBER
TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AS PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY DAY.
EPPS EPILEPSY IS THE MOST COMMON
BRAIN DISORDER WORLDWIDE IT
AFFECTS ONE IN EVERY TWENTY SIX
PEOPLE.
WHILE EPILEPSY CAN BRING AT
BEGIN AT ANY AGE THE MOST
COMMONLY OCCURS IN CHILDREN.
AND RESEARCH INDICATES THAT
SEIZURES CAN DAMAGE A CHILD'S
DEVELOPING BRAIN.
OF THE FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE
WITH EPILEPSY SIXTY THOUSAND OF
THEM ARE CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN MANY OF US KNOW
PEOPLE OUR LIVES THE ADMIN
AFFECTED BY THIS CONDITION.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
ARE AWARE OF THE IMPACTS
PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY CAN HAVE ON
CHILDREN AND ALSO THEIR
FAMILIES.
HR ONE FOURTEEN REAFFIRMS
DECEMBER'S COMMITMENT TO
PROMOTING GREATER AWARENESS FOR
PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION TAKE YOUR CURRENT MS
ADHERE FREEZE REQUESTING THAT
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON HR.
ONE FOURTEEN AS FOR CO AUTHORS
ADDING ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL THEIR SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AS HAVE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MISS AG AIRCREW BACK TO
YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GAS
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE MICKEY'S MIRACLES A
GLOBAL PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY
AWARENESS EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
NONPROFIT.
MICKEY'S MIRACLES WAS FOUNDED BY
WARRIOR MOM KRISTI CORRECT.
GREAT PRIEST AFTER HER OWN
DAUGHTER MICKEY WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY AT JUST
THREE MONTHS OLD.
SINCE ITS CONCEPTION MICKEY'S
MIRACLES HAS BEEN A FORCE OF
GOOD ENSURING THAT FAMILIES
AFFECTED BY PEDIATRIC EPILEPSY
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
GUESTS FROM MICKEY'S MIRACLES IN
THE GALLERY TODAY THANK YOU FOR
COMING
.
HE MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS.
TO THIRTY FIVE AND TO THIRTY SIX
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
SEVEN A C. ARE TWO FIFTY FIVE BY
MISTER HARPER QUICKER READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FIFTY FIVE BY SOME THE NUMBER
HARPER AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
SUICIDE PREVENTION WEEK IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THE SHARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
INTRODUCE ACR TO FIFTY FIVE
WHICH PROCLAIMS THE WEEK OF
SEPTEMBER NINTH.
THROUGH SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION WEEK HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS WEEK WILL BRING AWARENESS
TO THE CRISIS THAT IS GROWING
RAPIDLY ACROSS THE NATION.
SUICIDE IS NOW THE TO HIM
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN THE
UNITED STATES.
TRAGICALLY A PERSON TAKES THEIR
LIFE EVERY FOURTEEN MINUTES IN
OUR COUNTRY.
SUICIDE PREVENTION WEEK WILL
HOPEFULLY SERVE AS A REMINDER TO
PEOPLE THAT IS A SIGN OF
STRENGTH NOT WEAKNESS TO GET
HELP.
AND TREATMENT.
MORE THAN 75% OF THOSE WHO GET
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOUND IT
HELPFUL.
ADDITIONALLY IS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO LEARN THE WARNING
SIGNS FOR SUICIDE.
RECOGNIZING THOSE SIGNS AND
TALKING TO THOSE WHO ARE AT
RISK.
CAN LEAD TO LOVE ONE KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE SOMEONE TO TURN TO IN
A TIME OF NEED.
ACR TO FIFTY FIVE WILL NOT ONLY
RECOGNIZE THE SECOND WEEK OF
SEPTEMBER SUICIDE PREVENTION
WEEK BUT HOPEFULLY.
POTENTIALLY SAVE THE LIVES OF
SOME OF THE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPECTED TO COMMIT
SUICIDE THIS COMING YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND ASKED THAT THE FIRST RULE BE
OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH VOID
INTRODUCING DOES VERY IMPORTANT
MASHER.
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS ARE
DEFINITELY DYING BY SUICIDE AS A
GROWING RATE NEARLY FORTY THREE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS DIE BY
SUICIDE IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN DOES EPIDEMIC IS
GETTING WORSE AND WE ARE.
WE ALSO LEGISLATORS PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS AND FRIENDS NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA.
IN NEED I WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO ONE OF THE CITY THAT I
REPRESENT.
A MILPITAS HAS RECENTLY ADOPTED
A SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICY AND
I WITH OUR COURAGE AUTOCAD AS
WELL AS TO ORDERS TO STAY
CALIFORNIA. TO LOOK INTO
ADOPTING IS A SIMILAR A SUICIDE
PREVENTION OF POLICY --
Y. DEFINITELY BELIEVE HAVE WE
CAN INCREASE.
WHAT WOULD YOU CAN DO YOU NEED
TO DO IS TO INCREASE THEIR*
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
EDUCATION ALL SUICIDE
PREVENTION?
IN SCHOOL AND IN THE WORKPLACE
WE SHOULD INVEST MORE IN EARLY.
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION SO
PEPO KNOWS WHERE TO GO TO A GET
HELP I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU MR MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RESIDENT PROUD JOIN AUTHOR ON
THIS.
NO SUICIDE IS SOMETHING THAT'S
PLAGUING US ACROSS THE BOARD AS
A VETERAN --
WE DEAL WITH IT IN VETERAN
SUICIDE WITH TWENTY TWO A DAY.
AND YOU KNOW I'VE LOST FRIENDS
TO THIS AND THERE'S SOMETHING
YOU KNOW THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT
ON SUICIDE AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE.
WE GET THE INFORMATION OUT THERE
THAT WE'VE LET.
OUR FRIENDS AND OUR FAMILY KNOW
THAT IT'S OKAY TO GET HELP.
THAT HEALTH IS THERE THAT WE
CARE ABOUT THEM.
AND WE HAVE TO DO THAT AS A
COMMUNITY.
AND YOU KNOW BRING THESE PEOPLE
OUT AND RECOGNIZE THE SYMPTOMS.
BECAUSE THERE IS HELP OUT THERE.
AND THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH THAT WE
CAN DO. TO SHOW PEOPLE THE
COMPASSION AND LET THEM KNOW
THAT THEIR LIVES TO HAVE MEANING
BECAUSE A SUICIDE IT DOESN'T
JUST END WITH THEM.
THE PAIN GOES ON OTHER CHILDREN
IN ON OF THE FAMILY AND THAT'S
WHAT MAKES IT TRULY AN EPIDEMIC
SO.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS MISS
MELENDEZ HERE RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M JUST
BRIEFLY MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK WE ALL KNOW.
SOMEONE A FRIEND OR FAMILY
MEMBER WHO HAS --
HAD TO SUFFER THROUGH A CHILD
COMMITTING SUICIDE --
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
REMIND YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
--
YOUR TEACHERS THAT YOU COME IN
CONTACT WITH YOUR PDAS DOOR MIND
THEM THAT ON THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WEBSITE
THEIR NUMBER OF LINKS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THERE THAT.
THAT I MEAN EVERYTHING YOU NEED
TO KNOW ABOUT HOW TO REACH OUT
TO A CHILD AND HELP THEM IS RATE
THERE THERE'S NO SPECIAL CLASS
NEEDED ITS ALRIGHT THERE AT
THEIR FINGERTIPS ARE READING
COURAGE YOU.
TO REMIND THEM OF THAT --
IN THAT IT NEED IT IT COULD HELP
SAVE THE LIFE OF A CHILD THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ MISTER
COSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANNA WHO I THINK OF THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
YOU KNOW SUICIDE HIT EARLY I FOR
ME I WAS --
IN IN HIGH SCHOOL AND MY BEST
FRIEND IN SCOUTING --
COMMITTED SUICIDE IS FATHER HAD
A QUICKENING OUR SCOUT MASTER
AND HAD A PROFOUND EFFECT ON ME
EVEN TO THIS DAY I THINK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IF WHAT IF I HAD.
JUST BEEN THERE. FOR A FEW MORE
TIMES OR TALK TO HIM AND AND
QUITE FRANKLY HE GOT GOTTA
HIMSELF --
INVOLVES SOME DRUGS AND THAT'S
WHEN I PULLED AWAY.
AND MAYBE THAT'S THE TIME YOU
DON'T YOU LEAN FORWARD THE MOST
AND I ALWAYS THINK BACK TO THAT
TIME.
I THINK ABOUT OUR VETERANS TODAY
COMING HOME WITH PTSD I THINK OF
THOSE YOUNG CHILDREN WHO ARE
DEALING WITH ISSUES --
IN THEIR SCHOOLS WE OWE IT TO
OUR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND TO EACH
OTHER. TO ALWAYS TRY TO BE IN
ENCOURAGE YOUR AND TO REACH OUT
WHEN WE THINK THAT MAYBE I WE
WILL BE WELCOMED --
OFTENTIMES --
THESE THINGS ARE A CRY FOR HELP.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE PEOPLE ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE ASKING
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS YOU'RE
GETTING THE INFORMATION YOU NEED
BUT ALWAYS GO AND IF YOU THINK
SOMEONE'S IT IN IN CRISIS.
PICK UP THE PHONE GO OUT AND SEE
THEM.
A YEAR CALL SOMEONE FOR AN
INTERVENTION AYE IT HAD A
PROFOUND EFFECT ON ME AND I
BELIEVE IT STILL DOES TO THIS
DAY.
WHEN YOU REMEMBER YOUR FRIENDS
AND I I JUST THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS AND I APPRECIATED?
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION MR OUR PREEMIE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
JUST A REMINDER THE TENTH
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AYE IN
AMERICA AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
--
UNFORTUNATELY TOUCH MY LIFE IN
JUST THESE LAST FEW WEEKS.
I THIS IS SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS
FAR TOO MANY.
AGAIN IT IS STRENGTH TO REACH
OUT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE HIM
OUT FOR THE A FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
COOPER'S COOPER'S ON AC OR TWO
FIFTY FIVE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS HER CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
THREE COAUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WHERE IT FILE ONTO
THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS H. R.. ONE
FIFTEEN CORKERY HOUSE RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
MATHIS AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CURING STOMACH CANCER MONTH
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
BUT YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT HR. ONE
FIFTEEN PROCLAIMING NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS SECURING
STOMACH CANCER MARK.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL HELP RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT STOMACH CANCER.
IT'S SYMPTOMS PREVENTION AND
EARLY DETECTION.
AWARENESS OF STOMACH CANCER.
IT'S INDICATORS AND RISK FACTORS
REMAINS LOW DESPITE THE FACT
THAT IN NEARLY A MILLION PEOPLE
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH THIS DISEASE
ANNUALLY [inaudible]
EVERY YEAR.
NEARLY NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WORLDWIDE ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH STOMACH CANCER.
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DIE OF THE DISEASE
[inaudible]
EVEN WORSE.
THE NUMBER F CASES AND ADULTS
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
NINE YEARS OF AGE HAS GROWN
NEARLY.
70%.
IT'S NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN ONE
OF THE LEADING ORGANIZATIONS
FIGHTING TO BRING AWARENESS TO
STOMACH CANCER.
IS DEBBIE'S DREAM FOUNDATION
CREATED BY.
W. ZELMAN.
DEBBIE HAD IT ALL THREE LOVNG
CHILDREN A DEVOTED HUSBAND.
PROMISING LEGAL CAREER.
FOR OWN AND HER OWN FIRM.
WHEN STOMACH CANCER THREATENED
AT ALL?
DEBBIE FOUGHT BACK.
AFTER HER DIAGNOSIS RETURNED HER
DREAMS.
THE A STOMACH CANCER FREE WORLD
INTO AN ORGANIZATION WITH TWENTY
NINE CHAPTERS WORLDWIDE.
AND ADVOCATED FOR SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION IN NEW STOMACH CANCER
RESEARCH FUNDING.
ALTHOUGH W. PASSED LAST YEAR.
HER LEGACY LIVES ON THROUGH HER
FOUNDATION WHICH CONTINUES TO
MAKE ITS MARK.
IN THE BATTLE AGAINST STOMACH
CANCER.
IN PASSING H. ARE ONE FIFTEEN
THE ASSEMBLY WILL RECOGNIZE
STOMACH CANCER.
AS ONE OF THE DEADLIEST FORMS OF
CANCER AND REAFFIRM THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
FINDING A CURE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WISH MATHIS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS MATHIS WE LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THERE IS A FIRST WILL BE OPEN
FOR COAUTHORS ON HR ONE FIFTEEN
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
COOPER'S ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
ADDED AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY NINE ACR [inaudible]
ONE SEVENTY SIX COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
RUBIO RELATIVE TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AWARENESS MONTH
[inaudible]
THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I PRESENT ACR ONE SEVENTY
SIX WHICH PROCLAIMS THE MONTH OF
OCTOBER AS THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE
AWARENESS MONTH.
MEMBERS AFTER TWO YEARS OF
STANDING BEFORE THIS BODY I
RECOGNIZE THAT I MIGHT SOUND
LIKE A BROKEN RECORD.
WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES RELATED
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE?
HOWEVER IF IT HASN'T BEEN MADE
CLEAR TO ALREADY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CLEAR NOW.
THIS IS NOT A HOT BUTTON ISSUE
FOR ME. FOR ME THIS IS PERSONAL.
FOR ME.
THIS IS ABOUT STANDING UP FOR
WOMEN.
WHO ARE ABUSED AND DISREGARDED?
WHY NOT JUST THEIR ABUSERS BUT
BY EVERYONE WHO TURNS A BLIND
EYE TO THEIR STRUGGLES?
SO THAT THEY AREN'T
INCONVENIENCED BY THEIR ABUSE
[inaudible] FOR ME.
THIS IS ABOUT STANDING UP FOR
THE WOMEN WHO ARE BEATEN AND
THEN BLAME. FOR BLAMED FOR THEIR
PERPETRATORS ACTIONS.
FORCED CONTINUOUSLY INTERACT
WITH THEIR ABUSERS BY PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN DIFFERENT TO THEIR
TRAUMA.
THEY'RE THE REASON WHY I STAND
TODAY.
AND WHY I WILL I WILL CONTINUE
TO STAND FOR AS LONG AS I AM
HERE.
SO TODAY MEMBERS I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU NOT GESTURE AYE
VOTE ON ACR.
ONE SEVENTY SIX BUT ALSO YOUR
COMMITMENT TO STANDING WITH
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I IN THAT.
I'LL FOR COOPERS PLEASE.
THEY HIS RUBIO SAYING.
NO I'M SORRY THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SEVENTY SIX WHICH RAISES
AWARENESS ON THE CONTINUING
PROBLEM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
OUR STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S HEALTH SURVEY 40% OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN EXPERIENCE
PHYSICAL INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE IN THEIR LIFETIME.
LIKE ISSUES SURROUNDING SOCIAL
COULD MISCONDUCT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IMPACTS ALL RACES AND
COMMUNITIES.
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
FROM WOMEN AND CHILDREN TO
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE REGULARLY
FORCED TO NAVIGATE A WORLD IN
WHICH THEY DEAL WITH DAILY
DOMESTIC AND INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE.
IMPACTING EVERY PART OF THEIR
LIVES.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS TAKE THE TIME AND
TRULY EXPLORE THE NEW ON
SURROUNDING THIS COMPLEX ISSUE
SO THAT WE CANNOT.
CREATE REAL POLICY SOLUTIONS TO
HELP AND EMPOWER SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IT IS WITH
THESE SURVIVORS IN MIND THAT I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
AND JOIN MY COLLEAGUE IN
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU HIS RACE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION THE
AUTHORS ASSN THAT THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHOR CSUS
COAUTHORS AND ACR.
ONE SEVENTY SIX THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER THEIR SEVENTY TWO
COAUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE S. HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY ACR TO SIXTY SEVEN
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTY SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS FELT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SEEK AMERICAN
AWARENESS AND APPRECIATION MONTH
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIX SEVEN DOESN'T IS THE
MONTH OF NOVEMBER AS SICK
AMERICAN AWARENESS AND
APPRECIATION MONTH.
AS THE FIRST INDIAN AMERICAN AND
PERSONAL JOB IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE I'M PROUD TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE HISTORICAL
AND OF THE HISTORY AND RICHNESS
OF SOUTH ASIAN CULTURE
PARTICULARLY A TIME WHEN.
TARGETED TAX ON HATE CRIMES
THREATEN THOSE VERY CULTURAL
PRACTICES --
AND FAITH BASED PRACTICES IN OUR
STATE.
SICK ISN'T TEACHES THE MESSAGE
BASED ON THE PRINCIPLES OF LOVE
AND ONENESS AND CALLS ON ALL
FOLLOWERS TO BE SPIRITUAL
WARRIORS.
MEDITATION SERVICE AND JUSTICE
OUR CORE ASPECTS OF THE SICK WAY
OF LIFE IMPACT WHEN I THINK OF
THE THE STORY THAT MISTER ROGERS
WOULD.
OFTENTIMES TALK ABOUT WHEN HE
WAS A BOY EASY SOMETHING SCARY
IN THE NEWS.
HIS MOTHER WAS FATED WARM LOOK
FOR THE HELPERS YOU ALWAYS FIND
PEOPLE WHO ARE HELPING.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK ABOUT WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THIS WHENEVER
THERE'S A TRAGEDY WHENEVER
THERE'S A NEED FOR HELP.
THEY ARE ALWAYS THERE.
THERE ARE MORE.
GO TO THE WATERS ARE SICK HOUSES
OF WAR UP WORSHIPPING CALIFORNIA
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
NOT ONLY IS CALIFORNIA HOME TO
FIFTY EIGHT GOOD WATERS BUT THE
OLDEST ONE ISN'T STOCKTON.
AND THE LARGEST ONE IN NORTH
AMERICA IS IN MY DISTRICT IN SAN
JOSE. SIX AMERICANS CONTRIBUTE
TO A VIBRANT CULTURE AND AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT OF THE
SICK AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS
HELPED OUR ECONOMY INNOVATE AND
THRIVE FOR WELL OVER A CENTURY
[inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY SICK AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO BE THE
TARGET OF HATE CRIMES JR THEIR
ARTICLES OF FAITH.
INCLUDING A TURBAN AND BEARD
DROPPED WHICH REPRESENT --
SOME OF THE SICK RELIGIOUS
COMMITMENT.
OF TO JUSTICE EQUALITY AND
DIGNITY FOR ALL.
IN AUGUST ALONE THERE BEEN TWO
REPORTED HATE CRIMES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INVOLVED IN THE
BEATING UP INNOCENT SICK
AMERICAN MEN.
AND ONE ATTACK THE INDIVIDUAL
SPRAY PAINTED THE MAN'S TRUCK
WITH THE MESSAGE GO BACK TO YOUR
COUNTRY.
I AT A TIME WHEN HATEFUL
RHETORIC ASPIRES HEINOUS ACTION
IS IMPORTANT BECOME ABOUT THOSE
WORDS WITH OUR OWN.
THE ACCEPTANCE OF LOVE ONE
ANOTHER IS OUR STRENGTH ANYTHING
LESS IS ON AMERICAN AND IT'S IN
THAT SPIRIT THAT WE MUST STAND
TOGETHER AND SHOW OUR
APPRECIATION. FOR THE SICK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR BEING
GREAT AMERICANS AND GREAT
CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR STATE AND
NATION.
THANK YOU.
THEY GIVE US KALRA MISTER
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION I THINK MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM SAN JOSE FOR BRING IT
FORWARD.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
A SIGNIFICANT SEEK POPULATION.
I IN MY DISTRICT YUBA CITY --
IS HOME TO THE TERRIBLE IN A
GOOD LARA.
AND HOSTS EVERY YEAR AN ANNUAL
SEEK PARADE.
I WHICH DRAWS UP TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
MORE RECENTLY COME OUT BILL IN
HIS SHOW UNITED SHADES OF
AMERICA FEATURED SEVERAL
MEMBERS.
OF OUR COMMUNITY ENDS IN TRYING
TO RAISE MORE AWARENESS.
OF THE C. CULTURE.
OUR NBC NEWS RECENTLY FEATURED
MY CONSTITUENT DID OUR BRAINS --
KNOWN AS THE PEACH KING.
I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY I THINK
VERY REPRESENTATIVE.
OF PUNJABI AMERICANS WHO CAME TO
AMERICA.
I CAME IN JUST A FEW DOLLARS IN
THIS PART POCKET BUT A
DETERMINATION A WRK ETHIC.
IE THEN ESTABLISHED A A FORMING
EMPIRE IN A LEGACY.
OF CHARITY IN HIS COMMUNITY --
I ENCOURAGE EACH OF YOU. TO GET
TO KNOW YOUR SICK CONSTITUENTS
AND COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE PROUD AMERICANS WHO CAN
WHO CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO OUR
STATE AS PROFESSIONALS
ENTREPRENEURS FARMERS TEACHERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
JUST TO NAME A FEW THINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A LOT OF
IGNORANCE.
ABOUT THE SEA COMMUNITY AND ITS
CULTURE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE MAY LOOK
DIFFERENT.
THEY HAVE BEEN MISTREATED.
AND IGNORANCE HAS LED THE HATE
CRIMES AND DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST SIKH AMERICANS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
US TO INCREASE THE EDUCATION
AWARENESS AND CROSS CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING.
A TO OVERCOME THIS IGNORANCE.
THE TRADITIONAL SICK GARB --
KNOWN BY THE FIRE AS THE FIVE
KAY'S IS A COMMITMENT TO JUSTICE
EQUALITY AND DIGNITY FOR ALL.
AMERICAN VALUES.
THEIR FACE CELEBRATES.
GIVING AND FEED INTO ALL THE
TRADITION OF LONGER.
IF YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND A SIKH FESTIVAL OR PLEASE
COME TO MY DISTRICT ACTUALLY.
THE MEMBER FROM SAN JOSE MYSELF
WILL WILL PROBABLY BE UP AT THE
SEEK PRAYED TOGETHER I NOVEMBER
--
AND WE'D LOVE TO HOST ANYBODY
WHO'D LIKE TO COME UP AND TAKE
PART IN THE CELEBRATION.
I AM VERY PROUD. TO SUPPORT.
THE SEA COMMUNITY AND TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THINGS GALLAGHER MR THURMOND
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TWO SIX SEVEN I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES IN SAN JOSE
AND NICHOLAS. FOR BRING IT
FORWARD OF MY DISTRICT ALSO I IS
HOME TO A MAJOR SEEK CENTER.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE SEEN
--
FIRSTHAND A NUMBER OF HATE
CRIMES ARE COMMITTED AGAINST
SEEKS IN OUR COMMUNITY OF MOST
NOTABLY AN ATTACK AGAINST A SIKH
MAN.
OUT WHERE HIS HAIR WAS CUT.
S. FINGER WAS CUT OFF IN THIS
MAN WAS BRUTALLY BEATEN.
BECAUSE HE WAS DIFFERENT --
THE SEEK MEMBERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ARE VERY ACTIVE IN OUR
FAITH COMMUNITY AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY CENTER IS AN ARCHER
DOUBLE COMMUNITIES.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
AT THE FIRST SEEK EVER ELECTED
TO THE WRITTEN CITY COUNCIL.
AND CAN ATTEST TO THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT --
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN A
SEA COMMUNITY [inaudible]
THE OUR WORLD AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR.
TWO SIX SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SEEN NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
WONDERFUL COMMENTS AND AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM NICOLAS INDICATED
--
NOVEMBER IS THE MONTH OR
RECOGNIZING A SICK AMERICAN
AWARENESS APPRECIATION MONTH SO
THAT YOU CAN MAKE IT OVER YUBA
CITY.
IF YOU EVER COME TO SAN JOSE I
LOVE GIVING TOURS OF ARGUED
WATER OR FIND THE CLOSEST ONE
NEAR YOUR DISTRICT OR IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND NOVEMBER.
TAKE A CUT TAKE SOME COPIES OF
THE RESOLUTION TO THEM SO THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THEIR STATE
LEGISLATORS IN THEIR STATE STAND
WITH THEM OF TODAY AND ALWAYS.
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I BONUS FOR THE FIRST WILL BE A
POLITICAL AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THINGS KALRA MEMBERS THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT
[inaudible]
NURSES CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL THEIR SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE WE HAVE
--
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE SEA
COMMUNITY WITH US TODAY I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE I MENTIONED DR
BAINES HIS SON CARM VEINS A
MEMBER OF THE SUTTER COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND HIS DAUGHTER MEGAN ARE WITH
US AS WELL AS HARDEEP SINGH
PRESIDENT.
OF THE PUNJABI AMERICAN HERITAGE
SOCIETY AND HER DAUGHTERS OR HER
CHILDREN.
GOOD USE KHARIF AND ID.
AS WELL AS DOCTOR JASBIR SINGH
KANG.
PHYSICIAN AND CO FOUNDER OF THE
PUNJAB THE AMERICAN HERITAGE
SOCIETY.
AND HIS WIFE SUIT JEEP CAME.
PLEASE WELCOME THE MEMBERS
.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER WHERE
IT FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO FORTY ONE AJ ARE. FORTY EIGHT
THE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY TRY RESOLUTION FORTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER LIMON
RELATIVE TO CONSUMER LOANS.
MISS THE MARK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
BUREAU AYE IS UNDER ATTACK BORN
OUT OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
FINANCIAL CRISIS THE CFPB IS THE
ONLY FEDERAL REGULATORY AGENCY
THAT PLACES CONSUMERS FIRST.
WHEN CONSIDERING OUR COUNTRY'S
OVERSIGHT OF FINANCIAL SERVICES
INDUSTRY?
REGRETTABLY WE HAVE SEEN THE
WEAKENING OF THE CFPB BY ROLLING
BACK REGULATIONS STOPPING
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AND THE LACK
OF SUPPORT FOR THE BEARS
MISSION.
AND NO CONSUMERS LIKE SEGMENTS
ARE IMMUNE TO THIS ROLL BACK.
THIS LAST WEEK WE LEARNED THAT
THE CFPB WILL NO LONGER CONDUCT
EXAMINATION OF LENDERS TO ENSURE
THEY COMPLY WITH THE MILITARY
LANDING ACT WHICH PROTECTS OUR
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES FROM
PREDATORY LENDING PRACTICES.
CALCULUS CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
DESERVE A STRONG CFPB THAT
SUPPORTS HEALTHY FINANCIAL
MARKETS.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION INCEPTION IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE CFPB HAS
RETURNED OVER TWELVE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO OVER THIRTY
ONE MILLION CONSUMERS WHO ARE
HARMED BY UNFAIR OR DISTRICT
DISCRIMINATORY FINANCIAL
PRACTICES.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN URGING
POLICYMAKERS INTERMISSIONS
CAPITAL TO SUPPORT THE CFPB IN
CARRYING OUT ITS IMPORTANT
DUTIES TO PROMOTE FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND TO PROTECT ALL
CONSUMERS FROM ABUSIVE
PRACTICES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AMONG.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
MS AMONG WHICH THEY CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THE FIRST SHALL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THIS ACR CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON VERSUS IS
FOR COAUTHORS.
COOPER IS ON THE RESOLUTION. FOR
CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
MARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AN
AGE A ARE WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
[inaudible]
KARP WELL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI ABOUT ICE YOU TO
THREE KNOWS.
FOR THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY TWO THIS IS AJ ARE
[inaudible]
FORTY TWO GREGORY.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE THAN OTHERS WELL
TO TO TITLE.
TEN IS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AJ ARE.
FORTY TWO A RESOLUTION DECLARING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE TITLE TEN
PROGRAM IN URGENT OPPOSITION TO
THE RECENTLY PROPOSED GAG RULE
WHICH WOULD AFFECT TITLE TEN
PROVIDERS.
TITLE TEN WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY AND IS THE
NATION'S PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING BIRTH CONTROL CANCER
SCREENINGS AND TESTING AND
TREATMENT FOR SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
THE UNITED STATES IS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A THIRTY YEAR LOW
FOR UNPLANNED PREGNANCY THANKS
IN LARGE PART TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF PREVENTION.
THIS PROGRAM SERVES FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE EACH YEAR AND CALIFORNIA
IS HOME 225% OF TITLE TEN
PATIENTS NATIONWIDE.
YET DESPITE THESE OUTCOMES AND
HOW MANY LOW INCOME PATIENTS
RELY ON SUCH SERVICES THE
CURRENT FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED A DOMESTIC GAG RULE FOR
TITLE TEN PROVIDERS.
EVEN THOUGH IT HAS RECEIVED
WIDESPREAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR DECADES.
THE GAG RULE WOULD PROHIBIT
CLINICIANS FROM GIVING DIRECT
REFERRALS FOR ABORTION TO THEIR
PATIENTS OR EVEN TALKING ABOUT
ABORTION PREVENTING PATIENTS
FROM GETTING THE COMPLETE AND
HONEST MEDICAL INFORMATION THEY
DESERVE.
FROM DOCTORS THAT THEY TRUST.
THE GAG RULE BUILDS A WALL
BETWEEN MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS IT IS IRRESPONSIBLE
WHICH IS WHY THERE HAVE BEEN
MORE THAN EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
COMMENTS OPPOSING THE PROPOSED
RULE FROM CALIFORNIA ALONE.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN ASKING THE FEDERAL
MINISTRATION TO RE EVALUATE THIS
AND ANY PROPOSED RULE THAT WOULD
ENDANGER WOMEN'S HEALTH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF EGR.
FORTY TWO MY DISTRICT IS OFTEN
THE MARMONT TODAY PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATE WHICH IS
THE LARGEST AFFILIATE IN THE
TENNIS SO IMPORTANT LIKE
COMMISSIONER READ A BRIEF STORY
FOR WHAT ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
THAT WAS SHARED WITH ME
[inaudible]
VERY BRIEF [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THEY MAY TWENTY FIFTEEN I FOUND
A LUMP IN MY LEFT BREAST.
BEING UNINSURED ANY SINGLE
MOTHER I WASN'T SURE WHAT TO DO
OR TO GO.
AND THAT'S MY TURN TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MARMONT TODAY AND IT
WAS THROUGH THEM THAT I FOUND
OUT MY DIAGNOSIS OF BREAST
CANCER.
THE DOCTOR AND STAFF AND MORE
MONTY ON BE ST.
WE'RE SO INCREDIBLE.
MY DOCTOR GAVE ME GREAT CARE
THAT RECEIVE A DIAGNOSIS TO MY
PATIENT ADVOCATE.
I WOULD STILL CARE FOR I FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE PART OF MY JOURNEY
THAT WOULD BE OKAY FOR THEIR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IF THEY WILL
PROVIDE CARE TO PATIENTS LIKE MY
CONSTITUENT BECAUSE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THROUGH
TITLE TEN PROGRAM.
ARE STRICTLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
NAME IS COOPER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE OF YOU MAY
CLOSE AND WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTE.
I WILL SIMPLY CLOSE THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
TITLE TEN PROGRAM LIES IN THE
FACT THAT IT PROVIDES
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. TO ALL
WOMEN REGARDLESS.
OF THEIR INCOME OR BACKGROUND.
AND THIS PROPOSED RULE THIS GAG
RULE HAS BEEN DANGEROUS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE DANGEROUS AND AN
INTENTIONAL ATTACK.
ON REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
WOMEN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
CLARIFY MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE VIEW
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE ON THE
FIRST ROLE --
THIS --
RESOLUTION CURRENTLY ENJOYS --
A NUMBER OF CO AUTHORS FIFTEEN
CO AUTHOR SO I WILL RESPECTFULLY
JUST ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES.
FORTY NINE KNOWS TWELVE THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ON TO FORTY
THREE WE ARE AT FILE AT TWO
FORTY FOUR THIS IS A J. OUR
THIRTY COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY TRACK RESOLUTION THIRTY
BY SOME THE MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
MISTER AGUILAR CURRY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AJ ARE
THIRTIES CALLS ON CONGRESS TO
SWIFTLY PASS HR SIX SIX NINE
WHICH PROHIBITS THE PRESIDENT
FROM UNILATERALLY AUTHORIZING
THE OFFENSIVE USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS WITHOUT A CONGRESSIONAL
DECLARATION OF WAR.
IF ANY PRESIDENT ORDERS AN
OFFENSIVE NUCLEAR ATTACK ON ANY
OTHER NUCLEAR POWER THE RESPONSE
WOULD BE TO BE AN IMMEDIATE
COUNTERATTACKS RESULTING IN
UNSPEAKABLE AMERICAN CASUALTIES.
HR SIX SIX NINE WOULD FIX THIS
THREAT BY MAKING SURE CONGRESS
HAS A SAY IN SOMETHING THAT
COULD IMPACT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
IN THE UNITED STATES.
PASSING AJ OUR THIRTY
DEMONSTRATES CALIFORNIAS
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING ALL
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THE TERROR
OF A NUCLEAR WAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SCENE KNOW DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
YES I WOULD.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
NURSES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS COAUTHORS.
HIS CO AUTHORS ON AJ OUR THIRTY
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE FORTY
SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS A
MAJOR A ARE THEREFORE WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
OUR CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO SARAJEVO?
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AREA VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TIME BUT AYE AYES.
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE IT FILE ITEM TO FORTY FIVE
HJ OUR THIRTY THREE COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY TRY RESOLUTION THIRTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER LIMON AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
MISSILE MARK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT AJ
OUR THIRTY THREE URGES LEADERS
IN OUR NATION TO EMBRACE THE
UNITED NATIONS TREATY ON THE
PROHIBITION OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
SIMILAR TO THE RESOLUTION AND
JUST PASSED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WINTERS THIS SPEAR HEADS A
GLOBAL EFFORT TO PREVENT NUCLEAR
WAR.
THIS RESOLUTION ALSO CALLS UPON
OUR LEADERS TO END ANYONE SO
AUTHORITY TO LAUNCH A NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
SINCE THE HEIGHT OF THE COLD WAR
THAT ENDED STATES AND RUSSIA
HAVE DISMANTLED MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND NUCLEAR WARHEADS THAT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND OF THESE
WEAPONS STILL EXIST AND POST A
RISK. TO HUMAN SURVIVAL.
CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
PASSED SIMILAR RESOLUTIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG LED THE
NATION ON IMPORTANT POLICIES
LIKE THIS AND WE MUST YOU SO
AGAIN THIS TIME ON A CRITICAL
ISSUE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS THANK
YOU ARE STUCK THE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AMOUNTS SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A WOULD YOU LIKE
CO AUTHORS.
THIS AMOUNTS ASKING THAT THE
PRESSURE OF THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK LOCAL THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WISHING TO ADDIS CO AUTHORS ON
AG OR THIRTY THREE THIS IS CO
AUTHORS.
KARP WELL.
CLOSE RATHER FORTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ADDED.
WE'LL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
CARPOOL OPEN ROLL-ON.
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
RESOURCES OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS
VETERANS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLES HIGH THEM A NICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED WORK FILE
ITEM.
TO FORTY SIX A SEE ARE TWO SIXTY
OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTY BY FAMILY MEMBER LOW
AND OTHERS BUILT OF A GENDER
NEUTRAL LANGUAGE.
MR LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR TO
SIXTY IS SUPPORTED BY ALL EIGHT
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND SETS THE INTENDED FOR
CALIFORNIA BEER.
A MORE INCLUSIVE.
SOCIETY FOR TRANSGENDER AND NON
BINARY INDIVIDUALS BY ADOPTING
THE USE OF GENDER NEUTRAL
PRONOUNS AND NEEDS LEGISLATION.
IT WILL ALSO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF MADE TO A GENDER PRONOUNS OUT
WHEN PRESENT.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN MAKING
CALIFORNIA MORE CLUES A STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR A CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HE'S
HERE TO SIXTY THIS IS CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE FORTY FOUR
CO AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY SEVEN ACR TWO SEVENTY
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SEVENTY BY SOME A MEMBER
ACOSTA WELL TO THE PET FIRE
SAFETY [inaudible]
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO INTRODUCE A SEE
ARE TWO SEVEN ZERO SPONSORED BY
THE A SPC A RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF ARTICULATING
PRACTICAL STEPS FOR ALL PET
OWNING HOUSEHOLDS TO PROTECT
THEIR PETS.
IN THE EVENT OF A FIRE.
EVERY YEAR OVER FORTY THOUSAND
PETS DYING HOUSE FIRES AN
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE AFFECTED BY
FIRES.
DURING THIS TIME WHERE MANY --
PARTS OF OUR STATE ARE
EXPERIENCING FIRE HITS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE IT IS PET
OWNERS TAKE TIME. TO ENSURE
THEIR SAFETY WITH THIS
RESOLUTION WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER EDUCATE
PET OWNERS WHICH I AM ONE AS
WELL.
ABOUT TAKING PREEMPTIVE STEPS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE PLANS
IN PLACE IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY.
ON JULY FIFTEENTH ERROR OF EVERY
YEAR THE NATIONAL VOLUNTEER FIRE
COUNCIL PROVIDES PET OWNERS WITH
FREE PET SAFETY WINDOW CLINGS
MAKING IT EASIER FOR SOMEONE
ELSE TO IMPLEMENT.
A SAFETY PLAN IF THE PET OWNER
ISN'T THERE AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION.
OUR PETS LIKE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
WE SHOULD ALL BE AWARE OF THE
STEPS WE CAN TAKE TO PROTECT OUR
LUCK BELOVED PETS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
AND REQUEST FOR THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MR KOSS'S ASSN
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ADDED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS A
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY EIGHT THAT BRINGS US.
TO FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY NINE ACR TWO SEVENTY
THREE QUACKERY ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO WOMEN
SMALL BUSINESS MONTH.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
I AM PRESENTING ACR TWO SEVEN
THREE WHICH WOULD DESIGNATE THE
MONTH OF OCTOBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS WOMEN SMALL
BUSINESS MONTH.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN OWNED BUSINESS
HAS INCREASED BY 45%.
RATE FIVE TIMES FASTER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF ALL
BUSINESSES.
EVEN THOUGH WOMEN MAKE UP 40% OF
NEW ENTREPRENEURS AND THE UNITED
STATES THERE IS STILL TOO FEW
FEMALE INVESTORS AND START UP
ENTREPRENEURS.
MAKING IT MORE CHALLENGING TO
RAISE MUCH NEEDED CAPITAL.
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESS A KEY TO
OUR OVERALL ECONOMIC SUCCESS
IT'S ESSENTIAL WE ENCOURAGE ALL
CITIZENS TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WOMEN SMALL
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WOULD WE PRESS THE FIRST
ROLE WE ARE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE REST OF THE AUTHORS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
AS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
COAUTHORS HEADING ON ACR TWO
SEVENTY THREE THIS IS CO
AUTHORS.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WHAT OF PASS RETAIN A FILE ON?
TWO FIFTY THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM TWO FIFTY ONE ACR TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER ARAMBULA ABILITY TO THE
PROGRAM OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
ACR WO SEVENTY EIGHT RECOGNIZES
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS CAL
PAYS MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
ACR TWO SEVENTY EIGHT THE PACE
STANDS FOR THE PROGRAM OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF THE FRAIL
ELDERLY AND DISABLED ADULTS AGED
FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER.
THE PAY SMALL LITTLE IS A FULLY
INTEGRATED MODEL OF CARE THAT
PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE HIGHLY
COORDINATED CARE.
FOLLOWING FRAIL ELDER ADULTS WHO
MEET STATE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
FOR NURSING HOME LEVEL OF CARE.
TO CONTINUE LIVING IN THAT
COMMUNITY.
THE FIRST CAL PACE WAS STARTED
IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE THEIR ARE NOW
ELEVEN PACE PROGRAMS OPERATING
IN THIRTY NINE SITES AND TAKING
CARE OF SEVEN THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS.
I ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE HERE
TODAY AND FOR THE FIRST ROLE TO
BE OPEN TO CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE RESOLUTION THEY OFFER
SHASTA VIRTUAL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
THIS IS CO AUTHOR MEMBERS
COAUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR COAUTHORS ADDING ON
THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY TWO
COAUTHORS AT A WITHOUT OBJECTION
WITH WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WHAT A PASS RETAIN FILE ITEMS TO
FIFTY TWO TO FIFTY THREE AND?
TWO FIFTY FOUR MEMBERS WE ARE AT
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM. TWO FIFTY FIVE IS S.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY SIX FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL [inaudible]
SURE GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF TAKING UP AMENDMENTS
TO ASK ME.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX THESE
AMENDMENTS DETAIL AND CLARIFY
THE TYPES OF FIREARMS
ATTACHMENTS MADE ILLEGAL BY OUR
LAW AGAINST MULTI BURST TRIGGER
ACTIVATORS.
MORE POPULARLY KNOWN AS BOMB
STOCKS AN ADD CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
GABRIEL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YOU GUYS HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS.
NOW TO PRANCE AND BACK ON FILE.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ON FIFTY SIX
THROUGH.
TWO FIFTY NINE THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY THIS IS S. B.
NINE FORTY SIX CORKERY.
SENATE BILL NINE FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE SIDEWALK VENDORS.
MR GARCIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
PRESENT TO YOU S. B. NINE FORTY
SIX BY SENATOR LARA.
SAVE SIDEWALK BENDING ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ACROSS THE
STATE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WORK A SIDEWALK VENDORS
SELLING FOOD AND MERCHANDISE ON
PUBLIC SIDEWALKS OR PUBLIC
PARKS.
IT STARTS SEEN THESE PEOPLE FOR
WHO THEY ARE WOMEN IN SENIOR
SINGLE PARENTS AND MICHAEL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
TAKING THE FIRST STEP
[inaudible] TO START.
STARTING THEIR OWN BUSINESS HERE
IN OUR GREAT STATE.
THEY DON'T COME LOOKING FOR A
HANDOUT THEY ARE BEGGING ON THE
STREETS.
THESE VENDORS ARE WORKING PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO BE PART OF THE
FORMAL ECONOMY.
THEY DON'T WANNA WORK IN THE
SHADOWS THEY WANT TO PLAY BY THE
RULES.
AND THEY WANT TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
FOOD AND GOODS THEY SELL IS
OFTEN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
FEEDING THEIR FAMILIES.
PAY THE RENT OR BECOMING
HOMELESS.
BUT TOO OFTEN OUR LAWS TREAT
THEM AS NUISANCE OR CRIMINALS.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IMPOSE AN
OUTRIGHT PROHIBITION ON ALL
SIDEWALK BENDING WHILE OTHERS
IMPOSE ONEROUS RESTRICTIONS THAT
SEVERELY LIMITS SIDEWALK
BENDING.
RELEGATING VENDORS TO THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
PERMITS ARE OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE TO
OBTAIN AND VENDING WITHOUT A
PERMIT IS PROSECUTED AS A CRIME.
THIS CONVERSATION OF SIDEWALK
BENDING A SIGNIFICANT AND
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES
ESPECIALLY IN LOW INCOME
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY MANY VENDORS REPORT
THEIR EQUIPMENT AND OTHER
PROPERTY HAVE BEEN CONFISCATED
DURING ENFORCEMENT COUNTERS
CREATING A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL STRESS.
A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FOR ST
BENDING CAN CARRY SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES FRONT DOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS AND VENDORS.
PROSECUTION MAY INCLUDE ME
INCREASE AND A DOCUMENT
RESIDENTS PRIORITY FOR REMOVAL
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
PRIORITY ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN
IF THEY ARE NOT ULTIMATELY
CHARGER CONVICTED.
S. B. NINE FORTY SIX WILL ALLOW
A LOCAL AUTHORITY TO ADOPT THE
SIDEWALK BENDING PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO ADEQUATELY ENFORCE ANY
SIDEWALK BENDING VIOLATIONS.
PROVIDE THAT ANY VIOLATION OF
LOCAL SIDE WHAT BEEN THE RULES.
SHALL BE SUBJECT TO AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY PROGRAM
INSTEAD OF A MISDEMEANOR OR
INFRACTION.
ESTABLISH MINIMUM SAFETY
STANDARDS TO GUIDE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN INITIATING THE
SIDEWALK BENDING PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
VULNERABLE SIDEWALK VENDORS AND
CREATE NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND THE
NECRONOMICON MOBILITY WHILE
STILL PRESERVING LOCAL CONTROL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINGS GARCIA MISTER MAYES.
THANK YOU SIR SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE FORTY SIX THE AMERICAN
SPIRIT IS AT THE HEART OF THIS
MEASURE BY PROMOTING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND UPWARD MOBILITY OF LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
WELL MANY OPERATE WITH A SELLERS
PERMIT AND BUSINESS LICENSE
THESE HARDWORKING INDIVIDUALS
ARE REGULARLY MET WITH ARBITRARY
HURDLES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BY
JURISDICTIONS.
THEY WOULD RATHER RAISE REVENUE
THROUGH PENALTIES AND FINES
INSTEAD OF TAXES AND FEES.
THERE'S NO REASON LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD BE
EXCESSIVELY FIND IT MADE
CRIMINALS FOR PURSUING A MODEST
LIVING LIVING.
DO PERSONAL WORK ETHIC WHICH IS
FUNDAMENTALLY AT ODDS WITH THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT THAT RUNS
STRONG IN OUR STATE.
AND IN THIS COUNTRY.
S. B. NINE FORTY SIX BOUNCES
FAIRNESS AND PROSPERITY IN A
BROADER LEVEL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THOUGH.
THANK YOU MISTER MEN'S.
MISS AGUILAR CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE FORTY SIX A PATH TO
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS IMPORTANT IN
THIS BILL WILL HELP THOSE WHO
CAN'T ALWAYS STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES.
BY DECRYPTING ALLIES THING
SIDEWALK MENDING AND CREATING A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THIS BILL
WILL STIMULATE ECONOMIC MOBILITY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME
IMMIGRANTS AND WORKERS.
I SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND I ASK
YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
BECAUSE THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES.
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTY ONE SP [inaudible]
FIVE THIRTY ONE WE WILL.
WE JUST ONE MOMENT [inaudible]
GREGORY.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AND ACTUALLY
LOCAL EMERGENCIES DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBER.
S. B. FIVE THIRTY ONE IS --
BACK [inaudible]
FROM.
THE SENATE HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THE CLEARING STATES OF EMERGENCY
IF THE JURISDICTION OF A PORT
FALLS UNDER A LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WAS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TIE THAT I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS. ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE WANT TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTY TWO PASS AND RETAIN
TO SIXTY THREE WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM.
TO SIXTY FOUR S. J. OUR TWENTY
TWO CORKERY.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
TWO BY SENATOR HUESO AND OTHERS
BOLTED TO THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU STR TWENTY TWO WOULD
URGE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
U. S. A I'D BE WC. TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO THE
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS CROSS BORDER
POLLUTION IN THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHEN THE LARGEST BILLS OCCURRED
RESULTING IN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE MILLION GALLONS OF RAW
SEWAGE FLOWING INTO THE TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY.
IN THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS OF THIS
YEAR ALONE AT LEAST SEVENTEEN
SPILLS HAVE OCCURRED AND AT
LEAST THREE MILLION GALLONS OF
WASTEWATER HAVE BEEN DUMPED
CLOSING DOWN BEACHES AND CREAM A
SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN
FOR RESIDENTS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AS CHAIR TWENTY TWO WOULD DEMAND
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE U. S. I BWC TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTIONS ON THIS ENVIRONMENTAL.
ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IT'S TIME. FOR THEM TO
BUILD THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DIVERT DIVERT
CAPTURE AND TREAT WASTEWATER
TRASH AND SEDIMENT FLOWING INTO
THE TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY
PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
OF RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO WITH
APPRECIATION TO OUR SENATOR FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR OFFERING THIS.
AND WE'RE UNITED SAN DIEGO
DELEGATION CALLING ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE LONGSTANDING
CROSS BORDER POLLUTION ISSUES
ARE THAT AFFECT MY DISTRICT
ACUTELY.
THE CITIES OF IMPERIAL BEACH IN
CORONADO REGULARLY HAVE THEIR
STATE BEACH IS CLOSED CHILDREN
ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS THEIR
BEACHES THERE'S NOT AN ABILITY
TO ENJOY CLEAN WATER ARE OPEN
PUBLIC SPACES BECAUSE IT IS
ONGOING.
ENVIRONMENTAL CATASTROPHE THEIR
FEW ISSUES THAT ANIMATE SAN
DIEGANS MORE THAN THIS ISSUE
BEFORE US TODAY AND WE WANT TO
POINT OUT FOR ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE THE CLOSURE
OF THE SPEECH IS ALSO A DIRECT
IMPACT ON OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
BECAUSE IT DIRECTLY AFFECTS THE
NAVAL TRAINING OPERATIONS FAR
UNITED STATES NAVY SEALS ARE
THIS IS AN URGENT ISSUE THIS A
BODY HAS APPROPRIATE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO HELP ADDRESS THIS.
BUT THE LACK OF FEDERAL ACTION
ON THIS MATTER IS --
UNACCEPTABLE I ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE VOTE AGAIN EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO OUR GREAT
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA SEEM NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER WOULDYOU
LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
REST.
FIRST ROLE WE OPENED FOR CO
AUTHORS ARMY.
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION IT'S CO
AUTHORS.
THIS FOR CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY FOUR
CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS A SJR
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
AND TELL THE VOTE.
EYES.
SIXTY NOSES ZERO THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS I RECOGNIZE A FORMER
MEMBER THE LEGISLATURE AND
CONGRESSMAN [inaudible]
JIM COSTA.
CONGRESSMAN CASA WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTY FIVE S. B. NINE FORTY
SEVEN CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINE FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
[inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB.
NINE FORTY SEVEN THIS MEASURE
CALLS ON THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. TO THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION. TO CONVENE AN
ADVISORY PANEL TO PROMOTE
DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP.
INTERNET SAFETY AND MEDIA
LITERACY FOR OUR STUDENTS
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT MEDIA
AND THE INTERNET ARE TOOLS TO
SUPPORT LEARNING.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO MANY DANGERS
THAT OUR STUDENTS FACE WITHOUT
THE PROPER KNOWLEDGE OF HOW TO
USE THESE TOOLS AND HOW TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN FROM HARM
THAT CAN COME FROM SOME OF THE
BEHAVIORS.
THAT HAVE BEEN --
ENACTED BY --
CYBERBULLYING PRIVACY ISSUES AND
FAKE NEWS.
OF THIS RESOLUTION CALLS ON
EDUCATORS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
OUR STUDENTS IN THIS EVER
CHANGING DIGITAL LANDSCAPE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER THURMAN MISS MELENDEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE
A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
I I NOTICE IN THIS BILL THAT IT
TALKS ABOUT --
PERHAPS.
TRAINING WHEN IT COMES TO
DISINFORMATION OR FAKE NEWS AS
YOU STATED.
AND I WHAT IS UNCLEAR TO ME IS
HOW.
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WHOEVER THAT IS --
IS ASK HER THAT MIGHT END UP
BEING --
WHAT WOULD MAKE THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IN EXPERTS?
ON IDENTIFYING WHAT IS TRUE AND
WHAT IS FALSE WHEN IT COMES TO
NEWS OR THINGS OF THAT NATURE
WOULD REQUIRE SOME SORT OF
SPECIAL.
TRAINING BECAUSE I AM TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
HOW THIS TRANSLATES INTO OUR
SCHOOLS GIVEN THAT OUR TEACHERS
HAVE A DEGREE IN A CERTAIN YOU
KNOW AREA THEY'RE NOT EXPERTS
ON?
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW WHAT'S TRUE
AND WHAT'S NOT YOU HAVE THE
PEOPLE IN THIS LEGISLATURE CAN'T
DO THAT EITHER IN PEOPLE IN THE
NEWS FRANKLY IT'S NOT EASY SO.
IF YOU DON'T MIND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
I THINK YOU TO THE QUESTION OF
THIS MEASURE DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE SUPERINTENDENT TO BE THE ONE
DIRECTING.
TRAINING BUT TO CREATE A PANEL
OF EXPERTS TO STAKEHOLDERS.
WHO CAN USE BEST PRACTICES AND
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT?
SUPPORT EDUCATORS WILL SUPPORT
STUDENTS TO BE SAFE OUT WHILE
FAKE NEWS IS ONE OF THE EXAMPLES
REFERENCE THE PRIMARY CONCERN IS
HOW TO KEEP KIDS SAFE FROM CYBER
BULLYING.
AND FIGHTS AND SEXTING IN THINGS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE'S MIS UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO USE MEDIA HAS CAUSED SOME
YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE HURT.
AND LET'S FACE IT EVERYTHING
THAT HAPPENS IN THE MEDIA IS A
PERMANENT ACTIVITY SO WHY NOT
GIVE OUR STUDENTS MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE SAFE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO.
THANK YOU MISS THURMOND.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MR THURMAN WE CAN TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES IF YOU WISH
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
OUR PUBLIC.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
RESERVE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL YOU ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY THREE NO.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
RIGHT TO PASS A RETAIN FILE
ITEM.
TWO SIXTY SIX WE A RED FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY SEVEN SP TWELVE FORTY
FIVE THE COURT READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH COVERAGE.
MS LIMON EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS S. B. TWELVE OF FORTY
FIVE WOULD ALLOW COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE EMERGENCY
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY FOR NEARLY
ALL OF ITS REGULATORY PACKAGES
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THIS ATTER WOULD
ALSO ENSURE THAT THERE WOULD BE
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE PUBLIC TO
REVIEW AND COMMENT ON THE
PROPOSED REGULATIONS.
AHEAD OF THEM BEING ADOPTED BY
THE COVER EXECUTIVE BOARD.
AS THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
STABILIZE.
IT IS EXPECTED THAT COVERED
CALIFORNIA WOULD CONTINUE TO
EFFECTIVELY TRANSITION TO THE
PERMANENT RULE MAKING PROCESS.
HOWEVER CURRENT FEDERAL POLICY
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THE ACA
INDICATE THAT THERE WILL
POTENTIALLY BE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE RULES.
GOVERNING HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE IS LIKE COVERED
CALIFORNIA IN COMING YEARS.
DO THE POTENTIAL FOR FUTURE
CHANGES OF THE ACA AND OTHER
RELATED REGULATIONS COVERED
CALIFORNIA MAY BE REQUIRED TO
CREATE AND ADAPT REGULATIONS
MORE QUICKLY.
THAN IS POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
PERMANENT RULE MAKING PROCESS.
WITHOUT THIS TIMELY AUTHORITY
COVERED CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS
COULD CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL LAW
WHICH HAS THE POTENTIAL TO HARM
ITS ABILITY TO PROPERLY SERVE
THEIR MORE THAN THREE MILLION
CONSUMERS.
IN ORDER TO PROPERLY RESPOND TO
THE CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVELS SP TWELVE FORTY
FIVE WOULD ALLOW COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE EMERGENCY
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY. FOR
NEARLY ALL OF ITS REGULATORY
PACKAGES UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SECOND.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AMONG.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
COR CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE THAT EYES.
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THAT
MEASURE PASSES. ONE A PASS
TEMPERMENT PASS RETAIN ON FILE
IN.
TWO SIXTY EIGHT WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM TO SIXTY NINE SP FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR HEALTH AND
ACTUALLY DID DISCRIMINATION
[inaudible]
MS IRWIN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
PROTECT VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
AND ENSURE THAT LANDLORDS CANNOT
DENY HOMELESS VETERANS HOUSING
BASED SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT
THEY RISEN WE RECEIVED.
A RENTAL ASSISTANCE VOUCHER.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR HEROES ARE NOT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN HOUSING
AND ARE NOT HIS DENIED HOUSING
BECAUSE OF HOW THEY PAY THEIR
RENT THANKFUL.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLE ANTI VOTE EYES.
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
TO SEVENTY OR FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO SEVENTY ONE S. B. TEN
SEVENTY NINE CROCKERY.
CYNICAL TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR MONNING AND OTHERS AND I
PLAYED A FOREST RESOURCES DEPEND
URGED THE ARABS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS CURRENTLY CAL FIRES IN
THE PROCESS OF GIVING OUT.
BUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF GRANTS FOR FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT AND FIRE PREVENTION.
BUT THOSE CANCER GIVEN ARE
CURRENTLY ON A REIMBURSEMENT
BASIS THEY'RE GIVEN TO NON
PROFITS AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
BECAUSE OF THE REIMBURSEMENT
NATURE THAT MONEY IS NOT MOVING
VERY QUICKLY.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR MINING WOULD ALLOW THE
COW FIRE CHIEF CAO FIRE TO GIVE
THE THIS MONEY OUT AS GRANTS
THERE BY GETTING THE MONEY INTO
THE HANDS OF THOSE WHO NEED TO
QUICKLY.
IN ORDER TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
COURSE MANAGEMENT AND FIRE
PREVENTION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MICHELLE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTED AS ARROGANT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE [inaudible]
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WANNA
[inaudible]
SORRY.
I SIXTY NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES.
PAST RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TO
SEVENTY TWO INTO SEVENTY THREE
THAT BRINGS US TO FOLLOW.
TO SEVENTY FOUR S. B. NINE
TWENTY NINE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE ON NINE TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY TO
SPECIAL DISTRICTS [inaudible]
MR BLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I SP
NINE TWENTY NINE AS A IMPORTANT
BUT RELATIVELY SIMPLE BILL THAT
FOCUSES ON TRANSPARENCY.
AND UP FOR MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ANAHEIM I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT --
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
NOT EVEN PAYING ATTENTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER TWO THOUSAND
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THAT OPERATE.
VITAL SERVICES FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUCH AS WATER WASTE
WASTE WATER FIRE PROTECTION
PARTS IN TRANSIT.
BUT YOU MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN
KNOWING OR NOT THAT LESS THAN
HALF OF ALL THOSE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS HAVE WEBSITES IN THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE EVERY
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICT TO
CREATE.
A WEBSITE WITH SPECIFIC AND
DETAILED INFORMATION BY JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY THE BILL WILL HELP
SHINE A LIGHT ON THE MISSION OF
THESE DISTRICTS AND PROVIDE THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY.
THAT THEY DESERVE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK OF THE RUN ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TIME BUT
AYE SIXTY NINE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
TO SEVENTY FIVE WHAT FOLLOWED TO
SEVENTY SIX S. B..
EIGHT NINETY NINE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES
APPORTIONMENT OF PERMANENT
DISABILITY IN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
A PORTION IS THE PROCESS USED TO
ACCOUNT FOR PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS THAT ARE NOT RELATED
TO THE WORKPLACE INJURY.
BUT THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
INJURED WORKERS DISABILITY.
THE BILL PROHIBITS THE USE OF
RACE GENDER OR ETHNICITY AS A
FACTOR IN APPORTIONING AN
INJURED WORKERS PERMANENT
DISABILITY.
THIS BILL REFLECTS A NEGOTIATED
COMPROMISE AMONG STAKEHOLDERS.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK MISS DALY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LOVE IN THE WRONG ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS A
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TO SEVENTY
SEVEN THROUGH.
TWO SEVENTY NINE WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM.
TO EIGHTY THIS IS S. B. TEN
SIXTEEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TEN
SIXTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI.
MISTER MURATSUCHI ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M TAKING
AMENDMENT TO SP.
TEN SIXTEEN MM AS TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED NO NO NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH WORSE IF YOU SEEN
NO.
DISCUSSION DEBATE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINCE
AND BACK ON FILE.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TO
EIGHTY ONE AND TWO EIGHTY TWO
WHERE I'D FILE ITEM.
TO EIGHTY THREE S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTEEN KERKORIAN SENATE
ELEVEN THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
MONNING AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN
THE MENTAL HEALTH.
MISS CORREO YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN THIRTEEN
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR.
MINING S. B. ELEVEN THIRTEEN
WILL AUTHORIZE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. TO
WORK WITH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
EXPERTEN MENTAL HEALTH.
AND PSYCHOLOGISTS TO CRAFT A
VOLUNTARY STANDARD FOR MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE WORKPLACE.
THE COMMISSION PROVIDES
LEADERSHIP TO ENSURE THE AT
MENTAL HEALTH IS ESSENTIAL TO
OVERALL HEALTH AND TO PROMOTE
WELLNESS RECOVERY AND RESILIENCY
FOR ALL PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT EFFECTIVE
INVESTMENTS IN THE WORKPLACE
MENTAL HEALTH AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
SAFETY CAN REDUCE COSTS ENHANCE
EMPLOYEE WELL BEING.
AND ORGANIZATIONAL SUCCESS FOR
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL COMBATS
MENTAL HEALTH STIGMA INCREASES
AWARENESS OF MENTAL HEALTH
PREVENTION OPPORTUNITIES AND
PROMOTES MENTAL HEALTH WELLNESS.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS CARILLO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE KNOWS TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'RE GONNA PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS TO EIGHTY FOUR IN.
TO EIGHTY FIVE WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM TWO EIGHTY SIX THIS IS S.
B..
NINE FIFTY FOUR CORPORAL RATE.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI ACTUALLY TO
MEDIATION [inaudible]
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
NINE FIFTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING A CLIENT
MEDIATION TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
DISCLOSURE.
ON THE CONFIDENTIALITY
RESTRICTIONS IN MEDIATION AND
OBTAIN A SIGNED A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT THE CLIENT HAS READ
AND UNDERSTOOD THOSE
RESTRICTIONS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ZERO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COURT WILL OPEN THE RIGHT ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TIME BUT
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
I'LL ORDER TO I TO S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT MCGUIRE
BUYER DONALD MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
ACTUALLY THE MINOR WORK PERMITS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL --
MANY SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SP FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WILL PROHIBIT
THE DIAL OF A SCHOOL WORK
PERMIT.
ON THE BASIS OF A STUDENT'S
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE OR TENANTS
IF THE STUDENT IS SEEKING THE
WORK PERMIT TO PARTICIPATE.
IN A GOVERNMENT ADMINISTERED
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING PROGRAM
--
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THIS BILL
HAS NO NO VOTES.
SEEING NO REQUESTS TO SPEAK
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
OUR VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I DON'T THINK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SIXTIES NO ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING BACK AND FILE ORDER TO
ITEM TWO EIGHTY SEVEN SP
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE MCGUIRE BY
WOULD THAT A QUICK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY
THE CIVIL ACTIONS SOME MEMBER
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THINKING THAT A SPEAKER ILLEGAL
TIMBER LAND CONVERSION
VIOLATIONS OF JUMPED OVER 2100%
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE MEDICAL
MARIJUANA REGULATION.
REGULATION SAFETY ACCENT ACT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN RISING FROM
THIRTY IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TO NINETY NINE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF CALIFORNIA
FOREST LAND HAVE BEEN ILLEGALLY
CONVERTED. TO ILLEGAL CANNABIS
GROWS THIS YEAR HAVE THIS
REPREHENSIBLE ACTION IS POLLUTED
PRISTINE WATERSHED THREATEN
DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES.
KILLED COUNTLESS WILDLIFE AND IS
PUSHING THE PACIFIC MISTER TO
EXTINCTION DUE TO THE ILLEGAL
RODENTICIDE SUSAN SEVERAL OF
THESE GROSS SITES.
INTERPRET CAO PRIOR TO
THOROUGHLY INVESTIGATE ROAD
CANNABIS GROWS S. B. FOURTEENTH
FIFTY THREE EXTENDS THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATION FOR REAL ILLEGAL
FORCED CONVERSIONS.
WHICH ARE DEVASTATING
CALIFORNIA'S POOREST FROM ONE
YEAR TO THREE YEARS.
THIS WILL BRING IT IN LINE WITH
FISH AND WILDLIFE'S STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR SIMILAR
VIOLATIONS RELATED THE STREAMBED
ALTERATIONS WHICH OFTEN OCCUR IN
CONJUNCTION WITH VIOLATIONS OF
THE FORCE PRACTICE ACTIN RULES.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BRIGHT
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TO EIGHTY EIGHT
SP ONE SEVENTY FOUR MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
SP ONE SEVENTY FOUR SEEKS TO
MAKE CHANGES IN KEY CODE
SECTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN IN OUR
BOOKS FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS A REQUIRE
CRITICAL REVISION.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REVISED
IS AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION
IN THE STATE DEFINING CITIZEN OF
THE STATE IN ORDER TO INCLUDE
THE CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS WERE
BORN IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS
PASSED RESTRICTIONS ON WHO COULD
SERVE IN APPOINTED SYMBOL
OFFICES SUCH AS THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
FIVE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
COMMISSION AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING.
S. B. ONE SEVENTY FOUR WOULD
ALLOW FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO BE APPOINTED TO IN
SERVE ON THESE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS.
SINCE THE BILL IS BROUGHT IN
ALLOWING ALL IMMIGRANTS TO SERVE
IT TO FIRST TO FEDERAL LAW
REGARDING PAID WORK FOR EXAMPLE
IF AN IMMIGRANT IS NOT HAVE WORK
AUTHORIZATION THEN UNDER THIS
BILL THEY WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO SERVE IN AN APPOINTED CIVIL
OFFICE.
THAT IS A PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT.
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS HAVE VERY
STRICT REQUIREMENTS TO SERVE
INCLUDING OBTAINING CERTAIN
LICENSES AND UNDERGOING
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
PEOPLE WOULD STILL NEED TO MEET
EVERY ONE OF THESE REQUIREMENTS
TO BE ELIGIBLE TO SERVE ON A
BOARD OR COMMISSION.
BY PROVIDING IMMIGRANTS THE
OPPORTUNITY SERVE ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS CALIFORNIA BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THE TALENTS OF ALL OF
OUR RESIDENTS MAKER GOVERNMENTS
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE HEALTH
WELL BEING AND SAFETY OF EVERY
INDIVIDUAL.
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBERS SHOT AS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
S. A. A GROUP QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WHY DON'T YOU ASK YOUR QUESTION
SHE CAN RESPOND IN HER CLOSING
ONE LOOKING AT THE BOARD TO
COMMISSION I THINK HURTS FROM
IMPORTANT I WANTED NO --
MANY TIMES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WE HAVE --
COMMITTEES THAT COME OUT OF THE
CITY COUNCIL THAT ARE VERY
INVOLVED THE COMMUNITY LIKE.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEES UTILITY
COMMITTEES [inaudible]
WITH.
IS THAT REFERRING TO THOSE
GROUPS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO OTHER REQUESTED SPEAKS
ALL I'M.
SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
YOU MAY ANSWER BRIEFLY AND THEN
WE'LL RETURN TO MISTER SCHABAS.
I I I I WILL CHECK ON THAT I
BELIEVE THIS IS JUST STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS SO
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT OF TO SHUT US.
DIMITRY RESPONSE DO LIKE I CAN
SEE THE GREAT VALUE OF THAT THE
LOCAL COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ARE THE VALUE
IS CITIZENSHIP I SPOKE VERY
STRONGLY AGAINST.
NON CITIZEN JURIES BUT AND THE
COMMITTEE SPECIAL LOCAL CITIES I
CAN SEE THE GREAT VALUE IN
TRYING TO GET THE COMMUNITY
INVOLVED VESTED PUBLIC SAFETY
THINGS SO THAT'S WHY I ASKED THE
QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME EVER CARILLO YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
AS A PRINCIPAL CHO AUTHOR OF SP
ONE SEVENTY FOUR AS AN IMMIGRANT
FROM INSIDE Y. THOUGH IT AND A
FIRST JUNE GENERATION AMERICAN
I'VE WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD TO
GET TO WHERE I AM TODAY AND I
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS A PATH FOR
MANY.
PEOPLE.
I ALSO WAS INCREDIBLY LUCKY TO
HAVE HAD A PATHWAY TO RESIDENCY
AND CITIZENSHIP.
BUT NOT ALL IMMIGRANTS ARE THIS
FORTUNATE SOME IMMIGRANTS LIKE
THE MANY HARD WORKING PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT HAVE LIVED AND
WORKED.
THEIR WHOLE LIVES UNABLE TO
PURSUE PUBLIC SERVICE THAT OUR
STATE CONSOLE MUCH BENEFIT FROM.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WE SHOULD
ENCOURAGE NOT FAR FROM SERVING
OUR STATE.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS SAID AGAIN
AND AGAIN THAT WHERE YOU ARE
BORN SHOULD NOT BE AN OBSTACLE
TO GETTING AN EDUCATION APPLYING
FOR PROFESSIONAL LICENSE OR
PURSUING YOUR DREAMS.
S. B. ONE SEVENTY FOUR TO
CRITICAL MEASURE THAT SOLIDIFIES
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP.
IN AN AREA OF IMMIGRANT
ACCEPTANCE AND INTEGRATION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE WHO
CONSERVE IN THE LEGISLATURE OR
WHO CAN VOTE.
IT DOES ALLOW QUALIFY IMMIGRANTS
TO APPLY TO BE APPOINTED TO
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AND SERVE
OUR STATE IN THAT WAY.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE MUST OPEN
UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
AND AMPLIFY THEIR VOICES THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I WANTED TO
PROVIDE AN ANSWER TO OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM OCEANSIDE SO.
OUT THIS IS DRESSES ARE
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO CIVIL
OFFICES OF ONE IN WHOSE
POSITIONS CREATED BY
CONSTITUTION OUR STATUTE --
WHERE THE PERSON HOLDS A
POSITION IS DELEGATED WITH SOME
SORT OF SOVEREIGN FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT THERE ARE MANY LOCAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEES THAT ARE NOT
CAPTURED IN THAT SO?
UP MANY OF US --
HAVE COMMITTEES WHERE NON
CITIZEN IMMIGRANTS ARE ALLOWED
TO SERVE --
I THINK ME WITH ALL HAD VERY
GOOD EXPERIENCES WITH THAT --
IN ALLOWING FOLKS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS TO TAKE PART IN A
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I WILL SAY IS A
CO AUTHOR THIS BILL I'M
SUPPORTING THIS IN PART BECAUSE
THIS WAS LANGUAGE THAT WAS
WRITTEN SPECIFICALLY. TO EXCLUDE
CHINESE AMERICANS AND OTHER
IMMIGRANTS FROM PARTICIPATION IN
CIVIC LIFE OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEARS AGO AND IT WAS
WRITTEN AT A TIME WHEN WE WERE
LIVING IN A VERY DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK EVERYONE WILL KNOW IN
OUR STATE THERE WERE DAYS WHEN
IF YOU WERE --
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS IF YOU'RE OF
JAPANESE AMERICAN DESCENT IF
YOU'RE CATHOLIC I COULD GO ON
AND ON ARE YOU WERE BARRED FROM
FULL PARTICIPATION IN SOCIETY
AND ULTIMATELY THIS IS A BILL.
ABOUT GOOD GOVERNANCE AND
ENGAGING AND CIVIC THE PATIENTS
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE --
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WAS ANSWERING THE SAME QUESTION
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM OCEANSIDE
WAS ASKING I BELIEVE --
NOW AND HAVING.
CONVENIENTLY TEXTED WITH THE
ACTUAL AUTHOR ON THIS BILL WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING IS WILL THIS NOW
APPLIED TO THOSE LOCAL BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS ARE LOCAL
ADVISORY AND IT WILL IT WILL
APPLY TO EVERYTHING IN AND CIVIL
GOVERNMENT SO.
I THINK ALTHOUGH RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE SOME RESTRICTIONS IN
DIFFERENT CITIES THAT WILL --
OVERRIDE THESE RESTRICTIONS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ABOUT.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR A MINUTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE NO.
TWENTY THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO NINETY FOUR
SP ONE HUNDRED MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE HUNDRED WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU ON THE AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER THANK YOU SB ONE
HUNDRED WOULD SET A NEW CLEAN
RENEWABLE ENERGY TARGET FOR
CALIFORNIA AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING ANY TURNOUT
CO AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'LL BE
TAKING A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ON
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO
PRETTY BACK ON FILE.
I DON'T TO NINETY FIVE SB NINE
THIRTY ONE ADEQUATE PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR SENATOR HERTZBERG
ACTUALLY CONSERVATIVE SHIPS.
THINK YOU WERE SOME MEMBER JONES
SAWYER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT S. B.. NINE THREE ONE
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG WHICH MAKES
IT EASIER TO ESTABLISH A L. P.
S. CONSERVATORSHIP FOR AN INMATE
AT A COUNTY JAIL.
S. B. NINE THREE ONE WILSHIRE TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS WILL NOT HAVE
THEIR EVALUATION. FOUR LPS
CONSERVATORSHIP DELAY BECAUSE OF
THEIR CUSTODY STATUS S. B. NINE
THREE ONE WILL ALSO CLARIFIED
THAT MEDICAL STAFF PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT TO AN
INMATE IN A COUNTY JAIL.
CAN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
CONSERVATORSHIP.
ONLY 30% OF CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED INMATES RECEIVE
TREATMENT FOR SOME FORM OF
MENTAL ILLNESS AN INCREASE OF A
150% SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND S. B. NINETY ONE
HAS HAD NO NO VOTES AND ENJOY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
NO MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAME CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES BY
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS.
TO NINETY SIX TO THREE HUNDRED
PASS AND RETAIN ITEM THREE
ONE S. B. THIRTY MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTY BY SENATOR
LARA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY TO
INSURANCE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
OR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THIS
BILL BY SENATOR LARA.
DIRECTS THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER TO CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP.
WHICH WILL RECOMMEND POLICIES TO
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT IN NATURAL
RESOURCES TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
LOSSES FROM CATASTROPHIC EVENTS
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN ADDITION THIS WORKING GROUP
WILL CONSIDER POLICIES.
WHICH PROVIDE MITIGATION
INCENTIVES FOR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IN NATURAL LANDS. TO
LESSEN EXPOSURE AND REDUCE
CLIMATE RISK TO PUBLIC SAFETY
PROPERTY UTILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
ANY NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
TWO NO TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS THREE A TWO TO THREE OR
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM THREE OH FIVE S. B. SIX
NINETY ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY ONE
EXPLICITLY INCLUDES IMMIGRATION
STATUS AS A PROTECTED CLASS
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S EQUITY IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION ACT.
THIS MEANS THAT ALL PERSONS IN
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING ARE ENTITLED TO EQUAL
RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS FROM
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
THIS BILL MIRRORS LEGISLATION
FROM LAST YEAR WHICH GAVE THE
PROTECTION TO OUR K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS MAKE CLEAR
THAT NOTHING IN THIS ACT SHALL
BE CONSTRUED TO REQUIRE A
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTION TO
OFFER ADMISSION.
OR STUDENT FINANCIAL AID TO SIR
NOT NON IMMIGRANT FOREIGN
STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS WORKED TO ENSURE
THAT UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IN THE SAME WAY OTHER
RESIDENTS ARE ABLE TO DO SO. FOR
EXAMPLE WHILE NOT EXCLUSIVELY
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AB
FIVE FORTY EXAMS CERTAIN
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS FROM PAYING
NON RESIDENTS TUITION AT OUR
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS.
IF THEY MEET SPECIFIED CRITERIA.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY ONE WILL
REINFORCE CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO ALL PEOPLE WORKING
TO FURTHER THEIR EDUCATION.
OUR SCHOOLS SHOULD BE AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE AND
COMMITTED TO THE EDUCATION OF
ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
HAS A SHORTAGE OF WORKERS IN A
VARIETY OF SPECIALIZED
PROFESSIONS INCLUDING DOCTORS
AND TEACHERS.
WE NEED TO REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
ANYONE WHO IS WILLING ABLE AND
QUALIFIED TO AND TO ENTER INTO A
SPECIALIZED PROFESSIONAL FIELDS
TO STRENGTHEN OUR WORK FORCE.
WE SHOULD NOT STAND IN THE WAY
OF ANY STUDENTS TRYING TO BETTER
THEMSELVES WITH THE POWER OF
EDUCATION.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY FIVE NO SEVENTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM THREE OH
SIX S. B. SEVEN TWENTY ONE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR HELEN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY BUILDING STANDARDS
THANK YOU SOME OF OUR GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR --
HEAL THE SENATE BILLS ON SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH REQUIRES
APARTMENT BUILDINGS WITH THREE
OR MORE UNITS TO HAVING A 15%.
OF THE BALCONIES INSPECTED H. R.
EVERY SIX YEARS EMERGENCY
REPAIRS.
WOULD NEED TO BE MADE
IMMEDIATELY BUT BUILDING OWNERS
WOULD HAVE FOR MONTHS. TO GET
THE PERMIT AND UP TO SIX
ADDITIONAL MONTHS TO MAKE A NON
EMERGENCY REPAIRS THIS IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE.
THAT I WANT TO BRING TO MY
COLLEAGUES ATTENTION ON SOME OF
US HAD OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
IRELAND.
WHERE WE WERE --
VISIT IT [inaudible]
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO LOST THEIR
CHILDREN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
REMEMBER BERKELEY. TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ON A BALCONY WORKED
STUDENTS WERE.
KILLED OR A BALCONY COLLAPSE
ALSO IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
A STAIRWELL AT AN APARTMENT
BUILDING IN CITY OF FOLSOM ALSO
COLLAPSED KILLING.
OF ACCOUNTS POLLY MASTER STUDENT
THAT WAS VISITING A FRIEND --
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT PROTECT --
ANY STUDENTS WEATHER'S BALCONIES
OR STAIRWELLS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN --
SUPPORT --
OPPOSITIONS HAVE BEEN REMOVED
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE FOR SENATE BILL.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
QUICKLY IS OPEN THE RUN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES.
I IS FIFTY NINE AND NO THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM THREE OH SEVEN THROUGH
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN ITEM THREE
OH NINE S. B. EIGHT THIRTY THREE
NOT A QUICK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU A
SUMMARY OF YOUR CURRY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE THING IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO S. B. EIGHT THREE
THREE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
MCGUIRE.
S. B. A THREE THREE WILL CREATE
GUIDELINES FOR EMERGENCY
EVACUATION ALERT STATEWIDE THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL EXPAND THE LIST
OF GROUPS INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE GUIDELINES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE TEN S. BE
NINE TWENTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU
SOME MEMBER RAISE YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER NUMBERS
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR SKINNER AYE
PRESENT SB.
NINE TWENTY SIX A BILL WHICH
PROTECTS CAL WORKS AND CAL FRESH
PARTICIPANTS FROM LOSING
BENEFITS WHEN LEAVING UNSAFE
WORKPLACES.
CURRENT LAW SUSPENDS THE
BENEFITS OF PARTICIPANTS WHO
VOLUNTARILY QUIT EMPLOYMENT
WITHOUT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
UNLAWFUL CONDITIONS SUCH AS
HARASSMENT AND WAGE THEFT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY PRESERVES THE
BENEFITS FOR THREE MONTHS WHEN A
WORKER LEAVES THE JOB BECAUSE OF
UNLAWFUL CONDITIONS.
AND REQUIRES COUNTIES TO INFORM
PARTICIPANTS OF RIGHTS AND
REMEDIES AS WORKERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS.
NINETEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM THREE ELEVEN S. B. NINE
SIXTY FIVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY FIVE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS
AND I CLEAN FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
MAKING A PREPARATION THERE.
FOR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AS SPEAK. NINE SIXTY
FIVE BY CENTER MCGUIRE.
STRIDES TO INSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE CATTLE
INDUSTRY.
HAS THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
CONTINUE TO BE.
EXCEPT FOR HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY SB NINE SIXTY FIVE
ALLOWS FAMILY CATTLE RANCHERS
THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND DECIDE ON
WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY WANT TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLE COUNCIL.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM THREE TWELVE S. B. TEN
EIGHTY FIVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALLED AROUND.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER CALDERON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER S. B.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE RECOGNIZES
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE STEWARDS FOR
THEIR UNION SOMETIMES.
I NEED TO TAKE TIME OFF THEIR
FROM THE REGULAR JOBS PERFORMED
UNION.
RESPONSIBILITIES CENTER SKINNER
HAS AGREED TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CONCERNS FOR US TO ALLOW THE
REIMBURSEMENT BY THE EXCLUSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATION.
AS SHALL BE MADE WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS AFTER RECEIPT OF THE PUBLIC
AGENCIES CERTIFICATION OF
PAYMENT OF COMPENSATION TO THE
EMPLOYEE THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
SERVICE CREDIT A STEWARD CAN
EARN SHALL NOT EXCEED TWELVE
YEARS.
AND ALSO REMOVE SUPERVISORS IN
STATE EMPLOYMENT WHO ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO WRAP UP BY A UNION
THANK YOU KNOW RESPECT WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE MOVING TO
ITEM THREE THIRTEEN S. B..
TEN NINETY MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ CYNICAL TEN NINETY BY
SENATOR MONNING AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA ELECTRICITY THANK YOU SO
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
S. B. TEN NINETY REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE COMMISSION TO
APPROVE ELEMENTS OF THE JOINT
PROPOSAL SUBMITTED FOR THE
RETIREMENT.
THE DIABLO CANYON NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS INCLUDES
A FULL FUNDING OF THE WORKFORCE
EMPLOYEE RETENTION PACKAGE.
AND THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
MITIGATION FUNDS.
AND DIRECTS THE CPUC TO MANAGE
ITS INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN TO
ENSURE THERE IS NO INCREASE IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AS A RESULT OF THE PLANTS
RETIREMENT THE SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS HAS BORNE THE RISK OF
HAVING THIS PLANT.
IN ITS COMMUNITY FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS HOWEVER MINIMAL THAT
RISK HAS BEEN.
WELL THE ENTIRE STATE IN
PARTICULAR THE PGD RATEPAYERS A
BENEFITTED.
FROM THE CLEAN ABUNDANT POWER
IT'S PROVIDED.
THIS BILL GIVES US A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO TRANSITION SMOOTHLY TO
A POST YABBA FUTURE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR ENTIRE
STATE.
IT IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THROUGH NUMEROUS COMMITTEES AND
I RESPECTFULLY --
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THINK.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FIVE NOSE ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE FOURTEEN S.
B. ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY
DO IT ENERGY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
NOT THANK YOU SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR BRADFORD.
SP ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE WILLED CHO
DEFIED THE FAMILY ELECTRIC RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR FARAH.
AND ENERGY SAVINGS PROGRAM FOR
CONSUMERS.
FARAH ASSIST FAMILIES WITH A
HOUSEHOLD INCOME BETWEEN.
TWO HUNDRED AND 210050% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE THE PROGRAM
PERMANENT.
INCREASED A DISCOUNT FROM
12218%.
THIS BILL ALLOWS IOUS.
THAT IS INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
TO INCREASE THEIR MARKETING
OUTREACH EFFORT. TO RAISE
CUSTOMER PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROGRAM.
SPELL IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER PURPOSE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
I DON'T QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY SIX NO SEVENTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
SOME MEMBER CALDERON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER INTO TO TAKE UP
S. B. TEN HERTZBERG WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
SOME EVER WALDRON WE OPPOSE THE
MOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REQUIRES US A SECOND A SUMMER
GIPSON SECONDS THE MOTION.
IT HAS THIS MOTION IS THIS
MEASURE THIS MOTION IS NOT
DEBATABLE IT REQUIRES FORTY ONE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS OF CALDERON IS OUT.
I VOTER SOME.
FREE NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
TWENTY FIVE THE MOTION PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE FIFTEEN SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO I BEG YOUR
PARDON MEMBERS.
PERMISSION WAS GRANTED TO TAKE
UP S. B. TEN WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO THE FILE.
ADEQUATE PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND ACTUALLY IN A PRE
TRIAL RELEASE AND ATTENTION.
WAS A MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S. B..
TEN BY OUR COLLEAGUE IN THE
SENATE SENATOR BOB HERTZBERG
BAIL REFORM.
COLLEAGUES WITH S. B. TEN WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM.
A BROKEN.
UNJUST UNFAIR UNSAFE.
PORTION OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REPLACE IT WITH SOMETHING MORE
FAIR.
AND MORE SAFE THAT IS BASED ON
AND INDIVIDUALS UNIQUE RISK THAT
THEY POSE FOR FLIGHT.
OR TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS WILL BE A PARADIGM
SHIFTING.
MOVING THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM [inaudible]
WHOSE TIME [inaudible]
HAS COME.
WE WILL BE MOVING FROM A MONEY
BASED SYSTEM TO A RISK BASED
[inaudible]
SYSTEM.
OUR CURRENT MONEY BAIL SYSTEM
[inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM JUDGES
INDIVIDUALS BY [inaudible]
THE SIZE.
OF THEIR WALLET.
INSTEAD OF THE SIZE OF THEIR
RISK.
IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
[inaudible]
FREEDOM [inaudible]
AND LIBERTY.
IS PAY TO PLAY.
IF YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY.
AND YOU CAN PAY FOR IT YOU CAN
BE FREE.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR SAFETY RISK
REGARDLESS OF THE RISK OF
FAILING TO SHOW FOR YOUR NEXT
HEARING.
IF YOU DON'T.
AND EVEN IF YOU WILL.
SHOP AGAIN NEXT HEARING AND THE
COURT HEARING AFTER THAT.
AND EVEN IF YOU ARE NO RISK TO
THE PUBLIC.
YOU WITH WAGE ALLEN LANGUISHING
IN JAIL.
AND THAT IS WRONG.
AND WE CAN CHANGE IT TODAY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
RECOGNIZED.
WIDELY THROUGHOUT THE NATION AND
FROM LEADERS RIGHT HERE IN THE
STATE [inaudible]
OUR CURRENT [inaudible]
CHIEF JUSTICE.
JUST THE TONIC UNTIL SAKU UNIT
KNOWS THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN SHE
CALLED IT UNSAFE [inaudible]
AND UNFAIR.
A REPORT THAT SHE COMMISSION
FOUND THE SAME.
AND RECOMMENDATIONS WERE MADE
THAT.
LARGELY HAVE BEEN ADOPTED AND
OUR BILL I DON'T GOVERNOR. FORTY
YEARS AGO.
SAID THAT THE BILL IS A TAX ON
POOR PEOPLE.
IN CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LANGUISH IN
THE JAILS IN THE STATE EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVEN'T.
THERE BEEN CONVICTED OF NO CRIME
THEIR ONLY CRIME IS THAT THEY
CANNOT MAKE THE BAIL THAT ARE
PRESENT LAW REQUIRES.
IN COLLEGE THE HUMAN IMPACTS ARE
DEVASTATING.
WHEN INDIVIDUALS WHO POSE NO
RISK TO THE PUBLIC?
BUT DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
LANGUISHING IN JAIL.
SO MANY DEVASTATING THINGS CAN
HAPPEN TO THEM IN THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEY HAVE.
AND IT WILL CONTINUE UNLESS.
WE TAKE ACTION TODAY
[inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS CAN.
LOSE THEIR JOBS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE STUCK IN JAIL
AND CAN SHOW UP FOR WORK.
THEY CAN LOSE THEIR CARS BECAUSE
THEY'RE PARKING A TIME LIMITED
AREA.
AND IT GETS TOTAL WAY.
AND THEY NEVER SEE IT AGAIN.
THEY CAN LOSE THEIR HOMES
[inaudible]
IF THEY'RE IN JAIL THE CAPITA
MORTGAGE ARE THEIR RENT THE CAN
EVEN LOSE THEIR KIDS IF THEY'RE
SINGLE PARENT IS KNOWN TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR KIDS.
ALL BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THEY
POSE NO RISK.
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY IN THE
POCKET.
AND EVEN THOSE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH
TO PAY BAIL.
SUFFER AND SUFFER MIGHTILY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO SCRAPE TOGETHER
THE AVERAGE.
I AM REFUNDABLE BAIL AMOUNT OF
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR AMOUNT BAIL.
THEY OFTEN HAVE TO FORGO PAYING
OTHER BILLS.
OR OTHER THINGS FOR THEIR FAMILY
[inaudible]
AND COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
AS THIS.
CURRENT BROKEN SYSTEM HAS
CREATED.
SUCH UNFAIRNESS SUCH INJUSTICE.
IT ALSO HAS FAILED TO MAKE US
SAFER.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BASED ON
SAFETY.
IT'S NOT BASED ON ONE'S RISK.
IT'S BASED ON WEALTH.
AN ARBITRARY AN IRRELEVANT
FACTOR [inaudible]
UNRELATED. TO RISK AND SAFETY
[inaudible]
PEOPLE.
WHO DON'T SHOW FOR FUTURE COURT
HEARINGS AND WHO WON'T SHOW FOR
A A FUTURE COURT HEARING AND ARE
A SAFETY RISK?
CAN PAY TO GET OUT.
IF THEY CAN POST THE BELL.
THE MONEY BAIL SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO RELEASE PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SAFETY RISK
IF THEY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY.
AS LONG AS THEY PAY THAT STEVIE.
WITH NO REGARD.
DO DANGER TO THE PUBLIC AND WITH
NO CONSEQUENCE TO THE BAIL
BONDSMAN IF THAT PERSON WHO WAS
RELEASED ON THEIR BELT BOND.
TIMES A MEMBER.
OF THE PUBLIC.
SO WHAT IS THIS BILL DEAL.
IT MOVES US.
IN A FAIR DIRECTION.
A SAFER DIRECTION.
EVERY INDIVIDUAL IS TREATED AS
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT GIVEN AND
RISK ASSESSMENT OF BY A
VALIDATED TOOL.
THERE ARE PRETRIAL SERVICES THAT
ARE PUT IN PLACE TO OVERSEE WHEN
SAFE THEIR RELEASE INTO THE
COMMUNITY WITH THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE CONDITIONS.
INDIVIDUALS NO LONGER HAVE TO
PAY FOR ANY OF THOSE CONDITIONS
THAT OFF TO PAY FOR THEIR
ELECTRONIC MONITORING IF THAT'S
A CONDITION OF THEIR RELEASE
THAT I HAVE TO PAY FOR OTHER
CONDITIONS. FOR CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ARRESTED FOR
LOW LEVEL NON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT
--
MISDEMEANORS WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS WITHIN TWELVE HOURS
THEY'LL BE RELEASED BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY SAFELY.
OTHERS WILL GET A RISK
ASSESSMENT BY TREETOP PRETRIAL
SERVICES THEY WILL BE DESIGNATED
EITHER LOW RISK.
OUT WHICH IS A MINIMAL RISK
MEDIUM RISK WHICH IS A MODERATE
RISK OR HIGH RISK WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT RISK FOR LOW RISK
OFFENDERS.
THEY WILL BE RELEASED BACK INTO
THE COMMUNITY WITH THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE NAM MONETARY
CONDITIONS SAFELY.
AND FOR THOSE IN MEDIUM RISK
CATEGORIES SOME WILL GO TO A
JUDGE SOME COULD BE RELEASED AT
THE PRETRIAL SERVICES LEVEL.
AND THEN FOR THE HIGHEST RISK --
INDIVIDUALIST THEY'LL GO TO A
JUDGE.
AND THERE THEY WILL HAVE DUE
PROCESS TO BE REPRESENTED BY AN
ATTORNEY THEY'LL HAVE A HEARING
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR CASE
THE BE ABLE TO PRESENT THE FACTS
ARGUMENTS --
THE CONTEXT OF OF WHO THEY ARE
--
TO A JUDGE AND BE DECIDED ON
BASS DOESN'T BASED ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL.
OF FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES NOT
BASED ON HOW MUCH MONEY.
THEY HAVE IN THEIR POCKET AND
THESE CHANGES WERE GUIDED BY
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS WITH SOCIAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOLKS.
BY JUDICIAL OFFICERS AND CIVIL
LIBERTARIANS AND EVERYONE IN
BETWEEN.
AND WE RELY ON THE DEEP DIVE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DID TO HELP
GUIDE.
THIS POLICY THAT WILL MAKE US
SAFER.
AND WILL BE MORE JUST
[inaudible]
AND COLLEAGUES THIS.
BILL REALLY RELIES ON SOME OF
THE FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLES OF
WHO WE ARE AS A STATE.
AND AS A NATION.
THAT OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
SHOULD NOT BE.
PAY TO PLAY THAT ONE'S WEALTH.
SHOULD NOT BE AN OBSTACLE. TWO
ONE'S LIBERTY.
THAT WE SHOULD BE TREATED AS
INDIVIDUALS.
AND ASSESSED BASED ON WHAT WE'VE
DONE OR NOT DONE THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHO WE ARE
BASED ON OUR CONDUCT OUR
BEHAVIOR.
AND NOT BE SUBJECTED TO SOME ONE
SIZE FITS ALL BAIL SCHEDULE THAT
RENDERS THE INDIVIDUAL
INVISIBLE.
AND TREAT YOU AS A NUMBER OR
POCKETBOOK OR AN ATM.
AND THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THEIR CASE
BE REPRESENTED BY AN ATTORNEY
[inaudible]
AND PRESENT ALL THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY WISH TO
A NEUTRAL ARBITER.
BECAUSE THIS IS.
A HUGE CHANGE FOR THE BETTER.
THIS IS TRANSFORMATIONAL.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TODAY.
SEIZE THE MOMENT.
AND DO SOMETHING THAT WILL MAKE
CALIFORNIA A SAFER.
THAT WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
FAIR.
THAT WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
JUST.
WE PRIDE OURSELVES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN LEADING IN GOING FIRST IN
MAKING THE BIG CHANGES.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TURN
THE PAGE ON A FAILED BROKEN
[inaudible]
UNSAFE UNFAIR.
MONEY BASED SYSTEM.
IT'S A MOVE TOWARDS A RISK BASED
SYSTEM.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
TEN THANK YOU IT SOME MEMBER
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
WE HAVE ORDER PLEASE.
SOME MEMBER LACKEY.
YEAH THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW I HEARD FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR THAT THIS
BILL REFORM WAS GOING TO BE A
PRIORITY.
BUT YET HERE WE ARE TWO WEEKS
OUT.
AND THIS GETS WORKED A FOR HOW
DESPICABLE.
SOMETHING HAS A CRITICALLY IS A
BUT IMPORTANT.
AS HOW WE HOLD PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALLEGEDLY
COMMITTED VERY VERY DANGEROUS
OFFENSES.
BUT BECAUSE OF A BROKEN SYSTEM
WE HAVE THIS HURRIED POLICY THAT
WE'RE GONNA JAM TOGETHER.
HOW DO WE LEARN FROM OUR
MISTAKES IN THE PAST WILL YOU
DONE THOSE KIND OF HURRY POLICY?
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ARE
SEVERE PEOPLE.
VICTIMS VICTIMS ARE REAL.
I HAD THE UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF FACING SOME OF
THESE VICTIMS.
AND TELLING THEM THE WORST THING
POSSIBLE.
THEIR LOVED ONE IS GONE.
AND I KNOW NO.
ONE WHO IS CRAFTED THIS BILL HAS
THE DESIRE TO STE TO HAVE THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WILLIS
JUST TALK ABOUT THIS BILL FOR
JUST A SECOND.
THE ONLY WAY SOMEONE.
STAYS IN JAIL.
IS THAT THE PROSECUTION PUTS ON
A LITTLE MINI TRIAL.
AND THEN THE TRIAL THEY HAVE TO
PROVE WITH CLEAR CONVINCING
EVIDENCE.
BUT THAT PERSON IS A DANGER TO
THE PUBLIC OR A FLIGHT RISK.
OTHERWISE EVERYONE ELSE GETS
OUT.
FOLKS THAT IS NOT GOOD POLICY.
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THIS.
I TOTALLY AGREE.
THERE ARE BILL SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
AND WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER.
COLLECTIVELY [inaudible]
CALMLY.
AND IN IT ANY UNIFIED.
WELL THOUGHT OUT PROCESS.
NOT A HURRIED.
PANICKY OF THE POLICY LIKE THIS
IS COMING TO US.
WE COULD DO BETTER THAN THIS AND
WE HAVE.
TO I ASK YOUR NO VOTE.
IF YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER.
A COUPLE OF POINTS I WANT TO
RISE TO IN REGARDS TO THIS ONE I
THINK THAT THE A MISDEMEANOR SEX
OFFENDERS WILL BE RELEASED.
WITHOUT A RISK ASSESSMENT
ASSESSMENT UNDER THIS BILL THE
BILL'S EXEMPTION LANGUAGE ON
THIS POINT IS A LOOSER HE SINCE
IT REFERS TO THE OFFENSES THAT
ARE NOT MISDEMEANORS.
AND WOULD HAVE NO RISK
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE THEM TO
BE HIGH RISK.
IT REFERS ALSO TO THE PROVISION
OF LAW WHICH DOES NOT TAKE
EFFECT UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT MANAGE
VICAR MEMBERS.
BILL BETTER INSURERS OFFENDERS
SHOW UP IN COURT THAN THIS
SYSTEM HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OF THE 540-005-0090 EIGHT
WARRANTS IN THE SYSTEM. TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX OUR OWN
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN RELEASED
ON BAIL THE BALANCE OF THE
540-003-0050.
TWO HAVE BEEN RELEASED ON THEIR
OWN RECOGNIZANCE BAIL IS A
BETTER WAY OF ENSURING OFFENDERS
APPEAR AND IF THEY DON'T GETTING
THEM BACK IN COURT.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A RISKY.
POTENTIAL SYSTEM UNDER THIS
BILL.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD
BE PUTTING THE LIVES.
AND THE HEALTH AND THE WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIAN
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK BY PASSING
THIS BILL I STRONGLY URGE A NO
VOTE.
SOME EVER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GOT. THREE POINT THREE ARGUMENTS
TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY IN THE
HOPES THAT SOME OF YOU ARE
SITTING ON THE FENCE.
THINK DEEPLY ABOUT THE JUMP THE
LEAP YOU'RE ABOUT TO MAKE.
ON BEHALF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST ARGUMENTS REALLY HAS
TO DO WITH THE PROCESS AS MY
COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT.
YOU LOSE SOMETHING IN MAKING
LEGISLATION WHEN YOU RUSH IT.
YOU LOSE THE ABILITY TO TO
DELIBERATE TO BRING IN EXPERTS
BRING IN PEOPLE THAT KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SOME OF YOU AND I DON'T MEAN ANY
OFFENSE BUT SOME YOU PROBABLY
DON'T KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN JAIL BAIL AND A BALE OF
HAY.
AND THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT A
SLIGHT.
THAT'S THAT'S A REALITY WE'RE
ALL TRYING TO MAKE POLICY IN A
COMPLEX DIVERSE ENORMOUS STATE
WITH FORTY MILLION PEOPLE AND
AND THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS
TO DELIBERATE AND BRING IN
EXPERTS AND THINK ABOUT THINGS
AND RUN THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
THAT WE ALL TRUST TO RELY ON I
COME OUT THE OTHER SIDE WITH.
THOUGHTFUL LEGISLATION AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH.
AND THIS IS NO SMALL CHANGE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE IF YOU DON'T
WORK IN THIS INDUSTRY THIS IS A
GIANT [inaudible]
GIANT WIFE CHANGING LIFE
ALTERING CHANGE. FOR EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA.
YOU CAN'T JUST TAKE WHAT'S BEEN
DONE IN NEW JERSEY AND NEW
MEXICO COPY AND PASTED TO
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE BIGGER WERE MORE DIVERSE
WE HAVE UNIQUE CHALLENGES UNIQUE
LAWS AND UNIQUE PROBLEMS AND
DIFFICULTIES.
THE SECOND POINT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS TO ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
THIS WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT A
BILL.
A BILL THAT HAS BEEN RUSHED IN
THE PROCESS TO THE FOR WHEN THE
OPPOSITION GROUPSINCLUDE.
THE ACLU.
THE END DOUBLE ACP.
THE BAIL BONDS COALITION LET'S
PROBABLY OBVIOUS.
LOTS OF SHARES FROM AROUND THE
STATE.
LOTS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS
FROM AROUND THE STATE.
POLICE CHIEFS IN CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED WAS IT SAY DOES THAT TELL
YOU IS THAT THE INDICATION OF A
FULLY BAKED BILL IS THAT THE
INDICATION.
OF A POLICY THAT WE CAN ALL GET
BEHIND SINCE WE'RE CHANGING.
THE ENTIRE STRUCTURE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TODAY.
LASTLY TO THE MERITS THE BILL
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
I'M NOT I'M NOT HERE TO THE
BILL'S PERFECT.
THERE'S CHANGES WE CAN MAKE
THERE'S THINGS WE CAN APPROVE.
WE'RE DOING PILOT PROGRAMS ALL
THE TIME.
WHAT'S WRONG THE PILOT PROGRAM.
WHAT'S TRIED OUT FIND THE WORST
PLACE FIND THE COUNTY WHERE IT'S
THE MOST BROKEN WHEREVER THAT
IS.
TRY A PILOT PROGRAM OUT FOR
AWHILE STUDY IT AND SEE IF IT
WORKS.
SEE IF IT ACTUALLY MAKES US MORE
SAFE PEOPLE SEE PEOPLE SHOW UP.
AND NOT FAIL TO APPEAR IN COURT.
UNDER THE NEW RISK ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM.
WE'RE GONNA HAND WE'RE GONNA
THIS IS WHERE DOES.
TRUST ME ON THIS WE'RE GONNA
TAKE POWER AWAY FROM JUDGES AND
AWAY FROM ATTORNEYS THAT THE
CHANCE ARGUE.
WHETHER THERE SHOULD BE BAIL AND
WHAT AMOUNT SHOULD BE SET UP.
AND A JUDGE HAS THE POWER THE
CURRENT SYSTEM TO THE SIDE THAT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE A DAY ARE IN COURT.
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND JUDGES ARE MAKING THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF THESE
DETERMINATIONS BASED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL FACTS IN FRONT OF
THEM.
THE PERSON'S HISTORY WHETHER
THEY FAILED TO APPEAR THE
SEVERITY OF THE CRIME THE RISK
THEY POST THE PUBLIC THAT'S
ALREADY BEING DONE BY A JUDGE
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM THIS
WOULD WHITE MOST OF THAT AWAY.
AND LEAVE THE BUREAUCRACY
[inaudible]
UNDER FUNDED. TO DO EVEN MORE
WORK.
AND I'M SORRY FOLKS YOU CAN'T
REDUCE EVERYTHING IN LIFE TO AN
ALGORITHM. TO A COMPUTER
PROGRAM.
I HAVE SEEN AS A PROSECUTOR AND
AS A AS A CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY I'VE SEEN HUNDREDS OF
CASES WERE RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS.
FAILED THEY FAILED VICTIMS AND
PEOPLE AND DEFENDANTS ON ALL
DIFFERENT SITES.
YOU CAN'T JUST.
TAKE SOMETHING OUT OF A COMPUTER
AND PRESS A BUTTON.
GET A PREDICTION THAT'S GONNA
ALLOW YOU TO MAKE AN INTELLIGENT
CHOICE ABOUT WHETHER SOMETHING
SAFER NOT.
WHETHER SOMEBODY'S GONNA APPEAR
IN COURT OR FLIGHT REST WHETHER
THEY'RE DANGER TO THE PUBLIC.
LASTLY I'D SUGGEST PART OF THE
REASON YOU SEEN SOME OF THESE
GROUPS LIKE THE ACLU.
WHICH I'VE FOUGHT A IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE
FOUGHT THEM ALL SORTS OF BILLS
MA'AM BUT ONCE IN A WHILE THEY
ARE ON POINT.
AND THEY'RE ON POINT WITH THIS.
ONE THIS IS GOING TO LEAD TO
SOME PEOPLE [inaudible]
WHO?
HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING
INCARCERATED YOU KNOW THERE'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO BEAR.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT. TO POST BAIL
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION.
I'M NOT SURE THIS BUILDING
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S A PRE TRIAL DETENTION.
IT HAS A DETENTION BEFORE
ANYBODY A JURY OR A JUDGE HAS
TOLD YOU YOU'RE GUILTY.
IT'S A DEPRIVATION OF LIBERTY
AND YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO POST
BAIL ON ALMOST EVERY OFFENSE
THERE IS.
UNDER THE LAW.
SO YOU CAN WORK WITH YOUR
ATTORNEY AND REMAIN ON
INCARCERATED WILL YOU PREPARE
FOR TRIAL OR GET YOUR CASE
RESULT.
THIS IS GOING TO DIMINISH OUT
RIGHT FOR CERTAIN PEOPLE.
ON THE OTHER SIDE THERE'S GOING
TO BE DANGEROUS PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THAT.
ARE GOING TO BE OUT.
AND ARE GOING TO FAIL TO APPEAR
IN COURT AT THEIR COURT DAY.
THE FAILURE TO APPEAR RATE. FOR
REGARDLESS OF OFFENSE FOR PEOPLE
ACCUSED OF FELONIES IS
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
GO STUDY THAT DATA PLEASE STUDY
THAT IT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PEOPLE THAT
FAIL TO APPEAR.
THAT R. BLASTS TO REMAIN AT
LARGE IN PUBLIC BY BUREAUCRACY.
THE GO OUT DO TERRIBLE THINGS TO
BE.
SOME MEMBER IF YOU CAN BRING
YOUR ARGUMENTS WILL CLOSE YOUR
TIME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES SOUTH FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING IN WHAT
HAS BEEN A LONG PROCESS AND A
AND A CHALLENGING PROCESS AND
LET ME FIRST START BY TALKING
ABOUT PROCESS.
SINCE WE LAST DEBATED THIS ISSUE
ON THIS FLOOR YEAR AGO THERE
HAVE BEEN.
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF MEETINGS
HUNDREDS OF CONVERSATIONS
INVOLVING STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
GOVERNOR. TWO JUDGES TO MEMBERS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO FOLKS WHO
FIGHT FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
THE PROGRESSIVE VALUES OF WATER
STATER ABOUT.
A AND I WANNA THANK MISTER BONTA
AS WELL AS THE SENATE AUTHOR
THIS BILL FOR THEIR WORK ON
SINCE WE LAST VOTED ON THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL.
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY SO FOR THE FIRST TIME
WE'RE GONNA BE ENSURING THAT
HIGH RISK DEFENDANTS NO LONGER
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO BAIL BACK
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK WE'VE
ALL FOUND OFFENSIVE ABOUT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THE FACT IS IF
YOU'RE WEALTHY.
YOU CAN BUY [inaudible]
FREEDOM.
THAT A POOR PERSON CANNOT THAT
IS GONNA CHANGE IN THIS BILL
WERE ALSO ENSURING THE VICTIMS
RIGHTS OR STRENGTHENING
SIGNIFICANTLY.
WITH NOTICING PROVISIONS
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS
REQUIREMENTS THE DA'S MAKE BEST
EFFORTS TO NOTIFY VICTIMS TO
ALLOW FOR THE VOICING OF VICTIMS
IN OUR SYSTEM.
I KNOW AND I VERY MUCH RESPECT
THE PERSPECTIVE THE FORMER
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
OUR BODY I WILL SAY AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR.
IT ALWAYS PAINED ME WHEN I KNEW
THAT THERE WERE POOR PEOPLE AND
OUR SYSTEM BUT BECAUSE THEY WERE
POOR HAD TO SIT IN JAIL.
WHO WOULD LOSE THEIR HOMES WHO'D
LOSER FAMILIES WHO WOULD LOSE
PROPERTY WHO WOULD LOSE OUR
HEALTH?
WHO WOULD GET BACK IN THE
ENDLESS CYCLE OF POVERTY AND
CRIME THAT IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO CHANGE TODAY?
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CONSTITUTION I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE?
THAT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROVISION THE PRINCIPLE OF
INNOCENCE BEFORE BEING PROVEN
GUILTY.
IN THIS STATE ONLY APPLIES IF
YOU'RE WEALTHY.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO EQUAL PROTECTION HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY CHALLENGE BECAUSE
THE MONEY BILL SYSTEM.
LET ME ALSO SAY AND I WILL SAY
THIS IS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL.
THIS MAY NOT BE THE PERFECT
IT MAY NOT GO AS FAR AS PEOPLE
MAY WANT EITHER TO THE SO CALLED
LEFT OR TO THE SO CALLED RIGHT.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
I WAS HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THAT WE HAD TO VOTE ON LAST YEAR
BUT THAT'S NOT THE BILL WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US.
THIS BILL TRIES TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN ALL THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CONFRONTED WITH.
BUT WE NEED.
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD
COLLEAGUES I HOPE.
THAT YOU WILL JOIN US IN MAKING
HISTORY TODAY TO END A MONEY
BILL SYSTEM.
THAT HAS VIOLATED CONSTITUTIONS
THAT HAS ENSURED THAT POOR
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO REMAIN
VICTIMIZED IN OUR STATE.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM DID NOT
START WITH S. B. TEN IT'S NOT
GONNA END WITH S. B. TEN WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS.
THIS BILL HAS MANY MANY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
STUDY PERFECT TO MAKE IT BETTER.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY I HOPE
WE CAN ALL JOIN.
IN TAKING A STEP FORWARD IN
REFORMING A SYSTEM THAT IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF REFORM.
AS ROBERT F. KENNEDY SAID FIFTY
YEARS AGO.
MADAM SPEAKER PERMISSION TO
READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION ONLY ONE
FACTOR DETERMINES WHETHER
DEFENDANT STAYS IN JAIL BEFORE
IT COMES TO TRIAL.
THAT FACTOR IS NOT GUILT OR
INNOCENCE IT IS NOT THE NATURE
OF THE CRIME.
IT IS NOT THE CHARACTER OF THE
DEFENDANT.
THAT FACTOR SIMPLY IS MONEY.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS --
YOU KNOW WHEN THIS BILL FIRST
CAME UP.
I DIDN'T SUPPORT IT I DID VOTE
FOR IT BECAUSE I'M TERRIFIED.
I AM TERRIFIED THAT I AM BECOME
THE COMMUNITY WATCH.
AT MY HOUSE WITH PEOPLE SHOWING
UP.
IN FRONT OF MY DOOR TO TRY AND
STEAL PACKAGES WHEN I'M UP HERE
MY WIFE AND MY CHILD ARE HOME
ALONE.
UNLIKELY I HAVE GREAT MEMBER --
NEIGHBORS AND WE ALL TRY TO LOOK
OUT FOR ONE ANOTHER BUT I'M
TERRIFIED ABOUT BEING UP HERE
NOT BEING ABLE TO BE HOME TO
PROTECT MY FAMILY [inaudible]
SCARES.
AND SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT IS IF I TAKE A VOTE ON
BAIL REFORM.
CAN I HONESTLY SAY THAT I'M
DOING SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA
PROVIDE MORE SAFETY. TO MY
FAMILY WHEN I'M GONE.
AND I REALLY RESPECT THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BY THE AUTHOR I
RESPECT THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM OAKLAND BECAUSE THEY'VE
TAKEN A LOT OF TIME TO SAY THAT
THERE HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH TIME
AND CONSIDERATION PUT INTO THIS
MEASURE THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HAS BEEN A LOT OF TIME PUT INTO
THIS MEASURE I CARE ABOUT
PROCESS MY FATHER HAD A CAREER
OVER TWENTY YEARS IN THIS BY
TALKING ABOUT PROCESS.
THIS PROCESS IS RIGHT THIS
PROCESS IS NO DIFFERENT FROM
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE'VE DONE
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
ALL I WANT.
IS TO KNOW THAT I'M DOING
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE
[inaudible]
MAKES.
MICE CONSTITUENTS SAFER MAKES IN
MY FAMILY SAFER.
WHERE AND WHEN THEY'RE AT HOME?
AND THE PROBLEM THAT I'VE HAD
WITH BAIL AND IN THE ME LET ME
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS --
I HAVE NOTHING AGAINST ANYONE.
I HAVE NOTHING AGANST THE BAIL
AGENTS NOTHING AGAINST THE CO
YOU THIS ISN'T ABOUT WHO
SUPPORTS AND WHO OPPOSES THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT WE DO AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I AM
SICK AND TIRED OF UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IS.
IS THIS ABILITY FOR US TO ALWAYS
JUST PROTECT THE STATUS QUO
BECAUSE WE'RE SO AFRAID OF WHAT
THE CHANGE IS GOING TO BE.
YOU CANNOT CREATE ANY TYPE OF
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE UNLESS YOU'RE
WILLING TO TAKE SOME KIND OF A
RISK TO TRY SOMETHING NEW.
TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
AND I HAVE MY CONCERNS THIS IS
NOT A PERFECT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
BUT I THINK IT GOES FAR ENOUGH.
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAY WE
LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
CRIMES.
HOW THEIR HELD WHY THEY'RE HELD
AND HAVE SOME TYPE OF ASSESSMENT
AND HAVE THIS THE ASSESSMENT ON
THEIR ABILITY TO RE OFFEND BE
THE DETERMINING FACTOR AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE SHOULD BE
OUT?
OR NOT WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
THEIR BILL THE ABILITY TO PAY
SOMEBODY CAN GOING TO AMEND
MURDER GET A MILLION DOLLAR.
BOND SAID AND THEN THEY CAN BAIL
OUT BUT THEIR MURDER AND LOOK AT
THEIR CUES OF BEING A MURDERER
WERE UNDER THIS THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE THAT SAME ABILITY.
AND SO IT'S TAKING A LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT STRUCTURES OF HOW WE
SET.
UP WHETHER THE BAIL SCHEDULE IS
BETTER OR RISK ASSESSMENT IS
BETTER BETTER AND I THINK THAT
IN THIS INSTANCE A RISK
ASSESSMENT IS A FAR BETTER TOOL
TO ASSESS SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO
RE OFFEND OR FAN OR CONTINUE TO
VICTIMIZE AS OPPOSED TO WHETHER
OR NOT THEY HAVE THE MONEY. TO
BAIL THEMSELVES OUT OR NOT AN
ISSUE THAT WAS BROUGHT UP --
WAS THIS THIS THIS ISSUE OF TWO
NINETY IN MISDEMEANOR SEX
CRIMES.
THAT CONCERNS ME BECAUSE I HAVE
A DAUGHTER NOBODY KNOWS I'M
GONNA TELL YOU NOW I HAVE
ANOTHER DAUGHTER ON THE WAY.
AND THAT THAT TERRIFIES ME
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME --
NOW I'VE TALKED TO THE DA'S I
SPOKE TO JACKIE LACEY --
THIS THIS AFTERNOON A SKINNY
THIS MORNING ON MY WAY UP HERE
AND SHE SAID HE AND I NEED YOU
TO PLEASE VOTE ON THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW US TO
MAKE COMMUNITY SAFER.
THIS GIVES US MORE TOOLS TO KEEP
THOSE P. OUR MOST SERIOUS
OFFENDERS FROM BEING UP BAY
BEING ABLE TO GO OUT AND CREATE
COULD COMMIT MORE CRIMES.
AGAINST YOUR CONSTITUENTS
AGAINST YOUR FAMILY ARE AND AND
SO THIS ISSUE OF THE MISDEMEANOR
SEX CRIMES WELL AS IT IS RIGHT
NOW IF THEY CAN CHARGE A FELONY
WELL IF YOU GET CHARGED WITH A
FELONY WHICH IS WHAT THE DA SO
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE GOING.
FOR YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET OUT
BUT ASSUMING THAT YOU DON'T GET
CHARGED WITH A FELONY IT STAYS
THE MISDEMEANOR WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS.
DO YOU END UP GETTING A TWO
THREE HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR BOND ABOUT WHICH
EVERYBODY'S IT IS IS ABLE TO PAY
FOR EVERYBODY'S ABLE TO FORCE OF
THESE PEOPLE ALREADY OUT.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON IS AMENDMENTS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE COMING IN A BILL S. B..
TEN FIFTY FOUR I AND WE'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING TO FIX THIS ISSUE --
MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THEIR CONCERNS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT WE THAT
WE TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
BUT THINK ABOUT THIS.
TOO OWE YOU KNOW WHY DON'T YOU
JUST FIXING OUR YOU KNOW THEIR
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
ARGUMENTS ARE GOING TO BE MADE
ABOUT THIS.
BUT NOTHING IS PERFECT THE FIRST
TIME WE PASS IT IS ABOUT
CREATING THAT'S THAT CHANGED
TAKING THAT FIRST BIG STEP.
ON THE MOON WE PASS ON THIS
FLOOR --
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WITHIN PASSING KNOWING THAT WE
WOULD NEVER COME BACK TO FIX IT
WE PASS AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE GOING TO RISE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO COME BACK
AND FIX AND LO AND BEHOLD THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAD TO DO AND
WE'RE STILL DOING TO FIX LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO MAKE
IT THE BEST POLICY.
POSSIBLE UP BUT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO HERE AND
I THINK THAT.
THE RISK ASSESSMENT IS A FAR
BETTER TOOL THAN BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD A BAIL THE BAIL YOURSELF
OUT OF JAIL I THINK IT'S SAFER
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES I FEEL SAFER
WITH THAT TYPE OF SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY KNOWING THAT MY DE A
IS TELLING ME.
THAT THIS IS WHAT INTO HER
OFFICE CAN DO TO KEEP ME AND MY
FAMILY SAFE I EVEN WHEN I'M NOT
AROUND.
NOTHING'S EVER PERFECT BUT I
THINK IT'S A GOOD FIRST STEP AND
WE CAN'T BE AFRAID OF CHANGE
BECAUSE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
EMBRACE THINGS.
THAT ARE GOING TO HELP US ATON
CREATE A BETTER FUTURE FOR ALL
OF US BETTER FUTURE FOR OUR KIDS
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING ON
HERE FOR IS TO MAKE SURE I MAKE
IT BETTER --
SAFER COMMUNITY FOR MY KIDS I AM
GONNA STAY CONTINUALLY.
COMMITTED TO THIS ISSUE OUR AND
MAKING SURE THAT ANY ISSUES THAT
ARISE THAT WE FIX IT THAT'S OUR
JOB SO WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
IT BUT I THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
AND BECAUSE OF THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
[inaudible]
LOOK.
I'VE BEEN BEFORE YOU PROBABLY
MORE TIMES AND YOU NEVER WANT TO
SEE OPTIMAL JUSTICE AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE.
AS BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN TRUE OR
NOT I BELIEVE IT.
AND I BELIEVE WE NEED TO CHANGE
THE SYSTEM.
THE REASON I GET UP WHEN I WHEN.
WHETHER I LOSE I KEEP COMING
BACK OVER AND OVER AGAIN BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN WHAT THIS SYSTEM DOES
[inaudible] TO DISADVANTAGE
I'VE SEEN WHAT IT DOES TO
FAMILIES AND I'VE SEEN WHAT THE
BAIL SYSTEM HAS DONE.
RIGHT NOW VERY SIMPLY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
REPLACING THE MONEY BAIL SYSTEM
WITH A RISK ASSESSMENT SAYS
[inaudible]
AND PART OF THE BANKS THAT WE
HAVE.
IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WE'LL BE WE
HAVE A WE HAVE SOME COMFORT
LEVEL [inaudible]
BUT BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE THE SIX YEAR RULE WE'VE
GOT ABDICATED OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO IMPLEMENT THINGS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BILLS IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE PUSH.
FOR WILL ACTUALLY READ HAVE THE
RESULT THAT WE WANT BECAUSE
WE'VE ABDICATED THAT FOR SO LONG
[inaudible]
FULLER UNCOMFORTABLE.
I'M MAKING A COMMITMENT THAT
ALTHOUGH THIS MAY NOT BE THE
PERFECT SOLUTION.
A GREAT FIRST STEP.
IT MOVES US IN THE DIRECTION OF
WHAT WE ALL WANT TO BE WANT TO
HAVE IS A FAIR SYSTEM.
AND THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I'VE HEARD FROM BOTH SIDES
[inaudible]
AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE A TWILIGHT
ZONE.
YOU KNOW I HAVE THE ACLU COMING
AT ME SAYING.
WE'RE GONNA LOCK UP MORE PEOPLE
MORE POOR PEOPLE MORE AFRICAN
AMERICAN PEOPLE BE LOCKED UP.
BY THE BILL BONDS PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER SIDE SAY WELL LET A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE OUT.
RAPISTS AND MURDERERS.
IN THAT IRONIC.
YOU GOT TWO DIFFERENT SIDES TO
JUST EXTREME SITE SAME EXACT
OPPOSITE. FOR ME WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW.
STRADDLES RIGHT IN BETWEEN WHERE
WE NEED TO GO START MOVING
TOWARD THAT ULTIMATE GOAL.
LOOK OUT.
I LOVE HISTORY.
YOU KNOW DOCTOR KING WANTED TO
NONVIOLENCE AND IF ANY OF YOU
KNOW.
DURING THAT TIME.
THE IN DOUBLE ACP ALLOW CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUPS SAID HE WAS
[inaudible]
MOVING [inaudible] TOO FAST HE
WAS PUSHING THE AGENDA TOO FAST.
WHILE THE OTHER SIDE THE
PANTHERS IN THE IN IN THE
MATHEMATICS OF THE WORLD WHICH
SEEMS GOING TO SLOW.
AND IT WASN'T FIERCE ENOUGH
INFIGHTING ENOUGH.
DO THE RIGHT THING.
HISTORY HAS PROVED.
THAT NONVIOLENCE WITH THE WAY TO
GO AND I BELIEVE THAT HISTORY
WILL SHOW DAY USING A RISK
ASSESSMENT.
SYSTEM WILL BE THE WAY TO GO
ESPECIALLY.
AND I SAY THIS AGAIN AND AGAIN
[inaudible]
SPECIALLY [inaudible]
THIS BODY.
PUTS THE ELBOW GREASE IT NEEDS
TO ENSURE.
THAT THAT SYSTEM OFFSETS THE
JUDGES MADE TO ASSESS WHAT LAW
MY FIRST* WILL DO BUT
ULTIMATELY WILL ENSURE.
I WILL SAY THIS AGAIN WILL
ENSURE THE SAFETY.
OF EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA.
DISPEL DOES NOT SOLVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS WITH OUR PANEL JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT IT BRINGS ECONOMIC
JUSTICE TO THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
WE CAN DISAGREE ABOUT WHAT MAY
HAPPEN IF THIS BILL PASSES.
BUT HERE'S ONE THING WE CAN ALL
AGREE.
THAT BILL WILL DEFINITELY.
AND A LEGALIZED FORM OF ECONOMIC
DISCRIMINATION BY ELIMINATING
CASH BAIL IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS A FIRST STEP.
I LIKE EVERY BILL WE PASSED.
IS THAT ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION.
SAY IT ALL THE TIME IT'S REALLY
NOT ABOUT LEGISLATION IT'S ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION IF YOU DON'T SEE
IT BEFORE IT MEANS MORE SO RIGHT
NOW DID ANYTHING WE'VE EVER DONE
BEFORE ON THIS FLOOR.
THAT WHEN WE COME BACK.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO HAVE TO
HAVE LEGISLATION TO IMPROVE THIS
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT A FOR TWO
YEARS IS NOT SOME THAT CAME OUT
OF LEFT FIELD.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT NOW AND
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT A
TWO WEEK GET THE SYSTEM.
THAT WE ULTIMATELY WANT.
LOOK DOCTOR KING UNDERSTOOD.
THAT WE CANNOT STAND BY AND LET
THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD.
AND MOST IMPORTANT CONFUCIUS HAS
SAID IS BETTER TO HAVE A DIAMOND
WITH A FLAW.
BEEN A PEBBLE WITHOUT.
MEMBERS I WON A DIME.
S. B. TEN PROVIDES US WITH THE
FOUNDATION TO BUILD A SYSTEM
THAT WILL BE EQUITABLE AND
PROVIDE JUSTICE FOR ALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SAID AFTER A MULTI YEAR DEBATE
ON THE TOPIC I'M PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TOWN WHICH IF PASSED WOULD
CREATE THE STRONG GUESS.
THE MOST JUST.
FAIREST PRE TRIAL SYSTEM OF ANY
STATE.
IN OUR GREAT COUNTRY.
JUST AS WE'VE LED THE COUNTRY ON
OTHER FRONTS AND STARTED
NATIONAL POLICY DISCUSSIONS ON
SUBJECTS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
CIVIL RIGHTS AND GUN CONTROL WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE. TO
LEAD ON THE ISSUE OF BAIL REFORM
IS THE IS THE BILL PERFECT.
I THINK VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY HERE
AGREES FOR DIFFERENT REASONS
THAT IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT THIS
BILL HAS CHANGED SINCE I FIRST
AGREED TO BE A CO AUTHOR.
WITH THE SENATOR FROM VAN NUYS
IN OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ALAMEDA
AND DO I LIKE ALL THE CHANGES NO
I I I I FRANKLY I DON'T.
A BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
DEMOCRACY AS A GEORGE WILL WANT
SAID IS THE POLITICS OF THE HALF
LOAF -- AND
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
HERE WE HAVE A COMPROMISE ON AN
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED BUT
IMPORTANT ISSUE IMPORTANT ENOUGH
FOR THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF OUR
SUPREME COURT. TO SPEAK OUT ON
IT AND AND IF YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT OUR CHIEF JUSTICE SHE
DOESN'T GET UP AND STAND UP ON
JUST ANY ISSUE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
ALL OF US.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
UNDER THIS BILL THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE CHARGED XIN BOOK
FOR CRIME.
WILL BE RELEASED AND A SOUTH STE
UNDER A SYSTEM THAT IS MUCH
FAIRER.
THAT IS A RISK BASED SYSTEM NOT
A MONEY BASED SYSTEM AND UNDER
THIS BILL INNOCENT PEOPLE WILL
NO LONGER BE FORCED INTO GUILTY
PLEAS. TO GET BACK TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR JOBS.
NO I I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OF THOSE FROM BOTH SIDES OF THIS
BELT WE STRIKE AND TRYING ALONG
WITH ALL OF YOU TO UNDERSTAND
THEM.
BUT VOTING FOR THIS BILL TODAY
AS HAS BEEN SAID DOES NOT.
PREVENT US FROM MAKING THINGS
BETTER BUT NOT VOTING FOR THIS
TODAY HAS CONSEQUENCES.
AND THOSE CONSEQUENCES ARE THAT
PEOPLE AND THESE ARE PRIMARILY
LOW INCOME AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WILL CONTINUE TO BE VICTIMS.
OF A SYSTEM THAT MOST OF US IN
THE ROOM.
ARE ACKNOWLEDGING IS A
DISCRIMINATORY AND UNJUST SYSTEM
AND THERE WILL BE LITTLE HOPE
FOR CHANGE IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
MEAN THIS BILL HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSIDERATION FOR AT LEAST TWO
YEARS NOW THERE IS LOTS OF GROUP
THINK AN INDIVIDUAL THINK
INVOLVED IN WHAT.
WE ARE DEBATING HERE TODAY AND
ON BEHALF OF THOSE WHO WILL
BENEFIT.
PLEASE LET'S REMEMBER.
WHO WERE WORKING FOR AND WHO ARE
TRYING TO HELP HERE?
ON BEHALF OF THOSE WHO WILL
BENEFIT FROM THE INCREASED
FAIRNESS THAT'S PROVIDED BY SB.
TEN I RESPECTFULLY JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
[inaudible]
SO.
I HATE THIS PROCESS [inaudible]
I HATE.
HOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT?
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST.
CHANGES AND ARE CURRENT JUSTICE
SYSTEM [inaudible]
AND DECADES.
THROUGHOUT THE WAR PROCESS.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S AN INSULT. TO
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US AS
LEGISLATORS.
THAT THIS LANGUAGE.
IS BEING SPRUNG ON US TO THE
LAST MINUTE.
YOU I'VE BEEN ASKING FOR THIS
LANGUAGE [inaudible] FOR MONTHS.
WHERE IS THE LANGUAGE WHERE THEY
DETAILS?
WE'RE WORKING ON IT SOME GROUP
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING IS CALLING
ME OUTSIDE THE BUILDING. TO SAY
THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON IT.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US?
BUT I WAS DEFERRING.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I WAS
DEFERRING.
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHILE SPOKE WITH
THIS MORNING.
AND I WAS READING WHAT I COULD
OF THIS BILL.
AND I HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA
THAT.
WE DON'T DO SOMETHING.
PEOPLE ARE GONNA CONTINUE TO
SUFFER UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
IT SAID CRAPPIE PROCESS.
BUT I FEEL THE RIGHT THING TO DO
IS TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE I KNOW.
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO ACHIEVE
CHANGE?
I KNOW AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR.
HOW PEOPLE ARE HELD BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T [inaudible]
AFFORD BAIL.
I BELIEVE AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR
THAT [inaudible]
THIS WILL HELP.
STRENGTHENED PUBLIC SAFETY IT
WILL GIVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME. TO TELL US
FIND THESE PRE TRIAL ASSESSMENT
HEARINGS.
THE CRAPPY BILL AND IT'S GONNA
NEED A LOT OF FIXES.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL THOSE FIXES BUT I'M
AFRAID THAT IF WE DON'T BUT ON
THIS BILL NOW IT'S NOT GOING TO
PASS ON TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
--
LIKE SO MANY OF YOU KNOW I RISE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH.
ALWAYS WITH SOME CONCERNS
BECAUSE IT IS A MAJOR STEP FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU MY FIRST ENCOUNTER WITH THE
CONCEPT OF BAIL.
WAS WHEN I WAS A KID.
AND MY FATHER GOT A CALL TO HELP
BAIL SOMEBODY OUT OF JAIL.
THEN THE WHAT THE HECK THAT WAS.
BUT HE'D NEVER JOEY DIDN'T BILL
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL.
WE HAD A PERSON WHO HAD GOTTEN
INTO JAIL BECAUSE I DON'T NO
THEY WERE GAMBLING OR SOMETHING
THAT ONE OF THE GAMBLING PARTIES
IN THE PLEASE USE TO RAID THE
PLACE TO TAKE THESE FOLKS JAIL.
MY FATHER HAD TO A DECIDED TO
GIVE TO THIS BRAILLE FUND FOR
THIS PERSON HE SAID BECAUSE YOU
KNOW.
IF HE DOESN'T GET OUT OF JAIL
THIS WEEKEND HE WON'T HAVE A JOB
ON MONDAY WHEN BOTH MISTER
CHARLIE.
HE'LL LOSE HIS JOB.
AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS KIND OF
UNUSUAL BECAUSE THAT UNDERSTAND
THAT AT THE TIME AS A KID.
BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS OF POVERTY.
BUT IF YOU ARE GENERALLY IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE THESE
JOBS THAT ARE KIND OF LOW WAGE
JOBS WOULD ALSO JOBS WITHOUT A
LOT OF BENEFITS.
IT YOU THEN BECOME THE VICTIM OF
A HOST OF THINGS.
AND ONE OF THOSE IS A BRAILLE
SYSTEM.
AND SO MY DAD WOULD ALWAYS SAY I
DON'T BILL EVERYBODY OUT OF JAIL
BUT IF YOU HAVE A JOB I'M GOING
TO BAIL YOU OUT OF JAIL THIS IS
A POOR MAN TALKING.
ABOUT GIVING TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FORTY FIFTY DOLLARS TO BAIL
SYSTEM.
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS PERSON HAD A JOB ONE
MONDAY MORNING.
AND SO WHEN I BEGAN TO
UNDERSTAND EVEN LATER.
AND EVEN NOW THE LEGISLATIVE WE
LOOK AT THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY OUR SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
AND ALL OF THE JUDGES AROUND THE
STATE WILL CONSERVATIVE AS WELL
AS SOME LIBERAL ONES.
THE CONCERN WAS ALWAYS ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THIS SYSTEM WAS SO
OFTEN FEAR.
AND SO ON JUST TO POOR PEOPLE.
WHO DIDN'T HAVE THE MEANS TO
BAIL FOLKS OUT OF JAIL WHO
DIDN'T HAVE CREDIT CARDS TO GET
PEOPLE OUT?
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WANT TO
BAIL SOMEONE OUT THAT MONEY IS
GONE.
YOU DO NOT GET IT BACK.
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T PAID THE
FULL AMOUNT OF ONLY PAY 10%.
AND THAT 10% IS GONE TO SOMEONE
ELSE WHY BECAUSE YOU ARE IN A
SITUATION THAT YOU WEREN'T
HURTING SOMEONE YOU WEREN'T
DOING ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAN
YOU NORMALLY DO MAYBE.
WHAT YOU END UP IN JAIL AND YOU
NEEDED THE BILL YOURSELF OUT?
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT SYSTEM AND
I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL.
GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF SOCIAL JUSTICE.
BECAUSE UNLIKE WHAT SOME OF YOU
SAID THIS IS GOING TO GIVE MORE
POWER TO OUR JUDGES.
ACTUALLY MAKE A DECISION ABOUT
WHO GETS THAT WHO WHO GETS OUT
OF JAIL.
AND SO THIS POSITION THAT IT'S
NICE TAKEN AWAY FROM THE JUDGES
THIS IS ACTUALLY GIVING MORE.
AND THE SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS
LIKE THE IN DOUBLE ACP IN A CEO
YOUR CONCERN.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT I JUDGE
SYSTEM A JUDICIAL SYSTEM IS NOT
THAT PERFECT.
AND THERE'S STILL TREMENDOUS
BIAS IN OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
AND HOW THEY CHARGE POOR PEOPLE
FOR HIGHER CRIMES.
AND IS STILL BIAS IN OUR JUDGES
WHO LOOK AT PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
PEOPLE PORT DIFFERENTLY THAN
THEY DO OTHERS.
AND AS A RESULT THERE MAY BE
SOME BIAS.
IT IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THIS BILL IS THE FUNCTIONS
THE WAY WE WANT IT TO FUNCTION.
BUT I'VE LEARNED THAT.
ALL ALL THE YEARS OF MY LIFE.
THAT CHANGES FAR.
IT IS DIFFICULT.
AND OFTEN TIMES OUT OF OUR FEAR
OF CHANGE THAT WE DO NOTHING.
WE JUST STAND STILL.
AND WE FIND EVERY REASON NOT TO
CHANGE.
AND THINGS DON'T GET BETTER.
THEY GET WORSE.
AND REQUIRE SOME TIME SOME
COURAGE TO STEP FORWARD. TO NOT
ONLY MAKE THE CHANGE WOULD WORK
TO MAKE THAT CHANGE WORK RIGHT.
I CAN REMEMBER WHEN BROWN VERSUS
BOARD OF EDUCATION NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR'S DECISION WAS DONE.
PEOPLE WERE CONCERNED THAT THIS
WAS MOVING TOO FAST AND WE
NEEDED TO SLOW DOWN.
AND YOU LEARN VERY QUICKLY THAT
THIS WAS REALLY A SMALL STEP IN
THE INTEGRATION.
IT WASN'T THE BE ALL END ALL.
AND IT REQUIRED LOTS OF WORK
AFTERWARDS AND STILL TO THIS DAY
IT IS NOT THE PERFECT SYSTEM
THAT WE WANT.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT ALL THOSE
THINGS WE'VE DONE IN THIS HOUSE
AND FOR THE LAST FIFTY SIXTY
YEARS OF IT IN LAW ISSUE OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
WE'VE HAD SMALL STEPS TINY STEPS
SOMETIMES FOR STEP FORWARD TWO
STEPS BACK.
STILL MOVING FORWARD.
WILL YOU AN IMPERFECT WORLD THIS
IN AN IMPERFECT SYSTEM THAT'S
WHAT DEMOCRACY IS BUT IT
REQUIRES US TO HAVE SOME FAITH.
SOME COURAGE THAT WHEN WE FIND
SOMETHING WRONG.
AND THERE'S NOT A PERSON ON THIS
FLOOR WHO SAID MONEY BAIL IS A
GOOD THING.
WE ALL SAID IT IS WRONG.
MOST OF US HAVE DONE NOTHING TO
CHANGE IT THOUGH.
WE HAVE NOT ORGANIZE WE HAVE NOT
PUT FORTH FORTH A BILL WE HAVE
NOT ACTUALLY MOVED TO BAKE BUDDY
BILL.
I TAKE BUT A BILL OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO NOW WE HAVE SOME FOLKS WHO
HAVE.
AND THEY SPENT TWO YEARS SO
ANYONE WHO SAYS THIS JUST POPPED
UP NO MAYBE THE CONCEPT OF WAR
POPPED UP.
BUT REMEMBER WE HAVE A LOT OF
THIS THERE'S SOMETHING AS BEING
PREFACE EVERY TWO HOURS AND
WE'VE DONE THAT THEY'VE DONE
THAT.
AND SO YOU HAD ITS BENEFITS
SEVENTY TWO HOURS USE IT IF YOU
WANTED TO SEE IT IT'S BEEN HERE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY FOLKS HAVE
DECIDED THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER
GOING TO BE AFRAID.
THE NO LONGER THAN BE PARALYZED
BY FEAR.
ACTUALLY TRY TO MOVE FORWARD TO
BRING SOME CHANGE BECAUSE
EVERYONE ON THIS FLOOR HAS SAID
MONEY BAIL IS WRONG.
IT IS NOT A GOOD SYSTEM IT IS
NOT A SYSTEM THAT KEEPS US SAFE
AND IS SURELY IS UNFAIR AND
UNJUST TO THOSE WHO PROBABLY
NEED JUSTICE MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE.
I HOPE YOU WILL.
STRAIGHT NEAR BACK.
LOOK TOWARD THE SUN.
DO WHAT IS RIGHT WHAT IS JUST
AND THAT IT MOVES CALIFORNIA IN
A POSITION THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD
BEFORE.
AND THAT YOU WILL BASICALLY VOTE
YES FOR S. B. TM.
AND IF YOU CANNOT FIND YOURSELF
WANTING TO VOTE FOR IT AND IT
PASSES.
BUT YOU WILL WORK VERY HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT S. B. TIN WORKS
IN CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME I BOTH S. B..
TEN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MENTAL SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M JUST.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT I'M
HEARING.
ON THE FLOOR TODAY I MEAN.
ALMOST EVERYBODY WHO'S GOTTEN UP
TO TELL US TO BOW IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
HAS ESSENTIALLY MADE THIS
ARGUMENT --
YEAH THIS COULD BE REALLY BAD.
BUT IT'S BETTER THAN THE STATUS
QUO. TO PASS BAD POLICY IN HEY
WE COULD MAYBE FIX THAT BAD
POLICY.
DOWN THE ROAD WHY DON'T WE JUST
DO IT THE RIGHT WAY.
THE FIRST TIME.
AND THAT'S THE POINT THAT
EVERYBODY'S MAKING.
ON THE OPPOSITION SIDE WHY
DIDN'T WHY.
WHY DO WE NEED TO WORK THIS TO
THE BILL TO THE TO THE FLOOR?
MENDOZA YOU ARE MAKING THE
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS BAD --
THIS IS BAD PROCESS.
YOU CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
YOU COULDN'T REJECT.
THIS CONTINUAL POLITICS
LEGISLATIVE POLITICS OF FAST
FORWARDING LEGISLATION TO THE
FLOOR THAT NOBODY'S HAVE THE
TIME. TO REALLY DEVOID TO READ.
THAT NO COMMITTEES HAVE REALLY
HAD THE PROCESS TO DELIBERATE
AND DISCUSS.
AND THEN EXPECT DIFFERENT
RESULTS THAT LIKE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET GOOD POLICY OUT OF
IT.
YOU'RE NOT THAT IS CRAZY IS THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY. TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN THIS WAY.
AND MANY OF THE THINGS I'VE
HEARD ON THIS FLOOR JUST PURE
FANTASY.
LIKE THAT WE'VE BEEN DEBATING
THIS ARE YOU KIDDING ME.
THE LAST TIME WE HAD A DEBATE ON
THIS WAS LAST YEAR ON THE FLOOR
AGAIN AT THE VERY.
END THE SESSION.
TRIED TO PUT SOME THROUGH WE
DIDN'T GET.
LUCKILY.
THIS BODY SAID NO THE TIME IS
NOT RIGHT WE HAVE A DISCUSSES.
AND NOW A YEAR LATER.
AGAIN THE VERY END THE SESSION
WE HAD A BILL THAT.
HAD LANGUAGE IT WAS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
AS LATE AS LAST THURSDAY.
LAST THURSDAY WAS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT BILL.
THAT DAY LANGUAGE CHANGE WE
STILL GOING GET LANGUAGE SO OVER
THE WEEKEND.
AND NOW IT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT BILL.
AND WE'RE TOLD YEAH GO AHEAD AND
BONES AND APPROVE THE SAYING IN
AND LET'S MOVE FORWARD.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD WAY. TO MAKE
GOOD POLICY NOW FROM WHAT I CAN.
HAVE READ THE BILL THERE'S
THERE'S A MAJOR PROBLEMS HERE
EVERYBODY DOES AGREE.
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
FLAWED THERE'S INEQUITIES.
BUT WHAT THE OP USER THING THE
OPPOSITION DOESN'T DISAGREE.
THE OPPOSITION ACTUALLY AGREES
ON THIS POINT THIS WILL PROBABLY
LEAD TO ACTUALLY MORE
DETENTIONS.
NO PRIOR ACTUALLY TO MORE
DETENTIONS AND WHEN YOU DO RISK
BASE.
ASSESSMENTS IT DEPENDS ON HOW
YOU DO THAT CRITERIA AND YOU'RE
GIVING THAT AWAY. TO ANOTHER
BODY NOT THIS BODY.
THEY'RE GONNA DETERMINE WHAT
THAT RISK ASSESSMENT IS AND
DEPENDING ON HOW THEY DO IT
THOSE INEQUITIES THAT YOU'VE
SEEN ACTUALLY COULD BE
EXACERBATED.
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU ARE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THE
INEQUITIES WE'RE GOING TO STOP
UNFAIR DETENTION.
YOU MAY DO VERY VERY THE
OPPOSITE WITH THIS AND YOU HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER IT BECAUSE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS GOING TO
COME OF THAT CRITERIA NOT YOU.
AND SO YOU SHOULD REALLY THINK
ABOUT THAT THE OTHER THING
YOU'RE YOU ARE ELIMINATING.
AN ENTIRE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK MAYBE IT'S WORTH.
AT LEAST MORE THAN A COUPLE DAYS
TO FIGURE OUT IF THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA OR NOT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
NOW THERE MAY THERE ARE FLAWS IN
THE BILL SYSTEM BUT ONE THING IT
DOESN'T SURE IS IT IT CREATES A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE. FOR SOMEONE
TO ENSURE THAT SOMEONE SHOWS
BACK UP TO COURT.
WHICH IS KIND OF AN IMPORTANT
THING TO DO TO ENSURE RIGHT.
IT ALSO WERE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THAT'S
BEEN BROUGHT UP AS WELL THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
AS PROVISIONS OF THE PROTECT
YOUR RIGHT TO BAIL.
IN THAT ONLY UNDER VERY NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES CAN YOU BE DENIED.
CAN YOU BE DENIED THAT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE CREATING A SYSTEM THAT HAS
A WHOLE LOT OF EXEMPTIONS. TO
THAT IT MAY VERY WELL BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT WHY TAKE
THE TIME TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
REALLY TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
RIGHTS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
UNDER OUR CONSTITUTION.
THIS IS FLAWED POLICY LIKE
PLEASE I MEAN.
I MAKE THIS ADMONITION A LOT I
KNOW.
BUT THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF US
WORKING TOGETHER IN THIS BY US
FOR OVER ELECTED SO THAT WE CAN
DEBATE THIS THING SO WE CAN.
DEVOTED SO IF YOU GET DOWN TO
THE NITTY GRITTY DETAILS AND
HOPEFULLY COME UP WITH A BETTER
POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO DO IT WE
HAVE BEEN DEBATING IT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT.
WE'VE JUST SEEN THIS LANGUAGE
AND NOW YOU'RE PASSING SOMETHING
IF YOU SAY OH WELL WILL PASS
SOMETHING REALLY BAD SO THAT WE
CAN CHANGE IT LATER.
THAT'S A DERELICTION YOUR DUTY.
THAT'S NOT WHY WE'RE HERE.
SO PLEASE I WOULD JUST.
URGE MY COLLEAGUES LET'S REJECT
THIS POLLOCK WAS REJECT THIS
TYPE OF POLITICS.
COME BACK AND REALLY WORK ON
THIS WE CAN MAKE WE CAN REFORM
THE BILL SYSTEM TO MAKE IT WORK
BETTER FOR EVERYBODY.
BUT THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO
DO IT HIRED YOU KNOW THE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM LOCKER
TO OF YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
[inaudible]
I AM.
I AM NOT HAPPY.
MY CONSTITUENTS ARE NOT HAPPY.
MANY OF US WENT HOME OVER THE
WEEKEND. TO TRY AND VISIT THE
FOLKS IN OUR DISTRICT AND SPEND
TIME WITH OUR FAMILIES.
AND THE WHOLE WEEKEND.
I SPENT THINKING ABOUT THIS
BILL.
AND HEARING FROM FOLKS ABOUT
THIS BILL.
AND IT DOES HAVE MY STOMACH IN A
NOT.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST BE CLEAR.
THE LA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IS NOT THE END
ALL BE ALL FOR ME.
WHEN IT COMES TO GOOD CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POLICY?
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
IN LA COUNTY.
AND IF THIS BILL PASSES WE ALL
COLLECTIVELY.
HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION. TO WRAP
OUR ARMS AROUND THIS ISSUE AND
NOT LET IT GO BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT THE SILVER BULLET.
I BELIEVE NO BILL WE PASSED.
IS A SILVER BULLET.
SO MAYBE SOME DAYS WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR BRONZE OR COPPER.
OR EVEN SOME WOULD [inaudible]
PROBATION.
DA'S OFFICE SAYS JUDGES.
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THOSE SYSTEMS.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS PREVENTIVE
DETENTION REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
TRACKING AND TRANSPARENCY LET'S
BE CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY IS CLEAN
KEY TRACKING IS KEY.
BUT OUR OWNING THIS ISSUE ITS
PROCESS AND ITS SUCCESS IS ALSO
KEY.
AND WE DECIDED TO DO IT.
WHEN WE?
THIS BILL.
CASH RULES EVERYTHING AROUND ME.
CASH RULES EVERYTHING AROUND US.
THE BAIL SYSTEM.
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
OUR-PROBATION SYSTEM.
THOSE ALL GENERATE REVENUE
BECAUSE SPOKES GO BEFORE PEOPLE.
LOOKING FOR FREEDOM OR DUE
PROCESS.
BUT STRAPPING PEOPLE'S LIBERTY
[inaudible]
AND FUTURE. TO BAIL MONEY.
IS JUST WRONG.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE PEOPLE.
LOOK LIKE SO MANY FOLKS WHO ARE
REPEATEDLY THROWN UNDER THE BUS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
I'M GOING TO VOTE ON PRINCIPLE.
ON THIS BILL [inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible]
AN OBLIGATION. TO FIND WAYS TO
FIX THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE BROKEN.
WE HAVE POWER.
THAT NOT MANY OTHERS HALF IN
FACT ONLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
OF US.
AND FAILURE ONLY COMES.
WHEN WE DO NOTHING?
AND IF I TELL MY LITTLE PEOPLE.
IN MY HOUSEHOLD [inaudible] TO
TRY.
AND IF YOU FAIL GET UP AND DO IT
AGAIN.
BECAUSE THAT PROCESS AND FINDING
SUCCESS AND WORKING MUSCLES THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO WORK BECAUSE
THEY ARE UNCOMFORTABLE.
IS IMPORTANT.
THEN I CERTAINLY BELIEVE I HAVE
TO TAKE MY OWN COUNSEL.
TODAY.
I WILL BE SIGNING UP. TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT WE WORK THIS OUT.
IN A WAY THAT WORKS FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT.
AND I WOULD URGE OTHERS TO DO
THE SAME WITH ME THINK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU MEMBERS.
A IN THE MILITARY WE HAVE A
SAYING [inaudible]
SLOW SMOOTH.
SMOOTH AS FAST.
WE NEED TO SLOW THIS DOWN.
BECAUSE ALL I'VE HEARD TODAY.
FROM MANY OF YOU IS THAT.
THIS IS ALL PUT TOGETHER.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS.
YOU DON'T FOR SH.
SOMETHING BAD IN THE EFFORT TO
DO SOMETHING GOOD.
ESPECIALLY NOT IN COMBAT THAT'S
HOW YOU END UP WITH PEOPLE DEAD.
BUT YET HERE WE ARE.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THE EIGHTY
IN THE ASSEMBLY [inaudible] FOR
SEEN SOMETHING WE KNOW.
THAT IS NOT GOOD.
IT'S BEEN SAID IS NOT FULLY.
COOKED IT'S NOT FULLY BAKED.
IT'S BEEN CALLED APPEAL LESS.
THIS BILL IS GARBAGE.
AND YOU ALL KNOW IT.
IT'S GOING TO COMPLETELY AFFECT
THE LIVES OF EVERYBODY.
THAT SENT US UP HERE TO
REPRESENT THEM.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT OUR
FAMILIES [inaudible]
OUR NEIGHBORS.
WE HAVE MEMBERS TALKING ABOUT
OTHER AFRAID TO LEAVE.
THEIR WIVES AND THEIR CHILDREN.
AT HOME.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHO'S
GONNA BE LET OUT ON THE STREET.
WHERE D. SUFFERING FROM PROP
FORTY SEVEN PROP FIFTY SEVEN
THESE OTHER THINGS [inaudible]
BUT YET.
WE WANT TO SPEED IT UP.
WE WANT TO PUSH THIS FORWARD
WE'VE GOTTA MAKE A CHANGE.
A CHANGE FROM WHAT.
YOU ALL TOOK AN OATH YOU TOOK AN
OBLIGATION. FOR THOSE A SAY
THEY'RE SICK OF IT STOP RUNNING
FOR OFFICE [inaudible]
I'M NOT.
WELL NOT AFRAID TO STAND
APPARENTLY A SLOWDOWN.
GET IT RIGHT.
GET IT RIGHT FOR YOUR KIDS FOR
YOUR NEIGHBORS AND FOR THEIR
KIDS.
YEAH OTHERS BIAS OUT THERE YOU
KNOW WHETHER THERE'S VICE AND
EVERYTHING SOME OF US LIKE SPICY
SOME OF US LIKE HOT SUMMER.
ADVICE AND EVERYTHING.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT.
IF WE DON'T SLOW DOWN IF WE
DON'T COME BACK TOGETHER WE
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONVERSATION [inaudible]
AS LEGISLATURE'S.
ON WHAT THE RIGHT PATH FORWARD
FOR THIS BROKEN SYSTEM IS.
THEN WE'RE DOING A DISSERVICE.
IT'LL BE ON EVERYBODY THE VOTES
I ON THIS.
WHEN THIS GETS MESSED UP?
BECAUSE THE RISK MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER SYSTEM
[inaudible]
WHERE?
IS THE MEMBERS THE GOAL OF QUITE
FRANKLY I'D CALL YOU CAL WORDS
BECAUSE YOU'RE GIVING AWAY YOUR
POWER.
AS LEGISLATURE'S TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
SO IF YOU WANT TO HOLD ON ABOUT
POWER KEEP IT LET'S COME BACK
WITH GET THIS RIGHT.
SO YOU CAN SAY WE DID OUR JOBS.
IS THAT A PASS IN THE BLOCK
INSTEAD OF SPEEDING IT UP AND
GIVEN AWAY YOUR POWER TO
SOMEBODY ELSE SO MANY COULD TURN
AROUND AND PUT YOUR FINGER AGO.
ALL WE WE PASSED IT.
BUT BUT WE GIVE THE POWER TO
THEM SO NOW IT'S THEIR FAULT.
OWN UP TO YOUR JOB VOTE NO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I YOU
KNOW I JUST WANT.
TO MAKE HUMAN LIFE THIS A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO IMPACT
SO MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SOMETHING THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN IMPACTING MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS OUR STATE LET'S
TALK ABOUT.
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN BAIL.
THE FACT THAT. FOR LATINO MEN.
IT'S 19% AND FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN IT'S 35% HIGHER.
THAT OF THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS.
LET'S PUT SOME REAL CONTEXT INTO
THIS SOME.
EXAMPLES IN THE REAL WORLD.
JUST LAST YEAR A MAN NAMED
KENNETH HUMPHRIES --
SPEND MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DAYS.
IN JAIL.
ON THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BAIL FOR
STEALING FIVE DOLLARS.
AND A BOTTLE OF COLOGNE.
A STATE APPEAL A STATE APPEALS
ORDER ORDERED THE NEW BAIL
HEARING BECAUSE THEY AGREED THAT
A DEFENDANT MAY NOT BE
IMPRISONED.
SOLELY BASED ON POVERTY
[inaudible]
SECOND EXAMPLE.
A GUNMAN AND TO HIM A COUNTY
NAMED KEVIN MEAL.
WHEN OUT ON BAIL?
AFTER STABBING A NEIGHBOR AFTER
KILLING FIVE PEOPLE INCLUDING
HIS WIFE.
HE WAS A DANGER TO HIS
COMMUNITY.
AND HE WAS RELEASED SIMPLY
BECAUSE HE MADE BAIL.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT SAFETY AND
COMMUNITY AND WHAT THAT ALL
MEANS.
THOSE ARE TWO REAL WORLD
EXAMPLES.
OF HOW THIS ACTUALLY WORKS.
CASH BAIL IS ABOUT WHETHER YOU
CAN AFFORD IT OR NOT.
AND WHAT WE ARE DOING HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
IS DIFFERENT.
WE ARE ENSURING.
THAT OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
[inaudible]
ACTUALLY WORKS.
IN THAT YOU ARE INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY.
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT ROTTING AWAY
IN JAIL.
BECAUSE THEY ARE POOR.
AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD CASH BAIL.
THAT WORKING CLASS PEOPLE WHO
ARE MAKING AN HONEST LIVING
PERHAPS WORKING TWO TO THREE
JOBS.
TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AND WHO UNFORTUNATELY GET UP GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE SYSTEM.
HAVE AN EQUAL AND FAIR SYSTEM
THAT REPRESENTS THEM BASED ON
JUSTICE.
NOT ON THE PREMISE.
WHERE THEY CAN AFFORD TO MAKE
CASH BAIL?
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT.
HOW THIS BILL IS IN?
AND KNOW NOTHING IS EVER
PERFECT.
THERE IS THE REAL WORLD IN WHICH
ME LIVIN IN WHICH WE
LEGISLATIVE.
AND THEN THERE'S THE IDEAL WORLD
IN WHICH WE ALL HOPED WE LIVED
AND HOPEFULLY STEP BY STEP.
WE GET THERE.
BUT IT TAKES TIME IT TAKES
COURAGE AND I'M SO.
I'M SO AND I FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT SO MANY REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
SAYING THAT THEY WANT TO WORK ON
THIS IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE IF THIS MAKES IT OUT
INTO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND GET
FINE INTO LAW I'M REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO PUT TOGETHER A
COMMITTEE WITH.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO FIX THE SYSTEM.
I THINK THAT'S IMPRESSIVE AN
INSPIRATIONAL IN THE
CONVERSATION THAT HAS HAPPENED
TODAY.
SO LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOPE IN WHAT THAT MEANS BECAUSE
YOU CANNOT PUT.
PRICE ON FREEDOM.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO PIVOT.
I CHANGE THE COURSE OF THE STATE
TO BE A BEACON OF HOPE. FOR THE
REST OF THE NATION.
THEN NONE OF THIS IS EASY IT
TAKES COURAGE AS IT WAS STATED.
BY MEMBERS BEFORE ME THAT SPOKE.
WE CAME HERE.
NOT BECAUSE THIS IS A TOUGH IS
EASY OR BECAUSE CASTING VOTES
LIKE THIS IS EASY.
BUT BECAUSE IT AND IT IS IN FACT
QUITE HARD.
IT IS CHALLENGING.
AND IT TAKES COURAGE WHETHER
IT'S LITTLE BY LITTLE STEP BY
STEP TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY.
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE WHO DESERVE JUSTICE.
WHO DESERVE TO BE ABLE?
TO NOT ROT IN PRISON BECAUSE
THEY ARE POOR.
WE TALK ABOUT POVERTY THE TALK
ABOUT JOBS.
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT HELPING THE
WORKING WORKING CLASS WORKING
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
DO THAT.
CHANGE THE COURSE OF OUR STATE
CHANGE THE COURSE OF THIS
NATION.
AND WHILE THIS BILL S. B. TAME
MEN MAY NOT BE PERFECT.
IT IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND IN THE FUTURE.
MAYBE A FEW YEARS FROM NOW A
DECADE FROM NOW.
PEOPLE WILL BE SPEAKING ABOUT
WHO OPPOSED TO WAS IN SUPPORT.
THEY'RE GONNA BE ASKING WHO HAD
THE COURAGE.
I DO SOMETHING WHEN NOBODY ELSE
WOULD.
WHO HAD THE COURAGE TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE TOWARDS JUSTICE?
I HAVE THAT COURAGE.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF YOU DO AS
WELL.
SO REGARDLESS OF WHO SUPPORT
THEM WHO OPPOSES OR WHERE YOU
ARE TODAY FIND THE COURAGE
WITHIN YOURSELF TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT. FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE VOTE
ON SB TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
THINK HIM [inaudible]
I AM.
ONLY ONE TO SPEAK.
WHY PRIMARILY ONE SPEAK TO THE
PROCESS ISSUE --
I PEOPLE AT HOME WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS DOING THE PLAY BY
PLAY BY TAX TIME WHICH ARGUMENT
THEY FIND OF ALL THE YEARS THAT
SOUNDS GOOD OR BAD --
IN IN THAT I SO YEAH THAT SOUNDS
GOOD BUT THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
THIS IS NOT BEING HURRIED.
THIS BILL GRANTED IN DIFFERENT
FORMS AS BILLS OFTEN TAKE.
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS [inaudible]
CAN SIMPLY.
I DON'T NO FLY SAID ON THE WRONG
COMMITTEES BUT I THINK I'VE
HEARD THIS IN COMMITTEE
[inaudible] FOUR TIMES I'VE
HEARD IT ON THE FLOOR.
THIS IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING WE SUDDENLY
CAME UP WITH AND I REMEMBER
STANDING UP ON THE FLOOR LAST
YEAR. FOR THE ASSEMBLY BILL THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND
BROUGHT IN HEARING PEOPLE SAY
WELL WHY ARE WE RUSHING AT CAN'T
WE JUST WAIT FOR THE CHIEF
JUSTICE TO PUT OUT HER
RECOMMENDATION.
WELL SHE DID THAT.
AND THEY WERE LISTEN.
TO AND THEY WERE USED TO
COLLABORATE.
AND I HEARD PEOPLE STAND UP SOME
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE STANDING
UP TODAY OPPOSING THOSE SAYING
THEY KNEW SOMETHING WAS WRONG
BUT THIS WASN'T THE FIX AND
WE'VE HEARD NOTHING FROM THEM.
THIS PAST YEAR IN LOOKING FOR
AFFECTS.
AND YET STILL IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE.
PEOPLE ARE PICKED UP FOR THINGS
THAT THEY DIDN'T DO.
THEY HAVE TO POST A BILL IN
ORDER TO GO TO WORK.
AND THAT MONEY IS KEPT FROM THEM
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NEVER
CHARGED.
PEOPLE WHO ARE FOUND INNOCENT
WHO SHOW UP TO COURT.
THEY LOSE THAT 10%.
IN A COMMUNITY LIKE MINE.
WHERE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE A FEW
THOUSAND DOLLARS COULD BE YOUR
FAMILY'S ENTIRE SAVINGS?
WE KNOW THAT THE CASH BAIL
SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
AND I'LL SAY WHAT I SAID LAST
YEAR A THEFT ON POOR PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THAT. TO SUGGEST SOMEHOW
THAT WE'RE PUTTING OURSELVES IN
MORE DANGER.
IS INCREDIBLE TO ME AND I KEEP
HEARING THIS AS IF PEOPLE WHO
CAN AFFORD PAY ALL.
RICH PEOPLE WHO ARE LET OUT.
I THINK LAST YEAR THERE WAS A
POST OF A BILL FOR THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. TO SUGGEST THAT
THAT WOMAN IS ANY [inaudible]
LESS LIKELY. TO RE OFFEND.
BECAUSE SHE HAS MONEY.
OR TO SUGGEST THAT.
THE THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
SEX OFFENDERS [inaudible]
RAPIST [inaudible]
MURDERERS.
WHO ARE LED OUT BECAUSE THEY
SIMPLY HAVE MONEY?
SOMEHOW MAKE US SAFER BY KEEPING
THAT SYSTEM.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
MISTAKES IN THE SYSTEM.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THERE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CAN
GET THE EXACT NUMBER WHO ARE LET
OUT ON BAIL NOW. FOR LET OUT
AFTER PAIN THEIR BAIL WHO RE
OFFEND.
THERE WILL BE SOME PEOPLE.
WHO ARE LET OUT UNDER THIS RISK
ASSESSMENT STUDY?
WHO OUR SITUATION WHO WILL FUND?
BUT WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING TO
CORRECT A SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
ALL SAID NOW ON THIS FLOOR IS
BROKEN.
AND TO MY FRIENDS.
ON THE PROGRESSIVE SIDE AT THE
ACLU.
AND ARE ACTIVISTS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO SAY THIS DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH.
I WOULD JUST SAY THIS.
I AGREE AND I AGREE BOMB.
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO SAID WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONTINUE TO
WRAP HER ARMS AROUND THIS AND
MAKE IT BETTER.
BUT HAVING STEP THROUGH THIS
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IF WE DON'T PASS THIS NOW.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A BILL
TO BE BROUGHT BACK NEXT YEAR.
OR THE YEAR AFTER THAT.
THERE JUST ISN'T SIMPLY.
THE WILL TO START FROM SCRATCH
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH EVERYBODY WILL
SIT HERE TODAY AND SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD WORK ON 90%
OF THE PEOPLE STANDING UP AND
SAYING THAT HAVE DONE NOTHING.
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
OR TO MAKE THIS ISSUE BETTER.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE MOST OF US AREN'T
AFFECTED DIRECTLY BY THE US.
AND SOME OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
DIRECTED DIRECTLY OFFENDED
[inaudible]
I'VE S..
SO THOSE OF US WHO CARE DEEPLY
BUT CARE DEEPLY WHAT ARE
ACTIVISTS THINK AS MUCH AS
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
NO THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP.
IT'S A SOLID FIRST STEP. TO GET
US TO A POSITION WHERE WE CAN
WRAP OUR ARMS AROUND IT.
WHERE WE CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK?
TOWARDS AS MY FORMER SEAT MAKING
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO SAID
AND I I DON'T THINK ANYONE COULD
SAY IT BETTER.
TOWARDS JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO.
THIS IS BEEN A LONG TWO YEARS WE
HAVE DEBATED THIS IN COMMITTEE
AFTER COMMITTEE AFTER COMMITTEE.
WE'VE DEBATED ON THE FLOOR IT'S
BEEN DEBATED IN THE SENATE IT'S
BEEN DEBATED IN THE MEDIA IT'S
BEEN DEBATED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND BY OUR CHIEF
JUSTICE.
THIS IS NOT NEW TO ANYBODY OR
SHOULDN'T BE NUDE ANYBODY HERE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE VOTE
I TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
COOLEY YOUR RECOGNIZE SORRY NOT.
SO MEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANKS PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN
ADVANCED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATS ARREST RATES ARE DOWN.
CATCH RELEASE RATES ARE UP AND
NOW VIOLENT CRIME IS RISING
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GETTING RID OF OUR CURRENT MAIL
SYSTEM ONLY MAKE CALIFORNIA LESS
SAFE.
BY ELIMINATING BAIL CRIMINALS
WILL STOP SHOWING UP FOR TRIAL.
BY STRIPPING BAIL BONDSMAN OF
THEIR POWER TO BRING CRIMINALS
TO JUSTICE.
MORE CRIMINALS WILL NOW ROAM
FREE.
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH.
NOTES IN THEIR RECENT LETTER.
THIS THE CHEN SETS OF A SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS JUDGES NEARLY
UNLIMITED DISCRETION ORDER
PEOPLE ACCUSED OF CRIMES BUT NOT
CONVICTED AND PRESUMPTIVELY
INNOCENT TO BE HELD IN JAIL WITH
NO RECOURSE.
IN TWO OTHER CASES RESOLVE.
AND FURTHERMORE THE DETENTION
HEARING PROCEDURES PRESCRIBED BY
S. B. TEN VIOLATE DUE PROCESS
AND ARE SO LOOSE THE EMPOWER
JUDGES TO PREVENT DIGITALLY
DETAINED AT WILL.
S. B. TEN WILL MAKE US SAFER.
IT WILL LEAD EVEN HIGHER CRIME
RATES.
IT WILL LEAD TO EVEN MORE
CRIMINALS LOOSE ON OUR STREETS.
AND WILL LEAD TO INNOCENT PEOPLE
BEING HELD IN JAIL AGAINST THEIR
WILL AND WITHOUT DUE PROCESS AT
THE MERCY OF MANIPULATED
COMPUTER ALGORITHMS.
AN UNELECTED BUREAUCRACIES.
AS WE GET IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT
ENDANGERS EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND
IT LEFT DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES
FOR CALIFORNIA.
DON'T LET THE SAME POLITICIANS
YOU GAVE US PROP FORTY SEVEN
RUIN THE BAIL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
VOTE NO ON S. B..
TEN EACH YEAR MEMBER COOPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
NUMBER ONE THIS FIRST CAME OUT.
SUPPORTED BILL REFORM AND THAT
WITH THE AUTHOR MISTER BUT IT IT
CINNAMON FROM ALAMEDA.
AT THIS MOMENT FROM LOS ANGELES
AND THE AG ON THIS ISSUE WE
TALKED ABOUT IT.
IT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE THE JUDGES.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S A MAJOR
PART A PROBLEM TO GO BACK ON
BILL.
YOU'RE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
EACH COUNTY A PANEL OF JUDGES
SETS THE BILL EVERY TWO YEARS.
EVERY TWO YEARS SELLING
CALIFORNIA OFF OF TOUCH OF
ROBBERY IN ONE COUNTY BILL IS
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT WAS ALWAYS A TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANOTHER COUNTY ANYWHERE
IN BETWEEN.
JUDGES THAT THE BILL IS
p200-082-0009 WE DOUBLED THE
BILLS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE
JUDGES.
THIS IS MY GIVEN THE FOX
ACCUSING HIM HOUSE NOW JUST A
COUNCIL GETS TO DO THIS AND
ORGANIZE THIS.
SO ONCE AGAIN YOU HAVE FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT COUNTIES SITTING
FIFTY DIFFERENT STANDARDS
THERE'S ONLY ONE BILL ONE
STANDARD THAT'S WITH THE BIG
ISSUE WITH THIS AND YOU WILL
STILL HAVE THE HUMAN FACTOR
JUDGES.
MAKING DECISIONS THAT THAT'S
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO NOT WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
IT'S LIKE REFORM FATIGUE WE HAD
PROP FORTY SEVEN PROP FIFTY
SEVEN AB ONE I JUST VOTED ON
EIGHTEEN TEN IN A TRAILER BILL.
IT IS REFER IT IS A SIX FOOT
FATIGUE.
I DON'T THINK MAJORITY LEADER
CALDERON OFFERED FOR BEING OF
ALL THIS AND IN HELPING TO TRY
AND MAKE IT BETTER --
THE COST CLUSTER ENORMOUS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO START
OFF WITH WITHIN TWO HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR IT IS WAY MORE
THAN THAT BECAUSE THINK ABOUT
IT.
EVERYONE AT YOUR HOME ATTENTION
ANKLE BRACELET THAT'S PAID FOR
THE MONEY TO SYSTEM THAT'S PAID
FOR SOME OF THE MODERATE THAT'S
PAID FOR SOMEONE TO GO OUT WHEN
YOU CUT OFF IN LEAF IN FTA.
THAT'S PAID FOR TO LEARN MILLION
IS A BIG ISSUE IT'S ALL GONNA
COST WAY MORE THAN THAT.
IT WE TALK TO THE TO THE
PROPONENTS THE BILL THEY HAVE NO
IDEA.
IT IS REALLY JUST A WILD GUESS
IN DEALING WITH THAT.
WE WOULD BLOCK TURNER CASE A
JUDGE MADE A BAD DECISIONS YOU
GONNA HAVE THAT NEVER TAKE AWAY
THE HUMAN FACTOR.
AND YOU KNOW I WANT TO MORE
FOLKS IN JAIL TO BE HONEST.
THIS GONNA PUT MORE FOLKS IN
JAIL WITH THAT.
NOW IF THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE IS
GONNA HAPPEN GONNA COME BACK TO
FIX THIS AND YEAH WE HEARD A
BILL YEAR AGO BUT NOTHING'S
HAPPENED.
IT'S HAPPENED THIS HOUSE THERE'S
BEEN THE HEARINGS IN THIS HOUSE
ON THE ISSUE.
AND IT HASN'T INVENTED THERE
THERE'S NOT URGENCY TO DO IT
RIGHT TO HAVE A UNIFORM DEL
SCHEDULE.
TALK ABOUT FDA'S A LOT OF FOLKS
JUST DON'T SHOW UP FOR COURT.
SO IN SECOND A COUNTY
[inaudible]
CURRENTLY IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN
ENOUGH DOES ANYONE CAN GO ON
WITH A BILL NAY OR A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE'S A GOOD EXAMPLE.
THE GILLS FOUR BLOCKS AWAY
HOLES.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED INMATES
THAT'S THE MAX FOR PRE TRIAL
INMATES THE BOOK FIFTY THOUSAND
PRISONERS IN THE YEAR FIFTY
THOUSAND THE VAST MAJORITY GOING
ANGLED OUT LITTLE STATE.
ONCE ESTATE AVERAGE FIVE FOR THE
CONVICTIONS SO ALSO DRUNK
DRIVING AFFECT INSTANT IN JAIL.
WILL BE YES OF THE GEL COMMANDER
READY FOR TWO YEARS AND THEY'VE
A PRE TRIAL PROGRAM THERE.
SO NO I'M TALKING ABOUT ON THAT.
SO PEOPLE HAVE TO SHOW UP LEN
ORANGE COUNTY THINK IT'S FIVE
AND SEVEN IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT.
NONE THE FTA PART GO THE DOCTOR
BILL DENTIST HATE HIS
REPLACEMENT CARD SHOW UP FOR
YOUR APPOINTMENT.
A LOT OF FOLKS JUST DON'T DO
THAT AND THAT'S BEEN HONEST.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY A QUARTER OF A
MILLION OUTSTANDING WARRANTS.
ZAMBRANO COUNTY A QUARTER
MILLION OUTSTANDING WARRANTS LA
COUNTY TWO POINT ONE MILLION
OUTSTANDING WARRANTS.
PEOPLE SHOW UP AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE REAL FACT GUSTING
RESPONSIBILITY A SHORT FOR YOUR
COURT DATE.
AND A LOT OF FOLKS JUST DON'T DO
THAT.
IF YOU NEED TO FIX THIS RIGHT
AWAY FIX THAT.
NO IT'S NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO FIX
IT LET'S DO IT RIGHT AND BE
THOUGHTFUL WITH IT SO JUST JAM
IT THROUGH.
GO BACK EIGHTEEN TEN WE'LL FIX
THAT NOW.
NO WONDER KING GONNA FIX IT.
SO I'M AT SOME POINT YOU GOTTA
STOP.
YOU KNOW YOU KEEP HEARING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO FIX THE
THINGS WE'VE DONE SOME GOOD
FIXES FOR OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BUT WE NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
VICTIM'S MOST OF US ARE VICTIMS
IN HERE WE DON'T IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE BEING
AFFECTED.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GO BACK THE
SAME NEIGHBORHOODS WITH THE SAME
CRIME AFFECTING THE SAME GROUP
OF PEOPLE LOT US.
AND THAT'S THE SAD PART ABOUT IT
DEVELOPED THEY GO LIVE WITH IT
AND DEAL WITH THAT.
AND IT'S THE TICKETS ARE COME
HOME TO ROOST ON SOME OF THE
STUFF IS GOING TO COME BACK.
YOU KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
ON IN IN REALLY HAVE GOOD
CONVERSATION I THINK.
THIS BECAUSE VETTED THIS AND AND
TALKED ABOUT IT WILL HAVE SOME
REALLY IN DEPTH DISCUSSIONS WITH
ALL THE INVOLVED PARTIES.
SO PROVISIONS APART THIS
PROVISION WAS NEVER TALKED ABOUT
HOW WE FIX THIS WE GONNA DO.
AND MOST YOUR FOLKS ARE GOING
BACK TO STATE PRISON HERE IN THE
COUNTY JAILS IN THE COUNTY
SYSTEMS.
THE COUNTY SYSTEMS OVER BURDEN
RIGHT NOW YOU SEE LAWSUITS FOR
YOUR COUNTY JAILS ASHER SERIFS
FOR MEDICAL ISSUES WHICH STATE
PRISONS GOT THE COUNTIES GETTING
THAT NOW.
PROBATION SEEING LAWSUIT SO WHAT
WHAT THE STATE PROBLEM NOW IS
TRICKLE DOWN THE COUNTIES AND IF
IT'S NOT GOING TO STOP.
SO I IS MIKE MY HEARTBURN RIGHT
NOW IS WHAT DO WE GIVE MORE
POWERS TO THE JUDGES MORE POWER
THE JUDGES.
THAT STARTED THIS.
THEY RAISE THE BILLS GO BACK AND
YOU GET YOUR BILL SCHEDULE FOR
EACH COUNTY AND SEE HOW THE
BILL'S PROGRESSIVELY INCREASE.
BECAUSE OF JUDGES.
THEY'RE STILL MAKING IT WEARING
CAUCUS AND I ASKED SEE JUSTICE
Y. WORKED WITH.
I TALKED ABOUT IT JUDGES DO
INCREASE THE BILL'S RIGHT YEAH
SHE SHE AGREED JEFF.
AS A PUBLIC THAT NO ONE EVER
TALKED ABOUT IT'S NEVER MITCH
MENTIONED HERE ON THE FLOOR.
OR ANY HEARINGS WITH ME WHEN I
SPOKEN.
TO TOUGH BUT IF TEASING CAUCUS.
SHE WAS DEAF TIAS PEOPLE FILLED
TO APPEAR.
SO YOU GOT TO FIX THOSE THINGS
INTO A RIGHT AND USE EVERYONE'S
GOT AN OPINION AND STUFF BUT IT
TO YOU SEE IT AND LIVE IT.
AND DO SOME THESE FOLKS THAT
HAVE BEEN HURT.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS LISTEN
BAFFLES OTHER PERSON GOOD FOLKS
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOUR TIME IS
UP IF YOU COULD BRING YOUR
COMMON A CLOSED BUT YOU MIGHT MY
THING IS.
LET'S DO IT THOUGHTFULLY WAS TO
RATIONALLY.
AND IN THE LAST YEAR NOW LET'S
HAPPEN WITH THIS SO I URGE YOU
KNOW VOTE ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER RENDON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS JUSTICE IS A JOURNEY AND
SP TEN IS A STEP ON THAT PASS.
I'VE SPOKEN TO A LOT OF US HAVE
SPOKEN SINCE WE GOT HERE ABOUT
ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT COMPLETE DOES
NOT PROVIDE COMPLETE JUSTICE
DOESN'T UP NOT PROVIDE COMPLETE
ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
BUT IT SHOWS THAT WE ARE BENDING
IN THAT DIRECTION.
BY ELIMINATING CASH BAIL WE ARE
SAYING THAT THOSE WITH THE LEAST
ABILITY TO PAY SHOULD NOT BE
INCARCERATED SOLELY BECAUSE OF
THEIR PROPERTY.
CASH IS NOT THE MEASURE OF ANY
WOMAN OR ANY MAN.
AND ACCESS TO CASH.
IS NO SIGN OF CHARACTER.
WE ALSO NEED ONLY LOOK IN THAT
DIRECTION FOR A MINOR THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP FIXING OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM. TO BE FAIR.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR INCOME.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT IT
PROVIDES IN FACT.
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
WE CAN BE THE ARCHITECTS OF THE
ARC TOWARD JUSTICE.
THERE IS MUCH TO DO.
AND S. B. TED IS A START.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B..
TEN THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE HAVING CEASED TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE RICH
DISCUSSION THE COMMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES.
A LOT OF THE COMMENTS.
WHAT WERE MADE?
A YEAR AGO WHEN WE HAD A ROBUST
CONVERSATION AS WELL ON AND I I
APPRECIATE THOSE AND I THINK
THAT'S A SIGN THAT.
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS WE'VE
BEEN DEBATING IT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING EACH OTHER WE'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO EACH OTHER.
YOU KNOW THE WHEN SOMEONE WAS
SAYING THAT THIS IS BEEN RUSHED
[inaudible]
IT WAS.
YOU KNOW I WAS HAVE FLASHBACKS
--
OF ALL THE THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
MEETINGS THAT I'VE BEEN IN.
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
BEEN AT THE TABLE.
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS TO CIVIL
LIBERTARIAN GROUPS TO THE COURTS
TO PROBATION.
LAST YEAR WHEN WE DISCUSS THIS.
MANY OF YOU SAID HEY LET'S WAIT
FOR THE OF JUSTICE'S REFORM
WORKGROUP. TO COME OUT WITH
THEIR REPORT [inaudible]
CHECK.
WE DID THAT.
WE LISTEN TO IT.
EVEN COOPERATED THE COMMENTS IN
THE INSIDE AND THE INPUT FROM
THAT WORK GROUP REPORT INTO THIS
BILL.
SOME OF YOU SAID I'M CONCERNED
THAT LONG FORSMAN.
IS OPPOSED AND THEY'RE NOT BEING
HEARD.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO TALK
MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS
[inaudible]
CHECK.
WE WE DID THAT.
I HEARD A COMMENT.
IN DISCUSSION THAT LOTS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SHARE SOME
AROUND THE STATE ARE AGAINST
THIS BILL.
SO LET'S BIG LET'S JUST BE
REQUIRE [inaudible]
JUDICIAL COUNCIL SUPPORTS.
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IS NEUTRAL.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION [inaudible]
IS NEUTRAL.
CALIFORNIA SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
IS NEUTRAL.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE LOTS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS AND THE
SHERIFF THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE.
BUT THOSE ARE THE OFFICIAL
POSITIONS ON THIS BILL AND TO
THE EXTENT [inaudible]
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS [inaudible]
ARE.
TRYING TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN JUSTICE AND
SAFETY AND ARE LOOKING UP FOR
COMMUNITY SAFETY THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SO.
THIS IS BEEN ANYTHING BUT RUSHED
AND WE'VE HAD STAKEHOLDERS FROM.
ALL OVER THE THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM.
EXPERIENCE WILL SPECTRUM
INVOLVED IN DISCUSSIONS OVER
THOUSANDS OF THOUSANDS OF HOURS
AND IT HUNDRED TO MEETINGS.
THE COST WAS MENTIONED.
IT IS NOT INEXPENSIVE. TO CREATE
A FAIRER MORE JUST SYSTEM THAT
RELIES ON PRE TRIAL SERVICES IN
A RISK ASSESSMENT TO ON THE
FRONT END.
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM SOME OF THE
BEST COUNTIES THAT HAVE DONE
THIS THAT IF MEN AT THIS WE
DON'T NEED PILOTS WE'VE HAD
PILOTS.
WE'VE HAD SANTA CLARA DOING THIS
WE'VE HAD SAN FRANCISCO DOING
THIS WE'VE HAD SANTA CRUZ DOING
THIS.
ALMOST FORTY COUNTIES ARE USING
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND RELY
ON THEM.
SO THIS IS NOT TIME FTA TO TO
FOR A PILOT.
IT'S TIME TO TAKE THE LEARNING
TO THE TEACHINGS OF WHAT WORKS
ON THE GROUND EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIA.
AND BRING IT STATEWIDE IT'S
READY FOR PRIMETIME NOW.
WE ALSO TOUCH SOMEONE TALKED
ABOUT DETENTIONS.
THERE'S GONNA BE MORE THAT'S
GOING TO BE LESS.
IS ANY LESS.
SO TO BE UNSAFE OTHER NATIVE
PEOPLE ARE GONNA GET RELEASED.
AND HURT US.
LET ME MORE IT'S UNFAIR TO GET
HER TO REPUBLICAN.
COLLEAGUE INVOKING ACLU FIRST
TIME FOR THAT WHILE [inaudible]
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS.
IT RELEASES THOSE WHO CAN SAFELY
BE RELEASED.
IT HAS APPROPRIATE TENSED
DETENTIONS.
IT REDUCES AND SIX TO ELIMINATE.
INAPPROPRIATE DETENTIONS WHICH
IS THE HALLMARK OF THE CURRENT.
ATTENTIONS BASED ON MONEY.
ARE ARE WRONG.
NOW WE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE.
EVALUATED FOR YOUR SAFETY RISK.
AND IF YOU CANNOT REALLY SAY
THINK COMMUNITY.
YOU WON'T BE.
IF YOU CAN THEN YOU SHOULD BE
AND YOU WILL BE.
UNDER THE SPELL.
A LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT I'VE
HEARD.
SEEM TO BE ANIMATED BY.
A A COMMITMENT TO THE STATUS
QUO.
BUT JUST BECAUSE IT'S BEEN THAT
WAY.
EVEN FOR A LONG TIME DOESN'T
MEAN HOUSE TO CONTINUE TO BE
THAT WAY.
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S A BROKEN
SYSTEM AN UNFAIR SYSTEM.
AND ON SAY SIMPSON.
AND YES CHANGE REQUIRES COURAGE.
REQUIRES LEADERSHIP AND REQUIRES
US TO BE BOLD.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING YOU.
TO BE TODAY WE CAN'T BE
PARALYZED BY THE FEAR CHANGE
HEARD SO MY COLLEAGUES SAY THAT
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
WE ARE STARING IN THE FACE
[inaudible]
THE OPPORTUNITY ROOM AGREES IS A
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN CSUS.
AND TO SQUANDER THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
WILL BE WRONG WE NEED TO SEIZE
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
YOU COULDN'T PICK AT THIS BILL
ALL YOU WANT.
THE PERFECTION NOT BE THE ENEMY
OF THE GOOD.
THIS IS GOOD.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
WE CAN IMPROVE IT OVER TIME ALSO
BECAUSE NOTHING'S PERFECT A
PERFECT SHOULD BE THE
ASPIRATION.
BUT THIS IS A GOOD BILL THAT
WHAT AND THE SUFFERING.
THE ANGUISH THE PAIN THE
VICTIMIZATION.
THAT HAS COME FROM THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
WITH THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
UNFAIRLY.
CAR SERRATED FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN AT BEEN PUT AT RISK BECAUSE
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS UNSAFE.
S. B. TENNIS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
THE FAIR THING TO DO.
THE SAFE THING TO DO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB [inaudible]
TEN THANK YOU.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
HOW MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE?
BOTTOM CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE A
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES.
HIGHS FORTY ONE NO TWENTY SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
SOME MEMBERS.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
MOVE OUT OF FOURTEEN S. B. FIVE
THIRTY NINE DE LEN TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IF YOU ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RISK SEND THE ACTION
WHERE VIOLENCE SCENE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE ASSEMBLY READ FOR A
THIRD TIME.
PASSED S. B.. TWENTY NINE
MCGUIRE AND SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
BERRYHILL TO THE SENATE I ASK
ABOUT THE BILL'S BE PLACED ON
THE THIRD RING FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM THREE
EIGHTY TWO S. B. NINE SEVENTY
ATKINS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO SET US
BEFORE SIXTY DE LEN. FOR THE
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY THIRD
HEARING PENNY RE REFER A FROM
THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE.
SOME MEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED WE OPPOSE THE MOTION
THEN ASK FOR ALL CALL.
THANK YOU METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
MISTER GIBSON SECOND THE MOTION
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS REQUESTING AN
AYE VOTE MS WALTERS REQUESTING A
NO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BENEFIT CAN MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY NO TWENTY FIVE THE MOTION
PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ORDER ITEM.
THREE FIFTEEN ITEM THREE SIX
TEAM SP TWELVE HUNDRED MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE HUNDRED WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE AMBER
GETS AND SOME MEMBER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF I
RISE TO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL.
TWELVE HUNDRED A BY CENTER
SKINNER OF THESE AMENDMENTS
REFLECTS COMPROMISE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BY REMOVING
UNFINISHED FRAMES AND RECEIVERS.
OF FROM THIS BILL I ASK THAT THE
AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED AND THAT
THE MEASURE BE PLACED BACK IN
WILL REPLACE ON OF A PRINCE AND
BACK ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL OF THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS BACK TO PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE ITEMS.
THREE SEVENTEEN THROUGH THREE
THIRTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN ITEM
THREE THIRTY SEVEN SP ONE SIXTY
FIVE MATTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
HOLDEN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED --
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SP ONE SIXTY FIVE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR.
PORTANTINO WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT
THE INCREASE OF RENT TO THE SIX
NONPROFITS WHO READ.
NON RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY LOCATED ON THE STATE'S.
SEVEN TEN AND THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS IS THE
CLEAN UP BILL TO SP FOUR HUNDRED
FROM LAST YEAR TO ENSURE ALL
APPROPRIATE PROPERTIES IN MY
COMMUNITY ARE PROTECTED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
.
MISTER HOLDEN WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY AS AMENDMENTS MISTER
HOLDEN.
WELL I'M JUST
.
MEMBERS I BEG YOUR PARDON MISTER
HOLDEN.
READ THE CORRECT BILL SO I
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS BACK THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE ITEMS.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH THREE
FORTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN ITEM
THREE FORTY SEVEN S. B..
ELEVEN OH EIGHT MADAM COURT
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN AWAY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A PRESENTIMENT THAT
S. B. ELEVEN AWAIT AUTHORED BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ THE AMENDMENTS
PERMIT DE EIGHT CS. TO SEEK
FEDERAL WAIVERS THAT ARE IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE GOAL OF MEDI
CAL WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL HAS A COALITION OF
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT AN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS MEMBERS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SIGNIFY BY
SAYING NAME.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVEN SEVEN POINT TO I AM
RE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE ITEM THREE THIRTY
SEVEN SP ONE SIXTY FIVE TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ITEMS THREE FORTY EIGHT THREE
FORTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN ITEM
THREE FIFTY S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN ADEQUATE PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TOLD EIGHTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
WHAT.
SOME A MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THE COMMITTEE SPEAKER
MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS DELETE
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
DEALING WITH ADDITIONAL PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND TREATMENT
AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS ON EP
STT.
SERVICES AND CLARIFY THAT EP ES
DE TT FOLLOW UP TREATMENT MUST
STILL BE PROVIDED ASK YOU
MINUSCULE DOT THAT BILL GO OUT
PRINT BACK OUT ON FILE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL WAS UP TO PRINT A BACK ON
FILE ITEMS A THREE FIFTY ONE
THROUGHS THREE SIXTY ONE PASS
AND RETAIN.
ITEM A THREE SIXTY TWO S. B.
EIGHT NINETEEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETEEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN THINK
YOU'RE SOME MEMBER EGGMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TAKE YOUR SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF PRESENTING S. B.
EIGHT NINETEEN FROM THE HILL FOR
AMENDMENTS TO GO BACK ON FILE.
HAVING TO DO WITH UTILITIES.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE AYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
FILE.
ITEMS THREE SIXTY THREE THROUGH
SIX SIXTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM THREE SIXTY SIX S. B. TEN
THIRTY SIX MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
CYNICAL TEN THIRTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
HOLDEN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SP TEN THIRTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WILK.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AND FOR EXCESS OF
ACCESS. TO INFORMATION WHILE
ENSURING THAT SENSITIVE
INFORMATION IS NOT.
DISCLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
ABOUT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSE IF I BY SAYING
NAY THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS HOW TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH THREE
EIGHTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE TO COMMITTEE
MEETINGS UPON ADJOURNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND ROOM
FOR FORTY FOUR NATURAL RESOURCES
IN A ROOM.
FOR FORTY SEVEN THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
AUGUST TWENTY FIRST.
CHECK IN SESSIONAND FLOOR
SESSION UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER.
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY SECOND
CHECK IN SESSION AND FLOOR
SESSION UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER.
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY THIRD TEN
A. M..
FLOOR SESSION.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
FORM BECAUSE LIFTED AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THE JOURNEY MEMORY
MEMBERS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR AND GIVE YOUR RESPECT. TO
THOSE MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF CAROLINE WOULD
RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO.
WHO DIED ON JUNE NINETEENTH
UNEXPECTEDLY THIS YEAR?
CAROLINE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY ONE AND WAS BEST KNOWN FOR
FOUNDING THE GATEWAY SUMMER
SCHOOL IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THE GATEWAY
SUMMER SCHOOL IS A NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED SCHOOL GEARED
TOWARD PROVIDING UNIQUE AND
CHALLENGING DIVERSE.
ENRICHING EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES FOR CHILDREN FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS AND ABILITIES
FROM GRADES ONE THROUGH.
TWELVE SHE STARTED THE SCHOOL
FIRST ON A VOLUNTEER BASIS WITH
A GROUP OF PARENT VOLUNTEERS WHO
WERE LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR CHILDREN.
AND ALL CHILDREN HAD GREAT
ENRICHING SUMMER ACTIVITIES --
DURING THE SUMMER SEASON.
AND SHE PER FOUGHT TO PROVIDE
STIMULATING AND ENRICHING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
I'M GIFTED KIDS ARE ADVANCED
KIDS -- FOR
WHOM THOSE PROGRAMS ARE NOT
GENERALLY PROVIDED ANYMORE IN
OUR SCHOOLS.
AND THAT PROGRAM WENT ON TO
BECOME THE FOUNDATION OF A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
OF THAT HAS SERVED HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS AND I BELIEVE THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN IN THE SAN DIEGO
AREA --
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF ATTENDING
HER MEMORIAL SERVICE.
AND SAW THAT.
SHE HAD ALUMNI FROM HER GATEWAYS
PROGRAM WHO HAD BEEN INVOLVED
FOR MANY MANY YEARS FIRST AS
STUDENTSAND THEN AS STAFF.
AND INSTRUCTORS IN HELPING
HANDS.
ALL COME TOGETHER AND TELL THEIR
TESTIMONIALS OF THE DIFFERENCE
THAT SHE MADE IN THEIR LIFE FOR
THE ENRICHING PROGRAM SHE WAS
ABLE TO PROVIDE.
AND THE WAY SHE DID IT SHE
OPERATED THE PROGRAM FROM HER
HOME.
AND IT WAS HER ON IT WAS HER
BABY ALONG WITH HER FOR TERRIFIC
KIDS.
I TOOK GREAT PRIDE IN THEM AND
HER CHILDREN.
AND THEIR GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY A BEAUTIFUL
FAMILY FOUR CHILDREN KATHRYN
GREGORY JENNIFER AND SUZANNE.
HER BROTHER DOUGLAS HER SISTER
ALICE AS WELL AS FOUR NIECES TWO
NEPHEWS AND SIX BEAUTIFUL
GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED
THROUGHOUT THE SAN DIEGO AREA
FOR THEIR TERRIFIC SUMMER SCHOOL
THAT SHE PROVIDED SHE I WAS ALSO
SOMEONE THAT I KNEW --
SHE PROVIDED SOME WONDERFUL
CRAFTS AND AT MY WEDDING --
EYES ARE AS OUR WEDDING FAVORS
AND SHE DID BECAUSE SHE HAD
EVERY SINGLE CRAFT SUPPLY YOU
CAN POSSIBLY IMAGINE IN HER
HOME.
THAT SHE MADE AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR ESPECIALLY
DURING THE GATEWAYS PROGRAM.
AND SO MEMBERS I'D GREATLY
APPRECIATE I'M HONORING CAROLINE
WHICH MEMORY TODAY BY TURNING IN
HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY THREE S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTEEN FROM NO TO AYE.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTEEN NOTES I THANK YOU
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
OTHER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A
MEMBERS ARE AYE RISE WITH A
HEAVY HEART TODAY. TO DO AN
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY OF DOCTOR DON
BELLOTTO BOLLAND.
THAT THEIR GENERATION STOCK TONY
IN.
A HISTORIAN ACTIVISTS A BUT MOST
OF ALL THE SOUTH SIDE GROW.
AND SHE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
STOCKTON.
I WERE HER FAMILY SETTLED A
DURING THE NINETEEN TWENTIES --
SHE RECENTLY WENT TO ACCEPT A
BOB MEDAL OF HONOR FOR HER
FATHER FOR FIGHTING IN WORLD WAR
TWO WHEN HE FIRST CAME FROM THE
PHILIPPINES.
AND WHILE HER FAMILY HAS BEEN
HERE FOR GENERATIONS IT WAS
STRIKING TO HER THAT IT TOOK HER
GOING AWAY TO COLLEGE TO
UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF
FILIPINOS IN CALIFORNIA.
SHE KNEW ABOUT CESAR CHAVEZ IN
SCHOOL --
BUT SHE HAD NO IDEA WHO VERY
YOUNG WAS A AND IT WAS AMAZING
TO HER THAT SHE HAD TO GO TO WAY
TO UNDERSTAND THESE THINGS AND
THEREBY STARTED A LIFETIME --
OF ACTIVISM --
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE THAT HISTORY
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE --
SHE WAS IMPORTANT FOR HER TO NOW
DATA ALL FILIPINOS THAT THEIR
CULTURE WAS MORE THAN --
DANCING AND LIBYA --
AND GOOD FESTIVALS THAT IT ALSO
HAD TO DO WITH THE HISTORY THAT
MADE CALIFORNIA GREAT.
BUT SHE WAS A TENURED PROFESSOR
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
HER PASSION WAS SOMETHING CALLED
A LITTLE MEANT MIDDLE FOUNDATION
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN
WITH THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES I
SHOULD SAY WHEN.
WE DECIDE TO CONNECT THE NINETY
NINE WITH THE FIVE WE GET ACROSS
TOWN.
RIGHT ACROSS THE MIDDLE OF
LITTLE MANILA CHINATOWN AND
WHERE LITTLE LATINOS LIVED.
AND THEREBY DESTROYED A
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT WAS A HOME TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
WHEN IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE SHE
DECIDED THEY SHOULD DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT THEY SHOULD BRING
AWARENESS TO IT SO HER AND HER
CLASSMATE DILLON DELVAUX?
AS CREATE SOMETHING CALLED
LITTLE MANILA --
SINCE THEN SHE HAS WRITTEN A
NUMBER OF ONE IS A LITTLE MANILA
IS IN THE HEART. ONE FILIPINOS
--
IN STOCKTON.
AND SHE WAS AND THE PRIDE AND
JOY OF THE COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO GIVE A
PRESENTATION.
I AM AT THE UNITED STATES
COMMISSION ON CIVIL RIGHTS IN DC
ENTITLE REMEMBERING FILIPINO
HISTORY IN ITS INTERSECTION WITH
CIVIL RIGHTS.
SHE IS SCHEDULED TO DO THAT ON
AUGUST EIGHTEENTH WHICH WOULD
HAVE BEEN HER FORTY SIXTH
BIRTHDAY.
SHE WAS ON VACATION WITH HER
FAMILY CELEBRATING ONE LAST TIME
BEFORE THEY ALL WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL --
AND SUDDENLY DIED WHILE ENJOYING
HERSELF AND SPENDING TIME WITH
HER FAMILY.
HER LOSS OF HIS VIBRATED ACROSS
OUR COMMUNITY.
WE MOURN HER AND WE KNOW THAT
HER ACTIVISM HER ADVOCACY HER
WORK WILL LIVE ON WE KNOW THAT
SHE'S PROVIDE A FOUNDATION. FOR
OTHERS IN THE COMMUNITY TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF
FILIPINOS FILIPINO AMERICANS --
SHE TOLD STORIES ABOUT NOT
KNOWING A LOT ABOUT THE HISTORY
BUT IN DOING ORAL HISTORIES AND
TALKING WITH PEOPLE AND REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT STOCKTON WAS THE
PLACE. FOR FILIPINOS BACK IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES AND PEOPLE
COULD DRIVE UP AND DOWN EL
DORADO BOULEVARD AND SEE WHO IS
COMING FROM LOS ANGELES.
OR FROM SAN FRANCISCO --
AND KNOW THAT STOCKTON WAS
REALLY THE PLACE WHERE ALL THOSE
THINGS WERE GOING ON AT NINETEEN
CALL THAT A SONG ABOUT THAT TIME
CALLED REMEMBERING YOU.
AND WE REMEMBER YOU AND IN TO
GALLAUDET'S PRONOUNCED
[inaudible]
DALE CYO.
AND SO TO DOCTOR DON THE
ACTIVISTS THE ACADEMIC THE
WRITER.
THE SOUTH SIDE GIRL FROM
STOCKTON [inaudible]
DIAL CYO.
Q. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
BUT THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
UP MEMBERS.
A TODAY POWER.
PLEASED TO UP.
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY. FOR RETIRED FRESNO CITY
FIRE CAPTAIN LINNELL.
DONNIE.
WE ALL KNEW EN MASSE ONIH.
ONLY JOINED THE FRESNO CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE
GRADUATED WITH THE FIRST EVER
FRESNO PARAMEDIC CLASS IN
[inaudible] NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE ONLY SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
FRESNO FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES
ON THE DEPARTMENTS SPECIALIZED
URBAN SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAM.
AFTER FORTY ONE YEARS WITH THE
FRESNO CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
CAPTAIN DIRTY RETIRED IN JUNE OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN HE REALLY DID
DEEPLY LOVE THE FIRE SERVICE AND
HE PROVED IT IN YEARS AFTER HIS.
RETIREMENT BY CONTINUING TO
TRAIN FRESNO CITY FIRE RECRUITS.
AS WELL AS TEACH AT THE FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE FIRE ACADEMY.
WE OFTEN SAY ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
LIKE THIS THAT HE WAS SO KIND
AND GENEROUS THAT HE WOULD.
GIVE YOU THE SHIRT OFF OF THEIR
BACK.
BALONEY ACTION ACTUALLY DID
THAT.
GIVING UP HIS SHIRT. TO A
STRANGER.
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF FIGHTING
THE FIRE.
ONLY WAS STEADFAST IN HIS
COMMITMENT TO THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
THE PEOPLE HE SERVED UNTIL.
THE VERY END OF HIS LIFE HE
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY.
AT HIS HOME IN FRESNO ON JULY
TWENTIETH. TWENTY EIGHT TEAM.
AND WITH HIS BELOVED WIFE
DELORES.
AND HIS DOGS HE DEARLY LOVED AS
WELL.
BY HIS SIDE.
WE ALL MISS ONLY VERY MUCH.
BUT THE HE LIVED OUT HIS FIRE
SERVICE.
SO WELL THAT HE HAS --
A LEGACY AROUND.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WE ARE.
MINDFUL OF THE LIFE THAT WAS SO
WELL LIVED AND SO IN A MOMENT OF
SADNESS WE REMEMBER.
ONLY IN THE VERY SPECIAL MAN AND
FIREFIGHTER THAT HE WAS
APPRECIATE [inaudible]
A THIS BODY ADJOURNMENT IN HIS
MEMORY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SUMMER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON IN RISING TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF DON.
MAMULAN WHO SPENT HER LIFE
EDUCATING AND FIGHTING. FOR HER
COMMUNITY SHE WAS BORN ON THE
SOUTH SIDE OF STOCK INTO.
IMMIGRANTS FROM THE PHILIPPINES
AND SHE WAS SUMMONED THE
FILIPINO COMMUNITY WAS SO PROUD
OF SHE WAS AN AUTHOR.
AND A SCHOLARSHIP IS DEDICATED
TO PRESERVING OUR COMMUNITIES
HISTORY SHE DETAILED THE STORY
OF LITTLE MANILA.
IN HER OWN HOMETOWN AND I
ACTUALLY HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH DON WE
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF THE
MANILA TOWN HERITAGE FOUNDATION
TOGETHER [inaudible]
AND WE WERE ABLE TO COLLECTIVELY
TURN OUR VISION OF PRESERVING
FILIPINO HISTORY AND CULTURE.
INTO A REALITY WITH HER
LEADERSHIP AND HER PASSION.
SHE CONTINUED.
TO SUPPORT ME AND SHE WAS
SOMEONE I RELIED ON EVEN AS I
CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING PASS AB.
ONE TWENTY THREE A BILL THAT I
PASSED MY ANOTHER AUTHORED IN
THAT WAS PASSED WITH THE SUPPORT
OF MANY IN THIS FLORA MY FIRST
YEAR REQUIRED CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO TEACH.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF FILIPINO
AMERICANS TO THE CALIFORNIA FARM
LABOR MOVEMENT.
AS SHE CLIMBED THE RANKS.
IN ACADEMIA HAS A TENURED
PROFESSOR AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
SHE NEVER FORGOT.
WHO SHE WAS [inaudible]
STRONG FILIPINA.
FROM SOUTH STOCKTON.
HER LEGACY WILL CONTINUE ON
THROUGH HER EMPOWERING WORKING
ACADEMICS HER WRITINGS AND HER
ACTIVE AS ACTIVISM AS WELL AS
THROUGH ALL OF HER FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
WHO CONTINUED TO LOVE HER DEARLY
AND MISS HER DEARLY I ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF JOHN MODEL?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
YES MADAM SPEAKER OUT MEMBERS
ARE RISE --
WHO JOINED IN MEMORY AND ASK%
THAT WE WOULD ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF THE QUEEN OF SOUL?
READ THE FRANKLIN.
YOU KNOW IT'S SAD MY HEART LAST
THURSDAY WHEN I WOKE UP AND
DISCOVERED THAT EVERYTHING WAS
GONE.
I KNEW THAT SHE WAS ILL.
AND IT WOULD JUST BE A MATTER OF
TIME.
BUT THIS IS A WOMAN WHO'S BEEN A
PART OF MY LIFE SEEMS LIKE ALL
OF MY LIFE.
HER MUSIC HAS REALLY SHAPED MY
SPIRIT AND MY SOUL.
AND HAS MOTIVATED ME EVEN BEYOND
THE CAPACITY THAT I BELIEVED
AHEAD.
HER SONGS LIKE RESPECT.
IF YOU ONE TO DO RIGHT WOMAN YOU
GOTTA BE A DO RIGHT MAN. TO GIVE
YOU MISSION AND PURPOSE IN YOUR
LIFE.
SHE BEGAN SINGING JUST AS A
CHILD SHE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY TWO IN MEMPHIS TENNESSEE.
AND SHE BEGAN SINGING IN HER
FATHER'S CHURCH IN DETROIT.
SHE SANG WITH THE FAMOUS MAHALIA
JACKSON AND SO MANY OTHERS.
SHE TAUGHT HERSELF HOW TO PLAY
THE PIANO.
AND THEN SHE LEARNED TO READ
SHEET MUSIC AND BEGAN TO COMPOSE
SONGS ARE SELF.
SHE WAS TRULY A MUSICAL GENIUS.
SHE BEGAN SINGING AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN AND SO SHE SPENT OVER
SIXTY YEARS.
AS AN ARTIST.
NOT JUST SOMEONE WE KNEW ABOUT
SOMEONE WAS AN ACTIVE SINGER FOR
SIXTY YEARS WHOSE VOICE WAS JUST
A STRONG THE BASS HE PASSED.
AS WHEN SHE FIRST BEGAN TO SING.
SHE ALSO WASN'T NOTED FOR THE
FACT THAT SHE OF HIM THAT WHEN
SHE FOUND A SONG.
AND SANG THAT SONG THE ARTIST
PROBABLY DIDN'T WANT TO SING IT
AGAIN.
LIKE NATURAL WOMAN.
BECAUSE AT THAT POINT SHE OWNED
THAT SONG AND SHE BECAME THAT
PERSON.
AND SHE GAVE THAT SONG AS MOST
ARTISTS SAID NEW LIFE AND NEW
MEANING TO THE SONG ITSELF.
SHE WAS BRILLIANT.
IN HER MUSICAL ABILITIES.
MOST OF US WERE STUNNED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN WHEN SHE
SANG THE OPERA [inaudible]
A PAPARAZZI.
SHE'D BEEN ONLY ASKS THAT DAY IF
SHE THOUGHT SHE COULD STAND IN
FOR HIM.
BECAUSE HE COULD MAKE IT.
AND SHE SAID WELL LET ME LISTEN
TO IT.
LET ME HEAR IT.
AND SHE LISTENED TO IT.
AND SHE SANG IT AND ALL OF US
WERE IN AWE.
OF THIS WOMAN'S ABILITY TO SING
ANY TYPE OF MUSIC.
WEATHER WAS WHAT THOSE GOSPEL
WHETHER IT WAS JAZZ WHAT WAS
BLUES WITH ROCK AND ROLL SHE
COULD MASTER THAT SONG AND GIVE
IT NEW LIFE.
AND SO WE WERE ALL SHOCKED WHEN
I SAW ON TELEVISION I WAS A
MAYES.
THE GRANTED AT THE GRAMMYS
SINGING THIS SONG THAT YOU'D
ONLY BEEN ASKED TO SING THAT DAY
THAT MANY ARTISTS WOULD TAKE A
LIFETIME TO LEARN TO MASTER.
SHE WAS AN ACTIVIST WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT ACTIVISTS THE DAY SOMEONE
ASKED ME YOU KNOW IS IT UNUSUAL
THAT ACTIVISTS ARE NOW STEPPING
OUT AND SAYING BEINGS IN
FIGHTING FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AND I HAD TO REMIND THE BUT SO
MANY OF THE ARTISTS BEFORE THE
ONES WE KNOW TODAY DID THAT.
DISSIPATED ACTIVELY IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND SHE DID.
SHE GOT PERMISSION FROM HER
FATHER TO TRAVEL WOULD DOCTOR
KING INTO SAYING IT ALL OF HIS
RALLIES BECAUSE SHE BELIEVES SO
STRONGLY IN WHAT HE WAS DOING.
AND KNEW IT WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN HER LIFE AND LIFE
AND OTHERS TO COME.
SHE DONATED MONEY INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH AND WAS WILLING TO BELLA
ANGELA DAVIS OUT OF JAIL WHEN
ANGELA DAVIS WAS IN JAIL BUT SHE
FELT THIS IS TO DESERVE JUSTICE
AND SHE DESERVED TO BE FREE.
SHE WAS NOTED IN SOLVE MANY
OTHER KINDS OF WAYS THAT IT'S
AMAZING TO THINK ABOUT.
THAT SHE WON EVERY AWARD THERE
WAS.
SHE WON SEVERAL GRAMS I THINK
EIGHTEEN GRAMMYS HAD ALL KINDS
OF BEGET A GROUP RECEIVE THE
LEGEND AWARD.
THE KENNEDY CENTER CENTER HONOR
THE STAR OF HOLLYWOOD AWARD SHE
RECEIVED THE THE METAL OF OF
HONOR FROM THE PRESIDENT FROM
CLINTON.
AND TO SIGN FOR PROBABLY FOR
EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND THEY ALL
HAVE IN CONCERTS AND SINGING AND
SHE WAS ACTUALLY CLINTON'S
FAVORITE SINGER.
AND SO CHEAPLY PERFORMED
REGULARLY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE IS NOTED AS A PERSON WHO WAS
KIND AND GENTLE AND INSPIRED SO
MANY YOUNG ARTISTS TO SING IN TO
PERFORM.
AND SHE LEAVES TO MOURN FOUR
SONS AND FOUR GRANDDAUGHTERS
WHO.
USE TO TALK ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD
WALK AT A HOUSE AND SHE WOULD BE
SITTING AT THE PIANO.
PLAYING THE SONGS THAT WOULD
INSPIRE THEM TO DO GREAT THINGS.
RITA WAS MY FAVORITE SINGER.
AND I KNOW THAT WHEN I WOULD
TRAVEL ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHEN I
TRAVEL FROM NEW YORK TO GHANA
FOR EIGHT HOURS I WOULD LISTEN
TO ARETHA WITHOUT STOPPING.
AND SHE WOULD SOMEHOW OF THE
MAKE THE RIDE A WHOLE LOT
SMOOTHER.
AND SHE WOULD ALWAYS MAKE ME
FEEL BETTER WHEN I IN THAT IT.
SOMEONE IS SAID THE QUEEN IS
DEAD.
BUT HER MUSIC LIVES ON AND SO
SHE IT'S PROBABLY NOT A PERSON
IN THIS HOUSE WHO CANNOT THINK
OF THEIR FAVORITE SONG BY
ARETHA.
WHEN I ASK PEOPLE WHAT WAS YOUR
FAVORITE SONG EVERYBODY TELLS ME
DIFFERENT ONES?
I DON'T REMEMBER IN THE DORMS AT
UCLA RESPECT WAS IN EVERY WINDOW
AND EVERY.
HALL WHEN WHEN THE SONG CAME OUT
IN.
SIXTY SEVEN EVERYBODY WANTED TO
LISTEN TO RESPECT.
EVERYBODY WANTED A DO RIGHT
WOMAN.
EVERYONE WANTED I THERE'S NO WAY
FOR ME IS LOVE YOU UNLESS YOU
LET ME LOVE YOU.
A NO WAY.
THOSE SONGS SOMEHOW AND OF THE
NOT ONLY GAVE LIKE.
SHE DID AMAZING THINGS FOR THE
ARTIST AND FOR THE WHOLE CONCEPT
OF BLACK MUSIC IN BLACK HISTORY
IN BLACK FEELING.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DID BLACK
PEOPLE FEEL.
THE EXPRESSIONS OF ARETHA.
EVERY GROUP FELT ARETHA.
AND THERE WAS NOT ONE WHO COULD
NOT IDENTIFY WITH AT LEAST ONE
SONG IF NOT ALL OF HER SONGS
THAT MADE YOU FEEL SO MUCH
BETTER.
A WOMAN OF TREMENDOUS DEPTH AND
SOUL IS GONE.
BUT HER MUSIC LIVES ON AND I ASK
THAT WE NOT ONLY A GERMAN MEMBER
FOR REAP THE BUT WE THINK ABOUT
HER REGULARLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF JURY O'CONNELL. THREE PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY ON JULY
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER
A TWELVE YEAR BATTLE WITH BRAIN
CANCER SHE WAS SIXTY TWO YEARS
OLD. THREE WAS REYES SEMENTARA
THE ELDEST CHILD OF FIVE AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL JURY WORKED.
AS A COURT REPORTER IN VENTURA
BEFORE MEETING AND MARRYING JACK
O'CONNELL.
FORMER STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FORMER STATE
SENATOR AND FORMER STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
IN HER FORTIES AND JURY RETURNED
TO SCHOOL OR EARNING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN ENGLISH.
AND A TEACHING CREDENTIAL AT CAL
POLY STATE UNIVERSITY.
SHE MENTORED IMMIGRANT ADULTS
WHO ARE LEARNING ENGLISH TO
APPLY FOR CITIZENSHIP AND ALSO
WORK WITH THE EDUCATION ABROAD
PROGRAM AT CAL POLY. THREE
ENJOYED ATTENDING SPORTS EVENTS
AND CHICAGO CONCERTS WITH JACK.
TRAVELING READING WRITING AND
SPENDING TIME WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
AFTER HER DIAGNOSES OF WE A
BLAST TRAUMA MULTI FORM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX SHE BECAME A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR BRAIN
TUMOR RESEARCH RAISING FUNDS AND
PARTICIPATING IN SEVERAL
CLINICAL TRIALS AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN SHE WAS
ABORTED THE VISION OF HOPE AWARD
FROM THE NONPROFIT VOICES
AGAINST BRAIN CANCER.
STORY WAS UNKNOWN. FOR HER
COURAGE AND HER GRACE AND HER
QUIET DETERMINATION TO LIVE LIFE
TO THE FULLEST [inaudible]
SPIKE THE DISEASE.
SHE WAS AN INSPIRATION TO ALL
WHO KNEW HER.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
OF FORTY TWO YEARS JACK.
WHO IS JOINING US WITH US?
HERE IN THE GALLERY.
DOCTOR JENNIFER. TWO BROTHERS
DAVID AND DAN CAPUTO. TWO
SISTERS LESLIE ABRAHAM AND TONY
WEEKS SISTER LA NANCY SCHROEDER
AND TEN NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
THANK YOU AND TODAY I ASK THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF DIRECTORY O'CONNELL.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PRES PLEASE AND BRING
THE NAMES THE DESK TO BE PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN A MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE
SO CHANGE.
COULD YOU FROM HERE.
OKAY WITHOUT OBJECTION GO AHEAD
GO QUICK THANK YOU UP PATTERSON
THE FILE.
THREE TEN A BILL S. B. NINE TWO
SIX BERMAN AYE TO A NO.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON SENATE BILL NINE
TWENTY SIX I DUNNO.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GLORIA MOVES AND MISTER
COOLEY SECONDS AT THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
AUGUST TWENTY THIRD AT
NINE LOOK
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE ITEM NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA ON AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE FROM YES
TO NO.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE I TO KNOW.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN KAMLAGER-DOVE A.
B. TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE CHANGE
FROM AN AYE VOTE TO A NON VOTING
[inaudible]
THE CHANGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE AYE NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE CERVANTES S. B.
THIRTY NO TO YES.
BOOK CHANGED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES.
SOME SENATE BILL THIRTY NOTES I
OBERNOLTE FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
NO TO NOT VOTING.
FELT CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN NOTES NOT VOTING